FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS SENATE STAFF WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL THIS THE-
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE- THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ISN'T A HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS. TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CAN USED
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. OUR PANEL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
LA- WILL BE PARTICIPATING FOR
THE USE OF VIDEO CONFERENCE
SERVICE. FOR THE PALACE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING AND ON
MEETING THEMSELVES WHEN THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY AIDED ELIMINATING THE
COSTA FEEDBACK I ASSN EVERY
TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
ONCE RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME BEFORE YOU SPEAK.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISS THE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USED BAY TELECOM SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PRODUCE PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE PLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT. THE
PROPIONIBACTERIUM ONLY MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AMATO RAIDER
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST NHI<c.cyan> THE DEVICE WERE</c>
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE WILL MAKE
TRAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN IN
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS THE CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME. IT IS THE BILL OR JUST
USE OF OUR- LINE IN TECHNOLOGY.
WE ASK THAT EVERYONE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE. NINE THE ISSUES FOR
DISCUSSION ON TODAY'S AGENDA IN
ADDITION TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. TODAY'S VOTE ONLY
CALENDARS EXTENSIVE HOWEVER I
WOULD NOTE THAT MOST OF THE
ITEMS IN THE BOOK ONLY CALENDAR
HAVE BEEN HURT ORIGIN DIES FOR
HIGHER SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR FULL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS. FOR TODAY
THESE HEARING WE WILL BE
HEARING ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND VOTING. I'LL
REPEAT WE- ALL OF THE ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND VOTING. ONCE
WE HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA. WE WILL HAVE ONE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON ANY ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. SUBSEQUENT TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD WILL
VOTE ON AGENDA ITEMS. BEFORE WE
GET INTO THE AGENDA LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL. NIELSEN
THERE BELL BY THE CARRIER
PRESENT DOLLY. AT THE RAZA
HERE- TADO PRESENT LEYVA HERE
MCGUIRE AIR. MELENDEZ MONEY
HERE MORE LOT. MORALE PAN HERE
AW- SKINNER HERE TURN HERE MIKE
OWSKI HERE. SECRETARY NOTICES
THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
COLLEAGUES BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR
DELIBERATIONS TODAY I'M GOING
TO TAKE THE PRIVILEGE OF THE
CHAIRWOMAN SHIP IN ASK THAT WE
ALL OF US FOR A BRIEF MOMENT OF
SILENCE. RECOGNIZING ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIANS. AND RESIDENTS AND
CITIZENS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
WHO HAVE BEEN PLAGUED BY BOTH A
VIRUS IN IGNORANCE I ASKED THAT
WE PAUSE BRIEFLY. IN SILENT
MEDITATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
TODAY THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE IS
MEETING TO TAKE ACTION ON THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE STATE
BUDGET FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR. AS WE ALL KNOW
THIS IS NOT. A NORMAL YEAR BY
ANY MEANS. BEYOND THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL THE WE'RE FACING
BECAUSE OF THE COLD BUT
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC ANDEMIC. OUR ABILITY
TO CARRY OUT THE COMMITTEES
NORMAL BUDGET PROCESS HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED. AND
LET'S SAY THAT WHILE IT'S AN
ABBREVIATED PROCESS. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE COLLEAGUES THE
INTEGRITY OF THE REVIEW AND THE
ANALYSIS HAS BEEN MAINTAINED. I
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
INCOME IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
CHAIRS AND ALL OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
HARD WORK AND COMPLETING THE
HEARINGS OVER THE PAST WEEK. I
ALSO MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE STAFF
FROM BOTH PARTIES AND THE WORK
OF BOTH THE LA OLD OFFICE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EVERYONE HAS STEPPED UP TO THE
PLATE IN A PHENOMENAL WAY.
BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING TO TAKE
PART. IN THE SENATE VERSION OF
THE BUDGET IT'S NOT LOST ON ME
THAT IN THE MIDST OF MANAGING
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD THE
DIFFICULT TASK OF DEVELOPING A
BUDGET THAT PROTECTED. ALL OF
THE BOTTLE SIR THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE STATES RESIDENTS RELY
UPON. WHILE FACING A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL. THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TAKE THE BALANCED
APPROACH IN ADDRESSING THIS
BUDGET SHORTFALL INCLUDING
UTILIZING RESERVES BORROWING
TEMPORARY REVENUES EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS FEDERAL FUNDS. AND A
TRIGGER MECHANISM. THE PROPOSAL
SENATE PLAN USES THE GOVERNOR'S
FRAMEWORK FOR ADDRESSING THE
BUDGET PROBLEM WITH A COUPLE OF
KEY DIFFERENCES WHICH THE LA
ALL WILL FULLY EXPLAINED IN HIS
PRESENTATION. WHAT THE SEVENTY
TWO HOUR RULE AND TIME IT TAKES
TO PREPARE THE BUDGET BILL FOR
A VOTE WE ARE LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS AWAY FROM NEEDING TO
FINALIZE A BUDGET THAT BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR THREE ON IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR CONSTITUTION
DEADLINE OF JUNE FIFTEENTH. WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
IN THAT SHORT TIME. HOWEVER
TODAY IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
GETTING THIS CALL SIR. TO THE
FEELING OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION. AS WE ALL WORK
COLLECTIVELY TOGETHER OVER
THESE COMING DAYS TO REACH A
FINAL AGREEMENT I HOPE THAT THE
PROPOSAL AND IDEAS OF THE
SENATE PUTS FORWARD HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT. PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT COMES TO ADDRESSING THE
BUDGET SHORTFALL IN A MANNER
THAT DOES NOT MAKE ADDITIONS
WORSE FOR ARE VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. LASTLY I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT WE ARE
AWARE THAT THE- BUDGET. WILL
NOT BE OUR LAST ACTION THIS
YEAR. THERE ARE MANY THINGS
THAT WE CANNOT ADDRESS NOW THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THROUGH THE SUMMER. THESE
INCLUDE CONTINUING TO ADDRESS
THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN AND HOPEFULLY
EXPLORING NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS
TO INCREASE REVENUE TO SUPPORT
OUR STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INVITE
SENATOR NIELSEN TO PROVIDE
OPENING REMARKS SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE PUBLIC. AS WE ROLLED INTO
THIS INSTITUTION IN JANUARY IT
LOOKED LIKE IT WOULD BE A-
FAIRLY REASONABLE YEAR THERE
WERE EVEN SOME HOPES. NOW THEY
HAVE BEEN DASHED AND NOW WE'VE
GOT MUCH MORE TO GRAPPLE WITH.
ONE OF THE GREATEST
DIFFICULTIES HAS BEEN THE
CONTRACTION OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THE COLLAPSE OF THE
WORK OF THE SUBCOMMITTEES WOULD
BE OVER A PERIOD OF MONTHS HAS
BEEN NOW COLLAPSED IN JUST A
FEW HOURS IN ONE COMMITTEE.
DOES IT LIMIT THE DEPTH OF
SCRUTINY AND OVERSIGHT THAT WE
NORMALLY CAN EXERT. SO THE CALL
TO US IS TO BE VIGILANT AS WE
REVIEW WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY.
AND THEN WHERE WE WILL BE GOING
AS HIS BUDGET MOVES OUGHT. THAT
IS A CHALLENGE. MAYBE NOT AS
MUCH AS PREVIOUSLY BUT YET IN
THIS BUDGET WE WILL BE DEALING
WITH NOW ARE SOME MAJOR MAJOR
POLICY DECISIONS. THAT REALLY
WILL NOT BE SUBJECTED TO THE
KIND OF SCRUTINY AND REVIEW.
THAT THEY WARRANT AND DEMAND.
AND WE TRY TO POINT THOSE OUT
WHEREVER WE CAN. THE BURDEN IS
GREAT. BECAUSE THEY HILL WE
HAVE TO CLIMB. IS ALSO GREAT.
AS WE PROCEED HERE I WOULD
ADMONISHES TO KEEP IN MIND. NOT
JUST KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD. BUT THE STRUCTURAL
CHANGES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED. US TO GET BACK ON
SOUND FOOTING NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE ECONOMY. AND I
WOULD ARGUE HERE YET AGAIN AS
BEFORE WHEN WE HAD THE-
RECESSION. WE DIDN'T DO ENOUGH
TO ADDRESS STRUCTURAL CONCERNS.
BUT WE DID QUITE A LOT. IN THAT
PART OF IT ACTUALLY WAS ABOUT
THE ONLY PART THAT FELT GOOD.
IT APPEARS TO ME AND THIS.
BUDGET THAT WE'RE MOVING AHEAD
WITH NOW. SOME OF THAT GOOD IS
GOING TO BE UNDONE. IN OTHER
WORDS EXACERBATING OUR
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM RATHER THAN
FURTHER ALLEVIATING. WE NEED TO
BE AWARE OF THAT. THEN IN SOME
CASES ACTUALLY ROLLING BACK
DECADES. OF CHANGE AND REFORM
THAT HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
THAT I WILL BE TO SOME DEGREE
COMPROMISED I FEAR. IN THE
BUDGET BEFORE US. YET AGAIN AS
AT OTHER TIMES WHEN WE FACE
THESE GREAT CHALLENGES. WE HAVE
COME TOGETHER REASONABLY. AND
DONE THE BEST WE CAN. IS THAT
ALL WE CAN ASK. NO WE SHOULD
ASK EVEN MORE OF OURSELVES. AND
BE MINDFUL AS WE- DELIBERATE.
AND DISCUSS DEBATE AND VOTE.
NOT WHAT IS FOR US TOMORROW.
MANY THINGS WE WILL BE VOTING
ON. WELL AFFECTED GENERATIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA. WELL THE HARDEST
THINGS FOR US HERE TO DO. WHAT
KIND OF A ME NOW ME FIRST
SOCIETY ANYMORE GENERALLY. AND
THE DEMANDS OF THE PROCESS AND
THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE
HAVE. DO MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
ENVISION THE FUTURE IMPACT OF
THAT WHICH WE ARE VOTING ON. OR
ALTERING. OR DEBATING OR
SUPPORTING TODAY. AND I ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO THINK ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THIS. ON THE
GRAND CHILDREN TO THE FUTURE.
WHERE I WOULD THEN CIRCLE BACK
TO THE NEED TO NOT FORGET THE
CONSTRUCTIVE THINGS WE'VE DONE
TO ASSIST US IN THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT. AND LET ME CLOSE ON A
NOTE. PROPOSITION ONE THE RAINY
DAY FUND. WHAT IS BROADLY
OPPOSE. BUT IT GOT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND IS SURVIVED THE TIMES IN
THIS DONE ITS JOB. THE RAINY
DAY FUND HAS SERVED. TO
CONSTRAIN A BIT. LEGISLATIVE
SPENDING THAT BUILD THE BASE.
THAT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN I
BELIEVE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT.%
AND HELPFUL AND THEN THAT WE
HAD A RAINY DAY FUND. AS WELL
AS ENVISIONED. THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. HAS BEEN
QUESTION. S. WAGED A LITTLE BIT
MAYBE EVEN MORE THAN A LITTLE
BIT. THE MESSAGE IN THAT IT IS
WELL TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE. IT
IS WELL TO QUESTION AND LIBERTY
STEPS. AND IT IS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL NEEDS TO
ENSURE FUTURE BUDGET DID NOT
BECOME SO IMBALANCED. THOSE
pCAPABILITY CERTAIN SITUATIONS
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
GLOBALLY RIGHT NOW. NOT SO MUCH.
BUT I WELCOME AND THE
DELIBERATION WITH YOU. WE HAD A
GOOD YEAR END DELIBERATIONS SO
FAR TO GET US TO TODAY. AS THE
VOTE TODAY LET'S ALSO THINK
SIMULTANEOUSLY ABOUT TOMORROW
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR
COLLEAGUES WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN THE WORK. THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN DEBATING OUR STATE
BUDGET OUR COLLEAGUES I'M GOING
TO BEGIN. BY AYE IN A FINE
SOME. VOTE ONLY ITEMS THAT THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IS HALF THE
REMOVED FROM BOTH ONLY AND ADD
IT TO THE DISCUSSION SECTION SO
YOU ALL NEED TO UPDATE YOUR OWN
AGENDAS AS I READ TO YOU THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS. AGAIN WE ARE
ADDING YOUR YOUR AGENDA SHOULD
SHOW FOR ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION
AND I AM ADDING. AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE. ISSUE FIFTY EIGHT CAL
WORKS. ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN AND
TWENTY EIGHT REGARDING AB FIVE.
ISSUE FIFTY TWO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL. AND ISSUE EIGHTEEN THE
BAND THE BOX TRAILER. I'LL
REPEAT. THREE MORE LAW FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. THE MADAM CHAIR MAY I
ALSO REQUEST FIFTY NINE BE
PULLED. ISSUE FIFTY NINE WITH
THE TOPICS ARE FOR THAT WASN'T
ON THE LIST THAT I WAS
PROVIDED. IT WAS- SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO REALIGNMENT
PROGRAMS. COULD YOU LOOK IN
YOUR CHEN THEN GIVE ME THE
EXACT WAY IT'S FRAMED IN THE
AGENDA THAT BE HELPFUL TO ALL
OF US. IT WAS IN. SEVEN THREE
SO I WILL GET THEIR.
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL BACK FILL
FOR LOSS OF NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THE RIVER MORALE
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YEAH I'D LIKE
TO REQUEST- ISSUE NUMBER ONE
ABOUT- SCHOOL RE OPENING
SUPPORT BLOCK GRANT PLEASE. I'M
GOING TO ASSUME CERTAIN
SOMEONE. SOMEONE YEAH. SOMEONE
ISSUE ONE.
SO WILL ADD- ISSUE
ONE SUB ONE AS WELL. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH THE- ITEMS
THAT WERE ALREADY CHEN DICED-
FOR DISCUSSION BEFORE WE MOVED
INTO THE ONES THAT. WERE ADDED.
WE REPEAT IT ONE MORE TIME FOR
THE PURPOSES OF MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LA JOH TO BE AWARE AGAIN WE ARE
REMOVING FROM VOTE ONLY THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS. ISSUE FIFTY
EIGHT CAL WORKS. ISSUES TWENTY
SEVEN AND TWENTY EIGHT. UNDER
AB FIVE. ISSUE FIFTY TWO
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL. ISSUE EIGHTEEN BAN THE
BOX. ISSUE FIFTY NINE THE-
REALIGNMENT REVERSION. AND
ISSUE ONE. UNDER SOMEONE
EDUCATION. THE. THIRTY TO REBEL
RECOGNIZE. MADAM SURE ON BEHALF
OF MY COUNTY WE LIKE TO PULL
ITEM SIX FOR DISCUSSION THANK
YOU YOU NEED TO HELP ME BECAUSE
THERE'S A BUDGET ITEM WHICH
IT'S IN THE EDUCATION-
SUBCOMMITTEE ITEM STICKS PAGE
FIVE EIGHT AIRCRAFT. YES.
THE
COLLEGE LET'S GO AHEAD AND-
MOVED TO OUR FIRST DISCUSSION
ITEM RELATED TO THE PIECES OF
THE SENATE BUDGET FRAMEWORK I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE LA- ON WHO ALL
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FOR THE FIRST ITEM ARE LA- MR
PANIC IS GOING TO BEGIN AND
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN AND HOW THEY DIFFER FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION.
WITH THE PET. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THAT I
WANTED TO BEGIN JUST BY
THANKING YOU AND THE VICE CHAIR
AND OTHER SENATORS PER
INCLUDING OUR OFFICE IN IN THE
HEARING TODAY. AS YOU NOTED WE
WERE WE WERE ASKED BY COMMITTEE
STAFF TO PRESENT A CROSSWALK
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION. AND THE SENATE SENATE
BUDGET PACKAGE AND OF COURSE WE
ARE PLEASED TO DO THAT BUT I
JUST WANTED TO NOTE FOR
EVERYONE'S AS- YOU KNOW OUR
OFFICE WAS NOT INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PACKAGE SO.
TO THE EXTENT YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT PARTICULAR
PROVISIONS THAT ARE REFERENCED
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE BEST POSITION
TO RESPOND TO THOSE. AND I WAS
HOPING TO PULL UP MY SLIDE
PRESENTATION. AND MEMBERS
SHOULD HAVE A HARD COPY OF THE
LA ALL PRESENTATION AS WELL.
OKAY. EIGHT COLLEGES FOR THAT.
BY AND- SCREEN OKAY HANNAH. AND
THAT IS THAT IS THAT APPEARING
PROPERLY OR YES IT IS THANK YOU
OKAY OKAY GOOD I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE- LATE. OKAY SO SINCE SINCE
YOU HAVE COPIES AND IT'S ON THE
SCREEN AS WELL. I WILL GO AHEAD
AND- MOVE INTO THE INTO THE
DECK HERE SO BEGINNING ON THE
FIRST PAGE OF THE SLIDES- I WAS
GOING TO BEGIN WITH FROM ONE OF
THE HIGHER LEVEL WILL REVIEW IT
SOME OF THE MAJOR AND MAJOR
ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE IN THE TWO
PACKAGES IN PARTICULAR I WOULD
COMMENT ON REVENUES BASS LINE
SPENDING. AND FEDERAL FUNDING
BECAUSE THE ASSUMPTIONS IN
THESE AREAS DIFFER IN THE TWO
PACKAGES SOME CASES- SO
BEGINNING WITH REVENUES-
ACTUALLY THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
THEY DO PACKAGE OUR PACKAGES
ARE ACTUALLY LARGELY SIMILAR TO
ONE ANOTHER- PACKAGES MAKE
SIMILAR ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
REVENUES AND- INCLUDE. AT THE
TOP. THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE
MAY IN REVISION TO TEMPORARILY-
PRODUCED MORE REVENUE FOR THAT.
FOR THE- STATE IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS- BUT THIS IS
DONE BY THE SPENDING THEY USE
THAT MOLD NET OPERATING LOSSES
BY BUSINESS. BUSINESS TAXPAYERS.
X. THREE YEARS AND ALSO BY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF TAX
CREDITS THAT CAN BE TAKEN BY
BUSINESSES FOR THOSE YEARS AS
WELL. AND THAT'S ESTIMATED TO
AUGMENT THE REVENUE- PICTURE BY
ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION.
REGARDING SPENDING IT
PARTICULARLY IN THE BASELINE.
THE SENATE BUDGET PACKAGE-
DIFFERS IN A NOTABLE WAY FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION I
THINK THIS SENATE PACKAGE
WOULD. LOOK TO OUR ESTIMATES
THE LA- ESTIMATES OF CASELOADS
BOTH IN THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM
AND IN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM IN
MEDI CAL THE CASELOADS
THEMSELVES ACTUALLY ARE
RELATIVELY SIMILAR. BUT THE
COST PER CASE LOAD IS DIFFERENT
AND IN OUR THE ESTIMATES FROM
OUR OFFICE ARE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS LOWER. THAN WHAT WAS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION. IN
CAL WORKS THERE'S A FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIAL DIFFERENCE JUST IN
A NUMBER OF CASELOADS OUR
OFFICE IS ACTUALLY ESTIMATES
THAT. CASE LOADS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WILL BE LOWER THAN WHAT
THE NAY REVISION IS BUILT UPON
BY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- CASELOADS. THAT
RESULTS IN A SIGNIFICANT TWO
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLAR A
COST DIFFERENCE IN SO SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION PLUS
THE TWO POINT NINE BILLION. A
SUM UP TO THAT THREE POINT SIX
BILL AND IN LOWER EXPENDITURES
THEN THE BASELINE UNDER THE
SENATE PACKAGE. WHEN IT COMES
TO FEDERAL FUNDING. THE TWO
PACKAGES ARE DIFFERENT IN
FUNDAMENTAL WAYS IN FACT THE
BASELINE ASSUMPTION AND FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION AND THE
BASELINE ASSUMPTION REGARDING
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THE SENATE
PACKAGE DIFFER SUCH THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY DIFFICULT TO COMPARE
THEM YEAH COMPARE THEM UNDER
BOTH OF THEIR BASELINE VERSIONS
SO WHAT I MEAN IS IN THE MAIL.
IN THE NAY REVISION. THE
BASELINE IS THAT THERE IS NOT
GOING TO EIGHT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE FORTHCOMING.
AND THAT IS IT IN RECOGNITION
OF THAT IN THE LOWER REVENUE
EXPECTATIONS THAT WE HAVE NOW
FROM THE RECESSION. MAY
REVISION WOULD IT INCLUDES
ABOUT FIFTEEN BILLION AND A
REDUCTION IN THE BUDGET. NOW
THOSE REDUCTIONS WOULD BE A
RESTORED AND TRIGGERED OFF IF
THE STATE WERE TO REALIZE AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION OR
SO THE FEDERALIST SYSTEMS BY
JULY FIRST. THE SENATE PACKAGE
ON THE OTHER HAND STARTS FROM
THE PREMISE THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE AND SO THE BUDGET IS
FILLED WITH THAT- RESUMPTION IN
IN THE LINE. AND INSTEAD WHAT
IT WOULD DO IS IF IT DOES NOT
MATERIALIZE IT INCLUDES
TRIGGERS THAT WAY TO. OFFSET
THE MISSING FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
IN THE EVENT THAT THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE BY OCTOBER FIRST. SO
RATHER THAN COMPARE THE TWO
PACKAGES ON THEIR BASELINE-
ASSUMPTIONS I WILL ACTUALLY
COMPARE THEM THROUGH THE
BALANCE OF MY PRESENTATION IN
THIS IN AN AREA WHERE THERE IS
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING AND
IN THE ALTERNATIVE WHERE THERE
IS NOT CONDITIONAL FEDERAL. SO
MOVES TO THE NEXT PAGE. AND
THIS IS WHERE WE DO MOVE INTO
THE DISCUSSION ON FEDERAL
FUNDING AND I'LL BEGIN WITH THE
CASE IN WHICH THERE IS
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID
FORTHCOMING. IN THIS IN THIS
INSTANCE THE MAY REVISION IN
THE SENATE PACKAGE ARE BROADLY
SIMILAR- THERE ARE A FEW
DIFFERENCES ONE BEING THAT THE
SENATE PACKAGE WOULD WOULD END
THE- BUDGET YEAR WITH SLIGHTLY
HIGHER TOTAL BUDGET RESERVES OF
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. BUT
THEN THE SENATE PACKAGE WOULD
ALSO REJECTS SOME OF THE NAY
REVISION PROPOSALS AND IT ALSO
INCLUDES SOME AUGMENTATION
THEY'RE NOT IN THE MAYOR. SO
SOME OF THE ONES THAT. ARE
NOTABLE ARE- THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION IN COUNTY REALIGNMENT
ASSISTANCE. AND THIS IS A- YOU
KNOW A RECOGNITION THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANT.
REDUCTION IN REALIGNMENT
FUNDING BECAUSE OF HE
RECESSION THAT ESTIMATES I
BELIEVE IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION THERE THAT IT BE IT-
SEVENTY IN PERCENT REDUCTION IN
THOSE REVENUES THE SENATE
BUDGET PACKAGE ALSO INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR LOCAL HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. AND THEN FORTY TWO
MILLION FOR THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT EXPANSION IN THIS
CASE IT WOULD BE EXPANDED TO
COVER. I TEN FILERS TAX FILERS.
TAKING EARLY THOSE WITH
CHILDREN. AGES SIX AND UNDER.
NOW IF WE CAN SO THAT'S KIND OF
THE FROM THE NOTABLE WAYS IN
WHICH THEY DIFFER IF WE DO
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING BUT THAT ACTUALLY A
FAIRLY SHORT LIST WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE
THIS IS THE TWO PACKAGES ARE
REALLY QUITE DIFFERENT WHEN WE
GO TO THE OTHER SCENARIO WHERE
THERE IS NOT. FEDERAL BEING
FORTHCOMING SO FOR ALL MOVE NOW.
THE BEGINNING WITH REVENUES IN
THE EVENT THAT WE ARE NOT IN
RECEIPT OF ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
AID THE NAY REVISION DOES NOT
REALLY PROPOSING NEED
ADDITIONAL. REVENUE INCREASES
THAT WOULD BE CONTINGENT ON
WHETHER OR NOT WE GET THAT THAT
REALLY SO WE JUST GO AT WITH
THE REVENUE BASE AS IT. IS
SENATE BUDGET PACKAGE ON THE
OTHER HAND WOULD MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX FOR THE NCO
TAX AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
THAT WOULD RESULT IN ABOUT ONE
BILLION A GENERAL FUND STATE.
I'M THE CHANGE. THE ADJUSTMENT
TO THE TAX SEEMS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH CMS GUIDANCE
THAT CAME OUT ABOUT EIGHT
MONTHS AGO BUT IT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO FEDERAL REVIEWER
FEDERAL APPROVAL. NOW MOVING TO
BUDGET RESERVE BIRDS THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES HERE TO KNOW
BUT I'D LIKE TO BEGIN JUST WITH
THE PREFORMED HERE BECAUSE I
KNOW FROM ME CAN BE A LITTLE
BIT COMPLICATED AT TIMES. BUT
UNDER PROPOSITION TWO. UP TO
HALF OF THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT CAN BE
WITHDRAWN AND THE FIRST YEAR.
GOVERNOR DECLARES A BUDGET
EMERGENCY. AND THE GOVERNOR CAN
DECLARE A BUDGET EMERGENCY WHEN
THERE'S A DISASTER AND
TYPICALLY THINK YOU HAVE A
NATURAL DISASTER BUT IT COULD
BE. MAN MADE DISASTER OR- IN
THE CASE WHEN THERE IS A FISCAL
EMERGENCY AND FISCAL EMERGENCY
IS DEFINED AS A SITUATION IN
WHICH RESOURCES IN THE CURRENT
AND UPCOMING YEAR ARE PROJECTED
TO BE INSUFFICIENT TO COVER THE
LEVEL OF EXPENDITURES YEAH.
THERE WERE PROVIDED IN THE
HIGHEST OF THE LAST THREE
BUDGETS AND THEN YOU WOULD JUST
THOSE MEASUREMENTS BY A
POPULATION AND INFLATION. SO
THAT'S SORT OF THE GROUND RULES
FOR USING THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT AND JUST
TO KIND OF LEVEL SET HERE THE
BSA CURRENTLY HAS ABOUT SIXTEEN
POINT TWO BILLION IN. ERROR OF
THE BALANCE BUT IF YOU KNOW ON
THE SLIDE THE SENATE PLAN WOULD
BRING THAT DOWN TO NINE POINT
I'M SORRY TO SIX POINT SIX
BILLION. AND SO I THINK A FAIR
QUESTION IS WILL HOW IF YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO WITHDRAW HALF OF THE
BALANCE HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
REDUCE IT BY NINE POINT SIX
BILLION SINCE NINE POINT SIX
BILLION AND MORE THAN HALF OF
SIXTEEN BILLION. AND THE REASON
IS IN RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NO PRUDENT WE-
MADE SIGNS SUPPLEMENTAL
OPTIONAL DEPOSITS TO THE BSA IN
THE YEARS IN WHICH WE'VE HAD.
BUDGET SURPLUSES. AND THOSE
OPTIONAL SIR DEPOSITS SOME TO
ABOUT THREE BILLION.
INTERVIEWED AS A FULLY
AVAILABLE SO THOSE ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THAT YOU KNOW WITH
FOR ALL OF HALF OF THE BALLOTS
RULE. SO WE TAKE THE THREE
BILLION AND THEN HALF OF WHAT'S
LEFT WHICH IS THIRTEEN BILLION
THAT SIX AND A HALF BILLION. IN
THAT ROOM REALLY BRINGS YOU TO
YOU KNOW THAT NINE AND A HALF
BILLION OR SO THAT IS BEING
UTILIZED UNDER THE SENATE PLAN.
SO NEXT- GO INTO LIVE BRIEF
DISCUSSION HERE OF HOW THE TWO
PLANS WOULD. USE THE COST SHIFT
OPTIONS. IN THE FISCAL OPTIONS
FOR THE STATE. IF YOU WOULD
ALLOW ME TO I WOULD DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE MIDDLE LINE
THERE THAT SAYS REINSTATE
DEFERRALS AND IN THIS CASE NOT
TALKING ABOUT SCHOOL DEFERRALS.
REFERRING TO A DEFERRAL OF THE
JUNE PAYMENT ROLE PAYMENT THAT
GOES OUT TO STATE WORKERS. IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER CALPERS
CONTRIBUTION. THE JUNE PAVE
PAYROLL- DEFERRAL FOR STATE
WORKERS WE WOULD INVOLVE A
SHIFT OF THE FIGHT OF THE JUNE.
A ROLL PAYMENT GOING FROM LATE
JUNE TO EARLY JULY. THERE'S
ACTUALLY NO DELAY IN WHEN THE
WORKERS RECEIVED THEIR
PAYCHECKS BUT RATHER IT'S MORE
OF AN ACCOUNTING CHANGE BUT IT
DOES RESULT IN SHIFTING IT TO
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR ON THAT
BASIS. AS FOR THE- DID THE
DEFERRAL OF THE CALPERS
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE FOURTH
QUARTER- PAYMENT FROM LATE JUNE
TO EARLY JULY. THERE IS AN
ACTUAL DELAY IN WHEN THE
PAYMENT IS MADE BY A FEW DAYS
BUT WE UNDERSTAND- FROM LOOKING
INTO IT THAT THERE'S NOT A
MATERIAL. IMPACT ON THE
CONDITION OF THE STATE'S
PENSION SYSTEM FROM THIS ACTION.
A VERY IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE
HERE IS THAT THE DEFERRAL HOLES
IN THIS CASE APPLY TO BOTH THE
GENERAL FUND AND THE SPECIAL
FUNDS. AND THEN THERE'S THE
SAVINGS THAT ARE REALIZED ON
THE SPECIAL FUNDS SIDE WOULD BE
SHIFTED TO THE GENERAL FUND AND
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE TOP LINE
THEIR SPECIAL FUND LOANS IN
TRANSFER YOU'LL NOTE THAT THAT.
ITEM IS ONE POINT ONE BILL THE
ENTIRE IN THE SENATE PLAN THEN
IN THE GOVERNOR'S NEIGHBOR
VISION. AND THAT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION REALLY REPRESENTS THE
SAVINGS THAT I JUST DESCRIBED
FROM THOSE DEFERRALS. BEING
SHIFTED INTO THE GENERAL FUND.
OKAY SO NOW I THINK A V. TOPIC
OF EDUCATION AND PROP NINETY
EIGHT IS AN ITEM ON YOUR AGENDA
HERE TODAY SO I WILL NOT SPEND
A LOT OF TIME ON THIS BUT I
WILL TOUCH ON IT. SO WHEN IT
COMES TO FIND IN FOR THE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
UNDER THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN IN
THE IN THE INSTANCE IN WHICH
THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING. THERE IS NO REDUCTION
IS SCHOOL FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. RATHER THE OVERALL
FUNDING LEVEL ACTUALLY GOES OUT
BY- IS EIGHT BILLION HIGHER
UNDER THE SENATE PLAN THEN
UNDER THE- GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION. THE WAY THAT THIS IS
ACHIEVED IS THROUGH A TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR HIGHER
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT-
GENERALS I'M PAYMENT. WHICH IS
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE COLA.
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE GIRLS AT FOR THE SCHOOL
PAYMENTS NOW IN ADDITION TO THE
DEFERRAL. THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING IN THE NAY REVISION.
THE SENATE PLAN WOULD ADD AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION DEFERRALS. SO THAT THAT
THE TO THOSE TWO ITEMS THE TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN HIGHER
PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
AND THE DEFERRAL SON TO EIGHT
BILLION AND THAT'S HOW. THAT IS
PROVIDE IT. NOW FINALLY THIS
LAST PAGE. DISPLAYS RELEASE
SOME OF THE MAJOR PROGRAMMATIC
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO
PACKAGES. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
A SCENARIO IN WHICH THERE IS NO
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID. THESE
ITEMS SHOWN ON THIS PAGE ROOM
THE WAY AT THE HEART OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
PACKAGES. YOU WOULD KNOW THAT-
THE SENATE BUDGET PACKAGE DOES
REJECT SOME OF THE NAY REVISION
PROPOSALS SUCH AS THE ONE POINT
TWO BILLION. CHANGE AND USE OF
THE PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING SO
INSTEAD OF FUNDING GROW THROUGH
THE CONTINUE TO BE USED TO PAY
PROVIDER PAYMENTS. AND LIKEWISE
THE SENATE PLAN DOES REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS IT
RELATES TO THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IT IS
WHICH- IN THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION WOULD REDUCE SERVICE
HOURS BY 7% SO YOU CAN SEE
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHERS ON THE
LIST AS WELL. NOW THE QUESTION
IS HOW DOES THE SENATE PLAN DO
THAT AND IT'S REALLY WHAT I WAS
JUST DESCRIBING THROUGHOUT THE
PREVIOUS SLIDES AND THEREFORE
WAYS TO THINK ABOUT AND
CATEGORICALLY. FIRST THE SENATE
PLAN IDENTIFIES A BIT OF NEW
REVENUE IN THE NCO TAX
ADJUSTMENT. IT ALSO USES THE
**** CASELOADS ON CAL WORKS IN
MEDI CAL WHICH LOWERS THE
SPENDING BASS. BUT THEN IT ALSO
DOES USE A BIT MORE OF THE
STATE'S RESERVES AND IT DOES
RELY MORE ON CAUTIOUS AND SOLD.
THOSE ACTIONS WHEN YOU PUT THEM
TOGETHER REALLY ARE WHAT THE
NAVAL THE STATE TO PRESERVE
THESE EXISTING PROGRAM
COMMITMENTS. THAT I'VE YOU KNOW
SHOWN HERE ON THIS SLIDE. SO
THAT'S THE BEGINNING THAT HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
COMPARISON. BETWEEN THE TWO
PACKAGES. AND OF COURSE I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT MY-
ISN'T EIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WILL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF. FINANCE MISTER
THIS ONE OFTEN NINETY OF ANY
COMMENTS. GET AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON THANK YOU THAT MADAM
CHAIR WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS
VERY BRIEF WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE SENATE
PROPOSAL AS WELL AND WORKING
TOGETHER WITH YOU OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS- WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON A BUDGET THAT IS
BALANCED IN YOUR CONS BUT THAT
ALSO ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
STRUCTURAL JUST SAY NO WE ARE
ALL CONCERNED ABOUT. I SEE WHAT
ECONOMIC PROJECTIONS OVER THE
COMING THREE OR FOUR FISCALLY
AND DOING SO IN A WAY THAT CAN
SCORE SO WE ARE HAPPY IN
MINISTRATIONS TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR PROPOSALS
FOR MOST. FOR TO WORK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL IT UP TO.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM
ONLY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT COLLEAGUES SEEN NONE.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE SECOND ITEM
OF DISCUSSION. SENATOR DORADO.
HEY FOR THE FRATERNITY. OKAY
FROM I GET THIS WRONG I'M SURE
YOU'LL POINTED OUT TO ME. I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE. THE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES COVERED AND I THINK THIS
IS THIS IS THAT RIGHT THIS IS
ISSUE ONE RIGHT. YEAH OKAY-
JUST WITH REGARDS TO THE MCO
TAX. RIGHT OKAY TO YOU IN YOUR
ISSUES ARE WITH REGARD TO THE
OVERALL BUDGET FRAMEWORK THAT
THE ALLEY- JUST LIKE THE FOR
THE FRAMEWORK OF THE- BUDGET
TODAY YES. RIGHT WHAT ARE WE ON
ISSUE ONE. WE WERE ON ISSUE ONE
WHICH IS THE OVERALL BUDGET
FRAMEWORK YEAH AND THEN THAT IS
THE MCO TAX AND A NUMBER OF
THINGS. IS THIS RIGHT GIVES THE
ATTACK ON THE PART OF THE
OVERALL FRAMEWORK FOR THE
BUDGET SO YES GO HEAD OKAY
OKAY- SO I JUST WONDER- I KNOW
THAT THE- MAY REVISION INCLUDES
A FEDERAL APPROVAL OF THE MCO
ENROLLMENT TAX- WHICH WOULD.
WHICH WOULD RESULT IN AN OFFSET
OF ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS- THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSED EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY
FOR FULL SCOPE MEDICAL BENEFITS
TO ALL PERSONS. SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THAT COST OF WOULD HAVE
BEEN SIXTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE GENERAL FUND SO- I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE
THE INCLUDE IN A IN THE BUDGET
OF TWENTY NEED TO BUT I WANTED
OR JUST. KEEP WORKING AT IT TO
INCLUDE- THESE US SENIORS
SOONER THAN LATER SO THAT'S
JUST ON THE MC A TAX- I WANT TO
JUST COME INTO OF THE I. H. S.
S. AND I SHAPE THE- OF A TEN TO
THE H. S. S. UP WERE AND TO
THEIR CLIENTS BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY CRITICAL
TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO THE
WORKING POOR BUT TO WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES. SO I WENT
OUT OF THANK YOU AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND THEN- I
WANT TO MAKE COMMENT ALSO BUT
THE CSU THIS IS A SOMETHING
THAT I WANT THEM TO KEEP IN
MIND BECAUSE THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THEIR OWN BUDGET AND THAT'S
THEIR PROPRIETARY AND TO AVOID
OUGHT LABOR DISPUTES AND
DISRUPTIONS. THE IMPACT OF KOBE
NINETEEN IS THE DISEASE IS HAS
DESTABILIZED WORKPLACES- ACROSS
THE STATE- ALSO ON STATE OWNED
AND OPERATED FACILITIES. ARE
AMONG THESE ARE LOW WAGE
WORKERS EMPLOYED BY BUSINESSES
OPERATED AND FINANCED WITH IN
THE CSU SYSTEM ARE THEY INCLUDE
RESTAURANTS HOTELS AND RETAIL
STORES- THE CSU HAS
INCREASINGLY CONTRACTED OUT.
THESE FACILITIES TO PRIVATE
AUXILIARIES- AND IN TURN SUCH
OPERATIONS HAVE. BEEN INVOLVED
IN LABOR DISPUTES SO- IN THE
MIDST OF THIS UNPRECEDENTED
ECONOMIC DISRUPTION. I LEAVE
THE STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
TAKE ACTION TO PREVENT LATE
DISPUTES THAT BUT MINE OF THE
RE OPENING OF THE CSU SYSTEM.
AND I THINK WE TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT THE INTEREST OF THE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS TAXPAYERS
SO I WANTED TO- MAKE THOSE
COMMENTS ON THOSE PORTIONS OF
THE BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. FIRST ITEM.
SEEING NONE OF COLLEAGUES WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS HAVE THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PRODUCE A
NEW ISSUES FOR DISCUSSION
SHEET- SO YOU'LL HAVE ALL THE
ADDITIONAL ITEMS THAT WERE
ADDED THAT I SHARE WITH YOU
VERBALLY SO IT SHOULD BE COMING
SHORTLY. AFTER YOUR INDULGENCE
YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE ONE STAFF
MEMBER. ALLOWED SELL TO A
MINUTE WE'LL GET YOU THE
ADDITIONAL SHE WITH ALL THE
ADDITIONS THAT WERE SHARED WITH
US BY OUR COLLEAGUES. MOVING ON
TO FOR UNDER ITEMS FOR
DISCUSSION. ISSUE TO PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR. FROM LA- FIRST
AM I CORRECT ON THAT. WHY IS
FINANCE SPEAKING FOR SOME
PROBLEM NINETY EIGHT ISSUE TO.
THIS IS A I GET IT GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ENTER CABRAL TO LIVE
SAID ALMOST OFFICE. MISTER
PADDOCK WALK THROUGH OUR
QUICKLY AND SOME OF THE HIGH
POINTS OF THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THAT THE SENATE PACKAGE
AND THERE ARE ADMINISTRATION
MAY REVISE BUT I GOT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT IN IN SOMEWHAT MORE
DETAIL ABOUT HOW DOES THIS
DIFFER. AT AS WAS DISCUSSED
PREVIOUS THERE AS OF. EACH ARE
THERE ARE TWO TWO DIFFERENT
PACKAGES ONE ASSUMING FEDERAL
FUNDING MATERIALIZES. ONE
ASSUMING FOR OPENING DOES NOT.
INSTALL WHAT DO THOSE
DIFFERENCES UNDER THOSE
SCENARIOS- BUT THE FIRST THING
BEFORE I GET TO THAT THERE IS
ONE PROPOSAL THAT OR OR ONE
ACTION IS DIFFERENT IN IN
EITHER OF THESE ARE. A
SCENARIOS AND THAT'S FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION. SO THAT
THE- THE REVISION INCLUDED SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO INCREASE BASED
PASSAGE KITCHEN FUNDING RIGHT.
THE SENATE ACTION IT WOULD
PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION AND THEN WOULD.
TAKE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND USE THAT TO INCREASE.
FUNDING FOR LOW INCIDENCE
DISABILITIES WHICH ARE
DISABILITIES- RELATED TO SIT
BACK TO CHILDREN ARE HEARING
VISUAL OR- THAT'S A DIFFERENCE
IN THE SENATE PLAN THAT WOULD.
WOULD TAKE AFFECT WHETHER OR
NOT FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THE
MATERIALIZE. THEN NOW WALKING
THROUGH- SOME OF THE KEY
CHANGES OR DIFFERENCES- UNDER
EACH OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING OF
ASSUMPTIONS. IF FEDERAL FUNDS
WERE TO MATERIALIZE. THE
PACKAGES ARE LARGELY SIMILAR
THEY WOULD- BOTH PROVIDE FOR
EXAMPLE- COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS FOR ALL CFF AND FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPORTIONMENT. WILL ALSO
PROVIDE- CAN BE CALLED A
PORTION OF GROWTH. TO TWO
NOTABLE DIFFERENCES- IT IN IN
THE SENATE PLAN ONE OF THE
SENATE PLAN PROJECTS-
EXPOSITORY. ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THIS THE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM IS ADJUSTED AND
ANNUALLY FOR THAT PROJECT THE
CHANGES IN THE ZERO FOUR
POPULATION. AND A BAD AT THE
TWO POINT 55% REDUCTION IN THE
MIRROR IS. OF THE- THE SENATE
PACKAGE WOULD BACK TO CHANGE
STATUTES SUCH THAT THE SUBJECT
MIGHT BE MADE THE ADJUSTMENT
WAS. LESS THAN ZERO. RIVER
WOULD. RESULT IN A REDUCTION
AND THAT- RESULTS IN THAT-
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN- THE COMING OF PROVIDED IN
THE SENATE PACKAGE. THE NOT A
DIFFERENT IS RELATED TO
CALIBRATE COLOR. OF THE S.
SENATE PACKAGE ARE SIX SEVEN
SEVEN DOLLARS IN A DAY UNSPENT
OUR PRIOR FUNDING FOR CAL
COLLEGE. AND USES SOME OF
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL TO GROW.
AND THEN SEVENTY SEPARATE HOURS.
IN ORDER ORGAN BACK DESERVES
SIMILAR THESE ARE THE BIGGER
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEM. THEN
MOVING TO IF THERE IS NO
FEDERAL FUNDING- BUT THIS IS
WHERE THE PACKAGES TO HAVE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACHES. THAT
THE SENATE PACKAGE- RATHER THAN
MAKING VETERAN REDUCTIONS IN
THE MAYOR VISION WHICH WOULD
REDUCE. I'LL SEE IF I FUNDING A
FOUR SEMAINES- AND A VARIETY OF
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS INSTEAD
THOUGH THOSE NAMES ARE NOT BE
CUT. THAT IT INCREASES THE SIZE
OF THE DEFERRAL OR SCHOOLS
INCOMMUNICADO IS BY. POINT
THREE DOLLARS AND THIS IS FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS ON
TOP OF THE DEFERRALS BUT ARE
ARE YOU. IN THE MAIL. ABOUT
THREE SEVEN BILLION. THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT CAN MY
COMMENTS BUT TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FINANCE
ANY COM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WILL SAY JUST VERY BRIEFLY-
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
PUT FORWARD A PLAN THAT
INCLUDES THE USE OF FEDERAL
FUNDS THIS YEAR- AS WELL AS
THAT REPURPOSE SAYING OUT TELL
STIRS FUNDING. AND THE BUDGET
ACT LAST YEAR'S TO PROVIDE MORE
IMMEDIATE JUST OVER WEEKS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WELL AS A
PLAN WHICH I KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ENGAGED WITH.
FOR RESTORING THE NINETY EIGHT
CASE OVER TIME AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON HOW TO
DO ALL DAIS IN ACCOMPLISH WE
DON'T WANT TO ACCOMPLISH WITH A
MIX TAX. BUDGET THANK YOU.
MEMBERS COMMENTS ON ISSUE TO
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE
MEMBERS COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THREE TO TORONTO. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. A BIG I
THINK I REPRESENT THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS IN THE
LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
COUNTRY PROVIDES THE SERVICES
TO OVER. THE WALL PEACHES OVER
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS-
AND A PROVIDE SERVICES TO OVER
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITH INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLAN.
UP THE STAR WITH THE STRICT
ESTIMATES IT WILL SPEND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON COLBERT NINETEEN RESPONSE
EFFORTS JUST THROUGH AUGUST.
WITH FOUR MAJOR NEEDS B. E. AND
CLEANING SUPPLIES CHILDREN AND
ADULT MALES DEVICES AND
CONNECTIVITY AND INSTRUCTION TO
RE OPENING THE SCHOOL CAMPUSES
IS GOING TO TAKE MORE NOT FEWER
RESOURCES TO INSURANCES
STAYING- THE PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE AND THE SAFETY OF
THOSE STUDENTS TO RETURN. WITH
REGARDS TO THE FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION GRANTS
WE NEED MORE FLEXIBILITY ARE WE
HOPE. WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE
TO A GREATER FOR BLOODY AND
ALLOW FOR LOCAL DISCRETION USE
OF THESE FUNDS RE RE OPENING OF
SCHOOL CAMPUSES SUPPORT
LEARNING LOSS AND BRIDGE THE
ACADEMIC NEEDS OF THOSE
STUDENTS. WE ALSO- ARE LOOKING
FOR A MORE ADOPTING A MORE
EQUITABLE FORMULA THE MAY
REVISE- EQUALIZATION PROPOSAL.
AUGMENTS AN OUTDATED FORMULA
THAT DOESN'T SUPPORT EQUITY
SINCE IT FAILS TO RECOGNIZE THE
AMOUNT OF SERVICES. STUDENTS
WITH MODERATE TO SEVERE
DISABILITIES RECEIVE UNDER THE
ALTERNATIVE FAIR SHARE EQUITY
DRIVEN PROPOSAL THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SELBER WOULD RECEIVE AN
ESTIMATED SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE AVAILABLE
FUNDING. WHICH IS WHAT WE
SHOULD HAVE WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY 16% FALL FUNDS.
THE 16% OF THE STUDENTS WE
SERVE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER HAVE COME
OR ON ISSUE TO. DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM CHAIR I
THAT- AS OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE HAVING SENSUALLY TO SHIFT-
TO DISTANCE LEARNING LIKE MANY
OTHER EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
I APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
REDIRECTING RESOURCES FROM A
SEPARATE CAMPUS TO ALL OUR
CAMPUSES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WHEN IT COMES TO
CALIBRATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYTHING FURTHER I SEE NO
FURTHER MIKE'S REYES WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE THREE CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINE
ELEVEN POINT NINETY FIVE AND
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED. LA JOH.
OKAY MEDICARE I'D I'D WAS.
ANTICIPATING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SORRY
THEN FINANCE. ARE YOU PREPARED
TO ONE BRIEF US ON ISSUE THREE.
I SOLANO SENATE SHOULD THREES
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR
PROPOSAL FROM THE NAY
REVISIONS- BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT BOTH WITH
DISCUSSIONS IN THE LAST MEETING
OF THIS COMMITTEE NOT AND
SHARES AS WELL AS DISCUSSIONS
WITH ASSEMBLY SOME EIGHTY SIX
LAST FRIDAY- THAT WE ALL WANT
TO STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
HERE BETWEEN. ACCOUNTABILITY
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE CONTROLS
SINCE WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT. IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE- HE'S TRANSPARENCY
AROUND ANY PROPOSED ACTIONS.
AND WHATEVER WE DECIDE TO DO
WORKING WITH YOU WE WOULD YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RETAIN
SUFFICIENT FLEXIBILITY TO ASK
IN PARTICULAR IF WE SEE OUR
RESURGENCE INCORRECTLY. FOR A
SEARCH NEEDED FOR HOSPITAL SO
WITH THAT A HAPPY DAY A QUICK
ABOUT OUR PROPOSAL AND FOR TO
ENGAGE. THANK YOU QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS FROM. DOCTOR PAN I
THANK YOU A MADAM CHAIR- I
WOULD JUST MAKE NOTE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- YOU KNOW WE'RE
BACK IN SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE EXT SIR
OVERSIGHT- IS IN A BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT AND- SO FOR TWO.
ACTIONS BUT I. THAT GOT A BILL
IN AND C. N. ARE PUBLIC SPEND
FOR THE EVEN IN A SITUATION YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER FOR ME
BEFORE I GO BACK TO THE LA ANY
OTHER FROM MEMBERS THIS
APPENDIX. THANK YOU MADAM. I
JUST WANTED TO UNDERSCORE THAT
YES OUR OFFICE DOES VIEW THIS
AS ANY SUBJECT AREA AND WE
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR THE
STATE TO. ALIVE NUMBER RESPONSE
TO PUBLIC. CHEN BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERN ABOUT THE DEGREE OF
LATITUDE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN SEEKING
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND WE
HAVE SOME SPECIFIC IDEAS WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE WE
THINK. OF A VARIOUS TYPES OF
AMENDMENTS TO EVEN THAT YOU
COULD COME TO THE TROLL SECTION.
YOU COULD CAN SO JUST MINUTES
AS A DIFFERENT PER YOU KNOW.
THE PRO FOR WHEN THE LARGEST
SINCE THIS IS NOT AN SAID AS A
DOCTOR AND LOOTED FROM THERE
THERE ARE SOME IT JUST THAT CAN
BE MADE THAT WE NEED COULD
ENHANCE THE LEGISLATURE ABILITY
TO CAN OVERSIGHT. AND. YEAH.
MORE THANK YOU. WITH THAT THING
OVER THE ARE WE WILL MOVE ON.
TO ISSUE FOR HOUSING HOMELESS
TRAIL BILL FROM. ON ONE OR TWO
OF YOUR FINANCER LA- WHO'S
GOING FIRST. KEEP GETTING THAT
WRONG. WHOSE CUED UP TO GO
FIRST. I AM HAPPY DATA BRIEFLY
DISCUSS OUR PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
JK QUESTIONS SO WHEN IT COMES
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS IN THE
NAY RELATIONS AND THEIR NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT STREAMS- ONE OF
WHICH IS ANOTHER AUTHORIZATION
FOR THE LOAN CONNECTING ADDED A
SITE AND MILLION DOLLARS A WEEK.
AND THE NATIONAL MARKET
SETTLEMENT SUNDAY THIRTY ONE
MILLION. AND AFTER LAST FOR
THAT MAKE SURE THAT RENTERS TAX.
A POINT HOUSES WERE MATTER.
ENERGY WAY AND PERHAPS IN NEED
WAY WE- ALWAYS APPLICATION FOR
FUNDING FROM THE CARES ACTING.
RUNNING RESPOND ON THAT IS THE
AND- PROXIMATE. DOLLARS STATE
PROPOSING THAT SOME OF THE GOES
FOR ACT WAS. BERNIE MOTELS TO
HELP HOUSE WAS THIS POPULAR NOT
ONLY A MEDIUM TERM ALONG TERMS
I. ONE PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS CRISIS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR-
THANK. YOU IN COMMENTS ON. THE
PROPOSAL. YES ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM I BELIEVE MY
CON MY COLLEEN BORDERS MORALIS
WOULD- HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAIL TO PROVIDE GREAT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT'S WHEN
I WAS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ALL FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON PROJECT RICKY.
MINISTRATIONS RECENTLY MADE
AVAILABLE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE I WOULDN'T LIMóN
PROJECT RICKY. ON THIS ISSUE IS
NOTE THAT THE ADMIN THE TERM
DOES LACKEY TALENT SO WITH
DON'T. GET READY TO BE
ADMINISTERED. ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM.
FOR EXAMPLE THE LANGUAGE
DOESN'T SPECIFY HOW MANY WOULD
BE DISTRIBUTED WHETHER IT WOULD
BE ON A FIRST COME FIRST BASIS.
THIS IS THE CASE THIRTY SOME
CONCERN. ABOUT WHETHER THE
BENEFITS OF THIS PROGRAM WOULD
BE SEEN ACROSS. OTHERS NUMBER.
IN ADDITION OUR I WOULD HAVE
RECORDING OR TO THE LEGISLATURE
SEPARATIST INTERESTED IN.
NUMBER UNITS REQUIRED HOW MUCH
OF THESE PROPERTIES COST
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES HERE
PROVISIONAL AROUND ON THE
LANGUAGE. RUSSIAN THANK YOU.
THANK QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS ON
ISSUE FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TRAILER BILL
PROPOSALS SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
MEAT REVISING INCLUDE REHAB
PATIENT IN. FOR HEALTH MOTELS
AND OTHER. TO PROVIDE IN
BRIDGES AND FAMILIES WITH
HOUSING. A SERIES OF LET THAT
HAVE THAT HAVE LED BY PROVIDE A
PATHWAY FOR ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS THAT ARE ON PERMITTED TO
BECOME PERMITTED IN BEGAN
LEGALIZE INHABITABLE BY PEOPLE
DOES THE CAN. OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT TALK ABOUT THESE
OTHER PROPERTIES THAT WILL BE
INCLUDED IN- PROJECT ROOM KEY.
SENATOR WHAT COST YOU MONEY
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
CHRIS COOK WHO MAY HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAIL. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS ARE SENATOR.
SO ROOM KEY IS PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON- CRISCO FROM FINANCE
SO PROJECT ROOM HE IS PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON A LOT OF THE EFFORTS
THAT HAVE BEGUN ALREADY WITH
THE ACT- THE AGREEMENTS THAT WE
AT THE LOW SAID MADE WITH THESE
PROPERTY OWNERS AND WHILE WE'RE
NOT LIMITING EITHER ADDITIONAL
TYPES OF FACILITY WHERE WE
FOCUS ON A LOT OF THOSE THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE I'VE
BEEN WORK THIS. WITH THE-
SERVICE VGA. THESE INDIVIDUALS
HOUSE THE NIGHT AND SO TO AVOID
DISRUPTION WE'RE FOCUSING ON
THOSE- WITH THAT SAID I THINK
THAT THERE IS A ROOM FOR
ALTERNATIVE SITES SUCH AS- YOU
KNOW OTHER VACANT. PROPERTIES
THAT COULD BE ACQUIRED-
INTERESTINGLY I DON'T KNOW IF
WE THOUGHT ABOUT EIGHTY USE IN
PARTICULAR- BECAUSE OF THE THAT
THE YOU FUNDS AND HOW QUICKLY.
I SO. WE WERE CONTEMPLATING ALL
MORE OF THE BIG PROPERTIES IN
LARGE SCALE TO WHERE- THEY
COULD BE QUICKLY AND A CHOIR-
IN THE IN THE SOME. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE META MANAGER I
REALIZE THATWE HAVE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WE HAVE TO
SPEND BY THE END OF THE YEAR SO
IT WOULD SEEM THAT WE WANT TO
BE AS CLOSE OF SOME COME.
PEOPLE TAKE THEY THINK THAT
THEY CAN SPEND THE MONEY AND
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS AT LEAST
IN LOS ANGELES THEY HAVE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THE UNIT
AND PERMIT AND SORT OF THE MEAT
OPPORTUNITY THE A HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR A COUPLE DOLLARS IN
THAT STICK THE BILL EIGHTY
PROPERTY. IN A RELATIVE. SPAN
TAKE A LOOK THANK YOU BROTHER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HOUSING
PRODUCTION SHOULD SUPPORT
HOUSING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND HIGH QUALITY GOOD PAYING
JOBS I BELIEVE THAT WE MUST
INCLUDE PREVAILING WAGE SKILLED
AND TRAINED REQUIREMENT OF WORK
REQUIREMENTS IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THE PROJECT ROOM
KEEP PROGRAM. THEY IS NOT A
SEAT YOU CAN ASK. ACTION RECENT
REPORT SHOWED THAT CONSTRUCTION
LABOR ACCOUNTS FOR ONLY 15% OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT COSTS THIS
IS AN EQUITY ISSUE COMMUNITIES
ON THE MARGIN OF ECONOMIC
GROWTH BE AMONG WRITERS
BENEFICIARY OF HIGHER WEIGHT
AND HIGHER SAFETY STANDARDS.
CALLUM IS ALSO EXPERIENCING A
SHORTAGE HI SKILLED TRAINED
WORKERS. LOOTING PREVAILING AS
SKILLED AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS WILL HELP RETAIN A
SKILLED WORK FORCE THAT CAN
BUILD THE MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. OF THE MEN
WOMEN WHO DO CONSTRUCTION OF
THOSE OF THAT HOUSING TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD LIVING IN THAT
HOUSING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO I THINK THE
SENATE FOR THEIR FINE WELL FOR
REALLY CALLING OUT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S BEEN A
DISCUSSION- THE SENATE HAS
HOUSING PACKAGE THAT WE HOPE
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL WILL BE AS
THE OP TO BILL. MORE JUST THE
MEDIA. THE SAME TIME TO BE A IN
A MEETING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING AND FOSTER CARE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING IT MAKE
ANY SENSE SO REALLY COMMAND.
WORK THAT'S BEEN. TO THESE
RESORT SO THAT WE CAN MAKE- IT
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE I.
PROJECT WE CAN ACT FIND. THANK
YOU MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST AM WONDERING GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SET
ASIDE- HOTEL ROOMS THAT AREN'T
BEING USED- CURRENTLY AND IT
SEEMS AS THOUGH WE ARE
HOPEFULLY WINDING DOWN EPIDEMIC
THE DIDN'T FOR THESE WERE MIGHT
LESSEN. WHY WE HAVE. STANCES.
PROBABLY QUESTION MOST
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED BY
FINANCE YES THANK YOU SENATOR
MINUS ON THAT SO BUT YOU ARE
RIGHT AT THE END EXPENDITURES
FOR THE IMMEDIATE NEED- WITH
THE ONSET THE COMPLEX. THE
MINUTE. SAY WHAT MAKES YOU
POINTS FOR IS THAT EMERGING IS
NOT. AND WHILE WE HAVE BEEN
PROGRESS THEY'RE NOT A LOT
COUPLE DAYS IN WEEKS IN REAL
THE AND HOPE YOU CAN TO DO. WE
ARE NOT. YEAH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE RESPONSIBLE ARE NAY
REVISION AND WE I DON'T THIS
ELIGIBLE THANK YOU CRITICS I A
PLACE WHERE ARE WE TO BE AT
YOUR SOUL AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE TAKING. ALL PRECAUTIONS
NEEDED. OVER LONG TERM WE ARE
KNOW WHEN THIS EMERGENCY IS
GOING END AND WHEN WE ALL THINK
OF THE LONG TERM. HOMELESSNESS
STATE BASIS I'M NOT THE
GOVERNOR WHY DO YOU STATUS
ADDRESS EVEN BEFORE THE ONSET
OF THE COMING CRISIS. AND THEN
TALK ABOUT THANK YOU RATIONING
BELIEVES THAT THIS IS AN EL
WHEN YOU UNDER FEDERAL. WE NEED
A LOT OF. THAT IT. BILLS YES TO
FROM ON. THIS SHOULD BE RELATED
TO DEALING WITH HOMELESS. AND
IN THE GOVERNOR'S. UNREST
INITIAL SUBMISSION OF HIS PLAN
TO DEAL WITH THE HOMELESS. MUCH
WAS MADE TO BE KNOWN ABOUT
TRACKING THE SUCCESS OF THE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. IN THE
COMMUNITIES. TO ME THAT WAS OF
A GOOD IF YOU WILL. REFORM AND
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS
RATHER THAN JUST PROVIDING
HOUSING. BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE GOING TO BE PROVIDING
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM AND TRACKING THE
SUCCESS OF THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
IT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S BEEN A
BIT OF A RETREAT FROM THAT IN
THE- MAY REVISION HERE. COULD
YOU COMMENT ON THAT. YES
SENATOR NIELSEN I WILL SAY THAT
WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON NOT
SIMPLY PROVIDING HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS WHERE
POSSIBLE- BUT ALSO. SERVICES
THAT YOU REFERRED TO THAT ARE
IMPORTANT WHILE IT IS THE CASE
THAT IN THE NEIGHBORING NATIONS
WE DON'T HAVE THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE
PROJECTED BACK IN JANUARY AND
I. IN THIS AREA. ROSTER A
NUMBER OF OTHER AREAS IN WHICH
WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING SUPPORT YOU KNOW ONE
OF THEM I NICE DAYS- SOME
WORKERS. AND SHE JANE OUR
COASTAL HOW TO ALLOCATE THAT
MONEY AND PUTTING IT DIRECT TO
WORD I COUNSELING FOR PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE FOR PEOPLE ON
HOUSING RELATED MATTERS AND
THAT SHOULD HOPEFULLY HELP FROM
BANK I'M MORE. WHO ARE AT RISK
HOMELESSNESS FROM ACTUALLY.
BECOMING HOMELESS AND
EXPERIENCE. THEMSELVES IN
ADDITION WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER.
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PROPOSALS
INCLUDING ONCE YOU. STARTING A
NEW BUSINESS. AREAS ITEMS
RELATE TO RECOVERY IN OUR
OVERALL GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. THIS RECOVERY GO
AS ROBUSTLY AS POSSIBLE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THE
GOVERNOR'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
TASK FORCE IS ALSO PROVIDING US
WITH IDEAS ON THAT FRONT BUT I
THINK THE LAST THING THAT'LL
SAVE MONEY. WE PLACE THAT. THE
REASON NINETY POPULATIONS BUT
THE MANY IF NOT MOST OF THE
PEOPLE OUR LOW INCOME AND HAD
CHALLENGES ACCESSING HEALTHCARE
AND THAT'S WHY IN THIS BUDGET
EVEN WHEN IT COMES TO THE
VARIOUS CUTS THAT DISCRETION.
DO INCLUDING ITS NEIGHBOR
BANKING NORTH AMOUNTS TO BUDGET
AND THE STRUCTURE NOW THAT WE
ARE FACING THE GOVERNOR DEAN IT
A PRIORITY WE DO NOT WANT TO
MAKE ANY. REDUCE CHANGES COMES
TO MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY WE DO
NOT WANT TO REDUCE THAT CAL
WORKS FRANCE THAT ARE RISKY.
AND YOU WANT TO HOLD CONSTANT
COMBINED SSI SSD GRANT THAT
PEOPLE RECEIVE AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT THESE CHANGES COMBINED
WITH THE INCREASED AVAILABILITY
OF HOUSING PROGRAM I JUST
CRIED. HE WILL HAVE A- THE
DISCOURSE ALLEN JUST AT THIS
POPULATION. YES CAL WORKS. IT
TO ME THAT THERE MAY BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A RETREAT FROM
ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL TENETS
OF GAIN AND THEN LATER CAL
WORKS AND THAT IS. YOU WOULD.
BE TO BE IN SOME KIND OF
TREATMENT OR EDUCATION.
SOMETHING TO UPGRADE YOURSELF
SO THAT YOU COULD BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT PROVIDING FOR YOUR
HOUSING. IS THAT ROLL BACK THE-
STANDARD TIME THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS SO BENEFITING WOULD
NOT HAVE TO BE ENGAGED AND THEN
THEY DIDN'T WORK REHABILITATIVE.
REREAD MATTER NIELSEN I'LL MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT AND THEN- I NAY
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
TYLER WAITS TO SPEAK ABOUT CAL
WORK SPECIFICALLY ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE MINISTER HAS
TIME TO IT THE IMMEDIATE AMER
PLEASE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. I'M OF THE.
ACTOR THAT THANKS ALL MAY HAVE
TO JOHN THROUGH IN TO ADD THE
SERVICE. IN CON OF THIS ON.
EMERGENCY RELAXING SOME OF
THOSE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
SHORT TERM TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT SURPRISED. PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED I IN THE CONTEXT OF
ALL THE OTHER PRESSURES THAT
EIGHTY FACING AND SO ON THAT
RELATES TO SOME OF THAT-
CHANGES ARE WITH REGARD TO HOW
WE- MANAGE OUR REGION BERMAN
NATIONS ICE. POLICIES BUT ONE
HUNDRED OVER SPECIFICALLY OUR
WHAT STATE ARE WORKS YES THANK
YOU. I CENTER WE'VE
UNDERSTANDING YOUR QUESTION
CORRECTLY AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED WE HAVE MADE SOME
FLEXIBILITY IS IN THE PROGRAM.
RIGHT SELECT THEIR IF THERE'S-
YEAH FOR SOME OF THE
PARTICIPANTS NOT. ENGAGING IN
SOME WORK ACTIVITIES WITHOUT
FLEXIBILITY TO GRANT THEM BACK
BECAUSE- OURS THAT BUDGET
STRUCTURE FOR CAL WORKS IS MY
COLLEAGUE ALSO MENTION THERE
WERE A FEW REDUCTIONS PROPOSED
FOR SPECIFIC SERVICES HOWEVER
WE DO MAINTAIN FUNDING. AROUND
SUPPORT. OUT OF THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM IF THE BUT ARE
INDIVIDUALS REQUIRED AS A THAN
OUR QUALIFYING ARE THEY STILL
REQUIRED TO DO THIS KIND OF
UPGRADING THAT IS BEEN HISTORIC
AND TO SEE. ARE WE SO THE
SINGLE NOW WE'RE JUST GONNA
MAKE IT MORE FLEXIBLE AND WILL
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THE I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S ANY
LAND IN HERE THAT SAYS THIS IS
A- GO ALL. THE TIME THAT WE'RE
DEALING THE. CENTER IF I CAN IF
I CAN CLARIFY QUICKLY ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE SENATE
PROPOSAL FOR THE TIE BOX. WELL
THAT WOULD BE PART OF IT YES.
SO STILL NOTE THAT THAT THE
TIME CLOCK LANGUAGE IS
DISCUSSED ON YOUR AGENDA ITEMS
IS THE SENATE PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD RELAX SOME OF THE WORK
REQUIREMENTS- AS WELL AS
EXTENDED TIME PARK BUT
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO WAY WHICH
OTHER THAN TEMPORARY EXECUTIVE
ORDER ALLOWING FIRST. GO ON AN
ON GOING BASIS DOES WORK
REQUIREMENTS ARE STILL ON THE
FACT. OKAY THANK YOU. AND IF I
COULD ADD SENATOR NIELSEN JUST
REMIND US ALL THE SIXTY MONTH
TIME CLOCK WAS FEDERAL LAW. THE
STATE LEGISLATURE ADJUSTED THAT
TIME CLOCK SO WE ARE SIMPLY
TRYING TO ROLL BACK WHAT WAS
AGREED UPON THROUGH- WHEN THE
LATE NIGHT- SO TAKING US BACK
TO THE SIX O'CLOCK. CLEARLY
FEDERAL LAW WHICH WHICH WAS
NEGOTIATED INITIALLY CHECK
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ON THIS ITEM. ALL RIGHT SEEN
NONE OF EVERYONE SHOULD NOW
HAVE BEEN UPDATED ISSUES FOR
DISCUSSION LIST. AND WE'RE
GONNA THESE ARE THE ADDITIONAL
ITEMS THAT WERE ADDED TO THE
AGENDA TODAY WE GO AS THEY ARE
NOTED HERE. BY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH SOME ONE
UNDER EDUCATION ISSUE ONE. COOL
RE OPENING SUPPORT BLOCK GRANT
WHICH IS ON PAGE FOUR. OF YOUR
AGENDA. SENATOR MORALE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE LA-
WANTED OR WOULD YOU JUST PREFER
TO THE ISSUE SINCE. WHEN
WHATEVER LA DOES FINER I WILL.
BELIAU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE FIRST AND
THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM MONTHS IN
TOMORROW. MR AND MRS THAT.
BROAD PENINSULA BROWN'S OFFICE
AGAIN THIS PROPOSAL IS-
SPECIFICALLY TO ME TO USE- SOME
OF THE FEDERAL ONE TIME CARES
ACT BEING- TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S- REOPENING
GRANTS. AND THE FUNDS WITH. TO
RUN LOW EDUCATION AGENCIES ON A
PER ARE BASED ON ATTENDANCE
WOULD EXCLUDE NON CLASSROOM
BOOSTER SCHOOLS IN THE FUNDING
WOULD CAN BE USED FOR A VARIETY
OF THINGS BUT IT WOULD BE
ACTIVITIES. CLEANING TRAINING
FOR STAFF REGION COMMUNICATE
FAMILY. THANK YOU FINANCING A
COMMENT. NO COMMENT ON THIS
PROPOSAL MANAGER WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS IN THIS AREA THANK
YOU FOR THAT SENATOR AL. YES
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A RIGHT
NOW THIS PROPOSAL. EXCLUDES NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
I MOVED TO A MAN TO ALLOW THESE
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO BE INCLUDED
IN FUNDING. SIMILAR TO OTHER
SCHOOL BASED ON OUR PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION AND SUB. COMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE TO SUPPORT- A BLOCK
GRANT FOR THIS- HE'S- THANK YOU.
I'LL REMIND MEMBERS- BECAUSE
IT'S RELEVANT TO MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN PULLED
OFF. DATA IF YOU KNOW BEING IN
OUR AGENDA THAT WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TODAY OR THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT. THE
PROPOSAL AND PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE JUST REMIND PEOPLE
THAT THAT CONTINUES TO GIVE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CRAFT THE
SPECIFIC AROUND. REBEL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS ON ISSUE ONE
EDUCATION. THANK YOU SEEN NONE.
SENATOR STERN DO ME A FAVOR YOU
SEE THAT MICROPHONE ON THE
PODIUM RIGHT THERE TO THE SIDE
IF YOU COULD PUT IT ON THE
FLOOR BECAUSE IT MAKES ME THINK.
PROBABLY HERE HAS- MICA AND I'M
GONNA GET WHIPLASH CONTINUE TO
LOOK OVER THERE ALL DAY THANK
YOU. IT'S HARD ENOUGH SEEN
THROUGH THE GLASS THE NON
TRYING TO COVER EVERYBODY. OKAY
CONTINUE NON UNDER SOMEONE
EDUCATION GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SIX DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ACCESS EDUCATIONAL
REVENUE AUGMENTATION FUN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PAGE
FIVE- LA. YES THANK YOU MANAGER
BRIAN FROM THE LA- THIS IS A
MAJOR REASON HOLES ALL THAT
WOULD AUTHORIZE A BILL TO FOR
COUNTIES WHEN THEIR- YOUNGER
CONTROLLER BUT DOES NOT
VALIDATE. YOU WERE ASKED
PROPERTY TAX DOLLARS TO CATER
TO ALL SCHOOLS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH GUIDANCE TO BE PROVIDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT. AND IT'S- THANK
YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM- FROM A
FINANCE. NO COMMENTS EXCEPT TO
SAY THAT- THIS IS A PROPOSAL
MAKE SURE THAT ALL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE COMPLYING
WITH STABLE ON PROPER GUIDANCE
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THE BILL. MADAM
CHAIR OF SUB I'D LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT WE HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN- THE PENALTY AFFECTS ONLY
FIVE BEAR COUNTY SANTA CLARA-
SAN MATTEO SAN FRANCISCO MARIN
AND NAPA IF APPROVED- SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. FOR A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
ON TOP OF THEIR CURRENT- BUDGET
SHORTFALL TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION- IN THEIR BUDGET.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE KNOW
THE COUNTIES WERE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS WITH THE
STATE. FURTHERMORE THE DISK
BRAVE AND WE CANNOT. ZERO SHARE
INCORRECTLY OR NOT. I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER NOT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE BY LAW IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR GUIDANCE IN
AUDITING COUNTY DISTRIBUTION OF
THE PROPERTY TAX THE STATE
COMPTROLLER HAS IN FACT AUDITED
THE FIVE COUNTIES REGULARLY AND
THOSE AUDITS HAVE BEEN CLEAN.
IT'S TOTALLY APPROPRIATE THEN
CIVIL PENALTIES OF 10% PLUS ONE
ON ONE AND A HALF PERCENT A
MONTH OR GO RETROACTIVE WHICH I
FIND IT VERY OFFENSIVE. SAYS
THERE IS NO PARTICULAR WRITTEN
RULE- ON COUNTIES WHEN THIS
CONTROLLER HAS NEVER HAD ANY
FINDING THIS IS REPRESENTS
SERVE AN X. IMPOSITION OF
PENALTIES FINES. OF A ON-
CHARGES TO THE COUNTIES. THE
SCHOOLS DO NOT ACTUALLY BENEFIT
THIS MONEY THAT IT OFFSETS THE
STATE GENERAL FUND WITH THE
STATE IS CLEAR CLEARING A
HAVING A MAJOR BUDGET FIGHTS
CRIME. IT IS AN ANY REASON TO
TAKE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
FROM ONGOING SERVICES FROM
COUNTIES AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE LEADING THE
FIGHT AGAINST- THE COKE HEAD
AND ALSO SUFFERING THE SAME
BUDGET IMPACTS. IS PATRICIA
CONCERNING. THIS THE RESULT IN
ONGOING HARM TO COUNTIES AND
ONLY THE FIVE BAY AREA COUNTIES
IS NOT ELIGIBLE- IN MY COUNTIES
PARTICULAR SITUATION. OF THE
MONEY- THAT IS CUT OUT. WELL
PARTICULAR CHILD CARE IN THE-
GRAMS. BUT MOST OF IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. SO IF WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT PASSED THE FINES
PASSED THE- ACTIONS THAT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
DISAGREES WITH THE STATE
CONTROLLER AND THE COUNTY
AUDITOR'S IN THE COUNTY
CONTROLLERS. LET'S SIT DOWN AND
WORK IT OUT LET'S NOT LET'S NOT
HAVE A UNILATERAL IMPOSITION
OF- AN EX POST FACTO FIND
SYSTEM TO GRAB SOME MONEY. FOR
THE STATE BUDGET SO WHERE ARE
JOB. OF OPPOSING NESS AND WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THIS ITEM ON PUT
ON- HOLD AND HELD OPEN FOR
CONTINUED DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
SENATOR BILL RESTATE WHAT I
SAID EARLIER I THINK ON THE
RECOMMENDATION. THE CASUAL SEE
THROUGHOUT WHEN IT DEALS WITH
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SENATE'S
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS THIS IS THE FINAL
OF THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND SO WE WILL BE HOLDING ITEMS
OPEN TODAY- BUT- TV I'LL- BE
NEGOTIATED I'M SURE YOU AND ALL
OF THE- REPRESENTATION OF
CANADA WILL BE DIRECTLY. YEAH
THANK YOU I'M SURE SPEAKER. THE
REASON I RAISE IT TODAY WERE.
SIDE THE MEETING WAS YOU RAISE
YOUR MY CALLED POLICE EXCUSE ME
THE REASON I RAISE THIS TODAY
pANOTHER WAY IS BECAUSE THIS IS
A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY THIS
LIKE- COULD BE. COUNTIES OF
CLOSE TO THREE TO FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND SO THIS
WOULD BLOW A PRETTY BIG HOLE IN
THE BUDGET. REALIZE THAT BUT I
THINK IT'S UNFAIR IT'S-
APPROPRIATE I THINK IT HAS TO
BE WORKED OUT- WE ARE WE ARE.
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS LAST
MINUTE. THREE TO FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR HIT ON THE FIVE
COUNTY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER NIELSEN MANAGER
LIKE RE VISIT THE RESOLUTION ON
THE PREVIOUS ISSUE RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE HERE. BUT HE HAD MADE
A MOTION AND THEN I THINK YOUR
ANSWER WAS THAT THAT ISSUE
WOULD BE DISCUSSED AND DEALT
WITH IN A SEPARATE. BILL IS
THAT CORRECT. WHAT I SAW WAS IS
IF YOU LOOK AT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THE PROPOSAL IS
TO A TRY TO ADOPT PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN AS WE
KNOW. CUSTOM THAT MEANS THAT WE
DOT EVERY I AND CROSS EVERY T.
IN THE TECH IN TERMS THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE INSULT
STILL UP FOR NEW. YEAH AND SO.
TRAILER BILL. WILL COME BEFORE
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE THEN FOR
REVIEW. ALL UP THE NUMBER. GOOD
QUESTION THREE TWELVE I THINK
IS MY RECOLLECTION THE ANSWER
IS NO- THEY WILL COME UP FOR
THE VOTE ON THE FULL SENATE
FLOOR. THE BUT WOULD LEAVE MY
COLLEAGUES RECOURSE TO MAKE AN
AMENDMENT OFFERED ON THE FLOOR
BECAUSE HE'S NOT BEEN AFFORDED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
SORT OF REACH A RESOLUTION ON
IS CONCERNED WITH THE FIRST
ITEM. HE WAS A FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND
REYES IT AND I RESPONDED SO.
WHAT'S THE NEW ASK. WELL HE HE
MADE A MOTION AND THERE WAS NO
DETERMINATION OF YOUR- RULING
ON THE MOTION I GUESS THAT'S A
CONCERN SO WHERE THAN IS HE
GOING TO GET TO DISCUSS HIS
CONCERN ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
ITEM HE DID NOT GET TO EXPRESS
IT HERE- WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER. MORALE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO STAND UP AND PROVIDE FURTHER
CLARITY ON AND WHAT YOUR ACTUAL
MOTION WOULD BE. YEAH I'M JUST
GOING TO RE READ IT AGAIN
BECAUSE THIS IS MY MOTION. FROM
OUR MOTION. IS THIS PROPOSAL
EXCLUDES NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS SO I MOVED TO A
MAN TO- ALLOW THOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
FUNDING SIMILAR TO OTHER SCHOOL
BASED ON OUR PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION SOMEONE. SO WHAT WE
WILL DO A SENATOR MORALE IS ADD
THAT WHEN IT COMES TIME FOR US
TO ACTUALLY TAKE VOTES BECAUSE
AS YOU SEE WE'RE NOT TAKING
VOTE ON EACH ITEM NOW WE CAN
HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT WILL TAKE
THE VOTE. AND SO AS WE PULLED
OFTEN SEPARATED AND VOTES PER
THE REQUEST OF YOUR CAUCUS WILL
ADD YOUR MOTION TO THE BOAT AND
WE CAN SPLIT THE VOTE WE CAN
VOTE ON. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND THEN WE CAN
ALSO. IN YOU CAN PULL THAT UP
AND DOWN AND WILL ADD YOUR
LANGUAGE AND CAN VOTE ON YOUR
MOTION AS WELL. IS THAT MAJOR
EIGHT. THAT WORKS GREAT SENATOR
PAN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST HAD A QUESTION IN TERMS OF
OUR OVERALL PROCESS RECOGNIZING
WORDS IN A SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
MODES. AS WE ARE TOPPING THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE BUDGET I
ASSUME THEY SHOULDN'T ASSUME IT
IS TO SOME SORT OF CUT. HE
BETWEEN VISERYS ALREADY
COMPLETED THE SENATE THERE'S
DISCUSSES THE GOVERNOR WHATEVER
FINAL VERSION THEN. AS A COME
BACK TO SENATE BUDGET BEFORE WE
PASS IT ON TO THE FLOOR ARE WE
GUYS PASSED THAT STREET NOW. IS
HE IN THE PAST SIR YEAH THIS
THIS HEARING WE PASS THE SENATE
VERSION RIGHT- THEY THEN GO TO
CONFERENCE. AND THE NOTE WHAT
COMES OUT OF CONFERENCE GOES
DIRECTLY TO THE FLOOR OKAY AND
I'M BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THE RECORD FROM THE BACK OF THE
ROOM. THE COUPLE BACK FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR ABOUT
RIGHT BEFORE IT COMES TO FLOOR
FOR A VOTE. OKAY IS SO I DID TO
CLARIFY THAT ADVICE ROUTE WITH
CORRECTLY AND MADE. MY MEMORY
SOMETIMES FAULT. WELL YOURS IS
BETTER ON BECAUSE AT THAT WE
WENT FROM THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY FROM THE
FLOOR BUT BEEN CORRECTED. IF
THERE IS ANY. TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. THEY ALL THE REVIEW
BY OUR FULL COMMITTEE SO I
THINK PROCESS WHY. THIS WILL
TRAILER HOLD THE HOLDING WITH
WHICH WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IS A FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO FINALLY DECIDE. TO
VOTE ON. A TRAILER BILL ONCE IF
IT AT THAT TIME APPROPRIATE
CORRECT CORRECT THANK YOU THE
MANAGER UNTIL TO RESTATE.
MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE FINAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BEFORE IT
ACTUALLY COMES TO THE FLOOR FOR
A VOTE. I STAND CORRECTED ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE
ON INCIDENTS MORALIS CLEAR THAT
WE WILL ADD HIS MOTION WHEN WE
CHOOSE TO VOTE ON EITHER PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OR
THE LANGUAGE THAT STUDENTS FROM
MORALIS FOR. HOUSING ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE ON.
GREAT SEEN NONE LET'S MOVE ON
TO. ISSUE SIXTY EIGHT IF YOU'LL
BE IF YOU FIFTY NINE THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL BACK BILL
FOR LOSS OF NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES HELLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JENNY
FELLOW WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY KNOWN OR DID I THE
REVENUE STREAMS THAT SUPPORT
REALIGNMENT ARE ALSO IMPACTED
BY THE- AND ARE EXPECTED TO
EXPERIENCE A REVENUE DECLINED
BUDGET YEAR. THE SENATE PACKAGE
WOULD PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION- TOWARDS THAT DECLINING
REVENUE. THANK YOU FINANCING
THE COMMENT. NO COMMENT YOUR
MANAGER. QUESTION FROM
COMMITTEE THIRTY MORE LOCK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
SACRAMENTO'S HAD A PRACTICE OF
PUSHING FUNCTIONS DOWN TO THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND THEN PROVIDING
MINIMAL FUNDING. THAT'S EVEN
HINT THAT REALIGNMENT FUNDING
COULD BE JEOPARDIZED WOULD BE
DAMAGING TO FUTURE ATTEMPTS OF
A SIMILAR NATURE SO. I SUPPORT
THIS RECOMMENDATION BUT IT IS A
TRIGGER- ITEM SO I AM- EXCEL
GUY AND I. HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE
TO LIKE. DO THE BUDGET IN A
MANNER THAT. WOULD PROVIDE FOR
ALTERNATIVES IF FEDERAL FUNDING
DOESN'T COME IN AS EXPECTED AND
I WAS SORT OF HOPING TO HEAR.
OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE
DON'T GET. THE EXPECTED. DOLLAR
AMOUNT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHAT IF IT IS 90%
WHAT IF IT'S 75% FIFTY PERCENT-
AND SO I AM CONCERNED BECAUSE-
THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IS FOR CRITICAL HUMAN SERVICES
AND I SEE IT AS A FIX CARS BUT
NOT AS SOMETHING THAT COULD BE.
NATIVE CERTAIN FUNDING LEVELS
AREN'T CHEAP SO. IT MAY BE THE
LA- OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COULD JUST GIVE ME A LITTLE TO
TOUR REAL BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE.
COLUMNS IN NUMBERS AND WHAT IFS.
THE MANAGER IF YOU COULD
INDULGE ME SURE SO FINANCE
COULD RESPOND BECAUSE I THINK-
THE THAT WAS INCLUDED AS I
RECALL IN ONE OF YOUR INITIAL
TRIGGERS AS WELL AND SO FINANCE
COULD YOU RESPOND. YES OUR SON
BRIEF. I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
KRISTIN SHELTON IS ON THE LINE
AS WELL AS TO DECLARE FIND THIS
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL. IS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSED ON
MEDICATION FROM THE SENATE SO
THIS SPECIFIC FRIEDMAN FINDING
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
SENATOR. THAT IS NOT IN OUR
PROPOSALS WE DO HAVE A PROPOSED
ASK FOR OUR CREDIT IRIS RELIEF
FUND ALLOCATION NINE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGETS ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE BILLION UNDER
OUR PROPOSAL. THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD GO TO THE COUNTIES FOR
SOCIAL AND RELATED. SERVICES
BUT I THINK YOUR BROADER
QUESTION CENTER MORE WATCHES
ABOUT. THE OPERATION OF THE
TRIGGER AND I CAN SPEAK WITH
YOU MISTER NICE PROPOSED IN
THAT AREA. IN WAYS- UNDER OUR-
GOAL WICKS CONGRESS. WOULD HAVE
TO PROVIDE. OR NOW. INFLEXIBLE
RELEASE MONDAY FOR THAT TRIGGER
TO BE TODAY FOR THOSE CUTS
TRIGGERED A- FOR ANY WITHIN
THAT TRIGGER. YOU GOING TO BACK
TO I KNOW THAT SENT. ON
PROPOSAL HAS SOME DIFFERENT
ITEMS TRIGGER NOT HERE TO WHAT
WE HAVE SEC SPEAK TO THOSE
SPECIFIC ITEMS BUT IF THEY ARE
GOING ON. SIMILAR. IF YOU. ALL
NOT FROM THE TRIGGER BEING ON A-
NOT SAID I DO TO CLEAR THAT IF
WE DO RISK FEDERAL. THAT COMES
IN SOME. AMOUNT LAST. OVERALL
FOR BILLION DOLLAR NUMBER.
FUNDING DOESN'T GO AWAY. IT'S
JUST THE K. THAT LIKE. WOULD
HAVE TO. ON OWN AND WHAT IT
COME BACK I'M NOT A YOU. SOME
HOT SEPARATE OTHERWISE BE
TAKING FOR YOU THE CASE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT TO LIST
INCREASE WOULD NO LONGER BE GO
FORWARD. AND DO YOU HAVE A DAY.
THE DATE WHEN YOUR EX THIS
FUNDING WILL BE FIFTH. OR IF IT
HAPPENED AFTER. THE YEAH SO
UNDER THEN THE REVISION
PROPOSAL IF WE DO NOT RECEIVE
A- BY THE TIME THAT THIS BUDGET
IS ENACTED THESE CUTS ARE
SCHEDULED GO INTO EFFECT ON
JULY FIRST NINETEEN SAID UNDER
THAT LANGUAGE YES I FUNDING IS
AT ANY POINT OVER THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. THE END OF JUNE
TWENTY ONE X. THEN DOES WOULD
BE RESTORED ONCE FUNDING IS
HERE AND I KNOW THAT HAS BEEN A
ITEM DISCUSSION OUR STAFF HERE
AT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
WORKS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ON ON YOUR HOW THIS WILL.
REALLY SHOULD BE DATE BUT OUR
CURRENT PROPOSAL IS THE CUTS
WILL GO TO THE FACT. THAT THE
SCHOOL YEAR I WE CAN PASS
NECESSARY THERE BALANCE THE
BUDGET ANY POINT OVER THE YEAR-
SO SIX CONGRESS PASSES SUCH
FUNDING. ALL WINTER EVENING
NEXT SPRING THIS CUTS WHICH
TRIGGERED BACK ON THAT HE SAID
THE ADMINISTRATION CERTAINLY
QUESTION A- FEDERAL PARTNERS
WATCHING. CERTAIN HEREBY
PLANNING AT A ISSUE ALL TO
PROVIDE FUNDING IS. SO I GUESS
I WOULD WHAT I SAID WHEN I
START MATT IS. WE HAVE SOME STE
RELATES WITH COUNT EVERY TIME
WE GO RESEARCH IT'S SOMEHOW
COUNTIES ARE GETTING HAMMERED.
BUT I'M SURE YOU'LL APPRECIATE
THIS SOON. BUT IT IS A IT
DIFFICULT. COUNTY VERSES
SACRAMENTO KIND OF DYNAMIC
WHERE THE COUNTIES ARE SORT OF
POWER LIST JUST. HAVE TO GO
WITH THE FLOW AND I JUST WINNER
FIRM YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
KEEPING THIS SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
BUT I WANT TO BE REAL CAREFUL
ABOUT THIS TRIGGER CONCEPT
BECAUSE- OUR COUNTIES WILL HAVE
TO SUPPORT A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE. IN NEED AND SO THAT THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS AND I JUST
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME NO
PROBLEM JUST TO CLARIFY THAT
THE LA- WOULD WOULD PLEASE WAY
AND TO MAKE THE DISTINCTION
COULD YOU ASK ABOUT A DATE AND
THE SENATE PROPOSAL AND THE
SENATE ARCHITECTURE IS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT. AND THAT'S AN
EFFECTIVE DATE OF A AGAIN IT
BURGER- THAT'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WITH THE
MINISTRATIONS RECALLS AND THAT
DATE IS OCTOBER ONE PERSON BY
ONE. ELLIE OKAY YOU. EXPAND ON
THAT AGAIN IN TERMS OF THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE DIFFERENCE
OF THE TRIGGER. YES MADAM CHAIR
MY YES MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SENATE PACKAGES THAT. THE
BUDGET WOULD BE A ASSUME THAT
THE FEDERAL ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
EIGHTY IS FORTHCOMING AND THAT
WE WOULD RECEIVE IT. AND AT
THAT POINT- YOU KNOW THE-
FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED BUT
THEN IF IT'S NOT IF THE MOVE IF
THE FUNDING DID NOT MATERIALIZE
BY OCTOBER FIRST THE TRIGGER IN
THE SENATE PACKAGES IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION IT IN IT
WOULD REDUCE THE FUNDING AT
THAT POINT. IN THE YEAR. I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD WANT TO
SUPPLEMENT THAT BUT. THE
MANAGER I JUST AGAIN JUST WHEN
OUR FIRM THAT. WHO COUNTIES IN
OUR OUR SUBSIDIARIES OF THE
STATE AND IF WE YANK FUNDS FROM
THEM. AND THEY'RE DOING ARE
BIDDING OF THAT THAT COULD HAVE
SOME REVERBERATIONS AND
REPERCUSSIONS AT. YEAH COULD
COULD NOT CREATE ANGST FOR
YEARS AND DECADES SO AGAIN I
AFFIRM YOU FOR KEEPING THE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IN- BUT I WOULD
REALLY WANT ENCOURAGE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOT TO HOLD
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HOSTAGE AND
HOLD IT OVER FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ON THIS ITEM.
CRITICS SEEN NONE WILL MOVE
INTO SUB FOR STATE
ADMINISTRATION. ISSUES TWENTY
EIGHT AND TWENTY NINE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS WORKER
STATUS EMPLOYEES AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. HELLO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GRANULAR FROM THE
LA AGAIN THESE TWO ITEMS.
RELATED TO TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE STAFFING AT
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. HIS NAME THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. TEMPLE MAN AB FIVE
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. FINANCE. SO
THEY SAID TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IS IN OUR NAY REVISION-
PROPOSAL AND WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS. I DON'T REMEMBER
WHO PULLED IT QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE. ONE
EIGHTY FIVE IMPLEMENTATION
SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM CHAIR
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THE- IMPLEMENTATION IN
THE ENFORCEMENT OF AB FIVE AT
THIS PARTICULAR TIME IT'S KIND
OF A POLICY CONSIDERATION ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE
BY HIRING THE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AT THIS POINT IN TIME
IS THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
DISCUSS THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE
IN DEPTH. IT IS SOMEWHAT IS OF
CONCERN ABOUT THE LEGISLATION
AND TO ITSELF BUT ALSO THE
STAFFING UP AND WHAT IS THAT
GONNA LOOK LIKE WHO ARE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHAT WILL BE THEIR
STATUS. HELLO LEVY WHO BOUGHT A-
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO. I THINK
THIS IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
DURING A TIME LIKE THIS. WHEN
ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT. THERE ARE THE RULES
THE GOVERNOR WORKPLACE ARE
GOING TO BE ENFORCED AND ALL
THE MORE REASON. THAT WE SHOULD
DO IT SO I AM I SUPPORT DHEA
INCLUSION THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
MELENDEZ. THE THANK YOU AND I'M
SURE I'M JUST WONDERING IF WE
CAN GET- A RESPONSE TO SENATOR
NIELSEN'S QUESTIONS THAT YOU
POSED. FROM WHO FINANCE AT WHO
WHOWOULD YOU LIKE WHO WHOEVER
IS ABLE TO ANSWER AT THIS
POINT. DEPARTMENT FINANCE. CAN
YOU MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS COOK IS
ON THE LINE TO CAN YOU REPEAT
SENATOR NELSON SINGLES AND
COULD YOU SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPROCESSOR. YEAH BECAUSE I
HEARD A GENERAL'S OF CONCERN
ABOUT THE BILL BUT IF THERE'S A
PARTICULAR QUESTION. WELL THE
S. IN TERMS OF THE STAFFING UP
AS YOU ARE NOW PROPOSING HERE
THE STAFFING UP WHAT ARE THE
SPECIFICS OF HOW THAT'S GOING
TO WORK WILL THIS BE SHORT TERM
FOR THE POSITIONS- LIMITED TERM
FULL TIME POSITIONS. WHAT ARE
OR WHAT LOOK AT IN KIND WITH
VISUAL WHAT SORT OF AN AND FOR.
PERSON BEHIND BRING WHAT WE
PATIENT OF THEIR HIRING WHAT
WOULD BE THE RESPONSIBILITIES.
YES NELSON ALTERNATE ALREADY
MICHAEL CHRIS. YES CHRIS COOK
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND SO-
EIGHTY FIVE WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
AND ACKNOWLEDGING THE
IMPORTANCE OF APPROPRIATELY
CLASSIFYING THOSE WORKERS
SPECIFICALLY- THE THEIR REQUEST
THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING BEFORE
US- MY EMPLOYEE CERTAIN THE
BILL PROVIDES PROTECTIONS. FOR
EMPLOYEES AND- LIKE THE CALL SO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT MORE
SPECIFICALLY- THERE WAS THERE'S
TWO COMPONENTS OF IT WHICH
ACTUALLY THE SMALLER COMPONENT
IS THE ENFORCEMENT BUT THE BULK
OF THE REQUEST INCLUDES-
FUNDING FOR THE EDUCATION OF
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION AS A-
OF THE EXPANDED EMPLOYEE BASE
FOR THIS CLASSIFICATION OF
THESE WORKERS- HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH MORE DETAILED SPECIFICS
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL. FIGHTING IN
THE BALKANS FOR THE INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO PROVIDE THE
EDUCATION OF THOSE- OF THOSE
CLAIMS- MORE SPECIFICALLY THE
COSTS OF. THE EMPLOYEES AFTER
UP IT'S THREE TURN BASIS AND SO
THIS WILL ALLOW US TIME TO.
EVALUATE WORKLOAD AND IT TO THE
THAT THAT WORK LOW DOES
DECREASE THEN WILL BE
ADDRESSING THE BUDGET
ACCORDINGLY WHEN THAT TIME
COMES. THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT
I WOULD DRIVE EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION TO PAY SIX PAID SIXTY
NINE OF THE AGENDA. AGAIN ISSUE
TWENTY NINE. WHERE IT- ITEMIZE
IS THE HUNDRED AND THREE AND A
HALF POSITION SIR. OR
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE AS
FOLLOWS THE VISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION SIXTY THREE
POSITIONS TO ADJUDICATE MANAGE
WORKERS COMP CLAIMS. DIVISION
OF LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
TWENTY SIX POINT FIVE POSITIONS
TO INVESTIGATE VIOLATIONS ARE
CONDUCT OUT REACH. DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
TWO POSITIONS INSPECTIONS AND
DIVISION OF ADMINISTRATION
TWELVE SUPPORT STAFF POSITIONS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
MORE LAW THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. BEEN BEEN REALLY
CONCERT UNDERGROUND ECONOMY- IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE EMPLOYERS
THAT ARE PAYING EVERYTHING
PAYROLL TAXES WORKERS COMP
MEDICAL INSURANCE- AND- I'VE
I'VE NEVER SEEN THIS KIND OF
ATTENTION PUT ON THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY WHY IS THE
EDT GIVEN. UP FUNDING TO GO
AFTER THOSE THAT AREN'T PAYING
WORKERS COMP IN AND PAYING. THE
DEBTS UNDER THE TABLE AND SOUL
SPOUSES ARE FORMER SPOUSES ARE
GETTING PAID AND I WORK WITH
CENTER MINING ON BILLS THANK
YOU SOMETHING WITH WITHOUT
GOING TO. WE'RE GOING OUT A
CONTRACTORS AND- INTO THAT ARE
READY IS TEN NINETY NINE AND IN
THE IN THE WRIST. FOR TAKING
CARE OF SOCIAL SECURITY TAXES
THE REST- SO I'M JUST
WONDERING. IF FOR IF WE'RE
GETTING A LITTLE TOO AGGRESSIVE
IN AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES AND THEY
WERE STILL LIVING UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY ALONE. SO I JUST MAKE
THAT IS A COMMENT TO IT. IT IS
IF YOU WANT TO FIND REVENUE.
ONE OF MY GOOD REVENUE- IT THE
OUT ON CONTRACTS BY THE U.
DISHONEST GUYS AND- AND WE'VE
GOT TO GET THIS ECONOMY GOING
AND THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO
FOCUS OUR FINANCES THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU SET THE
MINING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND JUST TO COMMENT ON THIS
FRAME OF DISCUSSION AND RESPECT
THE WORK THAT I'VE DONE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ON UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY. OVER THE PAST YEARS
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF A
COLLABORATION UP ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND STREAMLINING THE
ABILITY TO GO AFTER THOSE BAD
ACTORS IN THE GROUND ECONOMY I
WOULD SHE YES THE PROPOSAL. SIX
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE IS
GETTING THE APPROPRIATE LEGAL
CONTRIBUTION. TO SUPPORT. ARE
UNABLE TO SUPPORT OTHER
MECHANISMS FOR WE KNOW SOME
EMPLOYERS RIGHT NOW ARE
BENEFITING FROM THE P. WAY BUT
HAVE PAID NOTHING INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I THINK
THIS GOES TO AN EQUITY ISSUE DO
WE AS TAXPAYERS TO SUPPORT
THESE COSTS OR DO WE ASK. WELL
THAT HAVE BEEN MISCLASSIFIED TO
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE SO JUST
MAYBE A ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE AS
WE LOOK AT THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SEEN THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FIFTY THREE AGAIN STILL
IN SUB FOR STATE
ADMINISTRATION. STATEWIDE
ISSUES SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILL AND THAT'S
ON PAGE SEVENTY SEVEN. MEMBERS
OF YOUR AGENDA. LA JOH. YES
TRUE SO TOWARD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
THIS- SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION BILL WOULD
PROVIDE GENERAL FUND FOR
UNANTICIPATED COSTS
EXPERIENCED- BY SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS IN THE NEW TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET YEAR
THIS INCLUDES FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION LEVIN POINT
EIGHT MILLION COMPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICE IS FORTY THREE
BILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE SEVENTY
OUT RELATED TO HOMICIDE TRIALS.
AND EIGHT MILLION REALLY TO-
WILDFIRE AND PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF COSTS-
EXPERIENCE BY VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS. THANK YOU FINANCE.
ANY COMMENT. COMMENT AND SHARE
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS. YOUR MORE LOT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S NUMBER FIFTY TWO ON MY-
LIST OF ITEMS I DO NOT HAVE A
FIFTY THREE AM I. MISSING A
PAGE. ITEM FIFTY THREE ARE YOU
I DON'T KNOW YOU MADE AS IT IS
FIFTY THREE TITLED STATEWIDE
ISSUES. YES IT IS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN. MILLION YES SIR OKAY
THAT THAT'S MY FIFTY TWO THANK
YOU. AND SO- LET ME LET ME KNOW
I'LL GET CLEAR SINCE. IT BY NO
THAT WAS A MEMBER OF YOUR
CAUCUS THAT HOLD IT DIDN'T DO
IT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE
RIGHT ISSUE THE ISSUE THAT YOU
THAT SOMEONE HAD CONCERN OVER
WAS AT ISSUE FIFTY TWO OR FIFTY
THREE. I WANNA MAKE SURE WE PUT
THE RIGHT ISSUE SENATOR NELSON.
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION IN THE
NUMBER OF PAGES HERE MADAM
CHAIR SO HAPTICS USERS WERE
FINED UNTANGLE IT THAT'S OKAY
THE ISSUE OF CONCERN HERE WOULD
BE A RELATED TO THE- AT RECALL
THE FAIRS. AND AFFAIRS AND THE
FUNDING- THAT FOR STATE VISIT
FOR FAIR DISABILITIES AND THEN
THE IMPACT ON THE DISTRICT
FAIRS THE SMALLER ONES. THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET AT GOT
IT SO THAT IS OKAY SO IN IN
MIND INTO THAT ISSUE FIFTY
THREE BUT AGAIN IT IS THE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL. SO LET ME JUST READ IT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE AGAIN THIS MEASURE
PROVIDES NINETEEN TWENTY
GENERAL FUND FOR UNANTICIPATED
COSTS FOR SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS.
INCLUDING DEPARTMENT FULLER
FORESTRY DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS GENERAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OF OOD AND AG.
FAIRS THE LEGALLY OBLIGATED
STAFF PAINT STAFF PAYMENTS
HOMICIDE TRIAL REIMBURSEMENT.
IN VARIOUS DEPARTMENT WHILE
FIRING PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
UP. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
RIGHT ISSUE SIR. IT SURE TO THE
CONCERNED. AND WOOD RELATED TO
THE HOMELESS ISSUE TOO EARLY ON
THERE WAS A DESIRE TO. MOVE
HOMELESS INTO THE- FACILITIES
IN THE COUNTIES FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS GOT IT
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THE-
YOU THAT OCCUPY VALUABLE SPACE
HOUSING THE HOMELESS WHICH THE
FAIRS USED TO GENERATE INCOME.
THEY DON'T GET MUCH HELP THE
STATE SO THEY HAVE TO GENERATE.
INCOME FROM THEIR FACILITIES
AND THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
THEN IS THAT HOMELESS
POPULATION WOULD IMPEDE THEIR
ABILITY TO MAKE MONEY. AND IN
ADDITION THESE FAIRGROUNDS ARE
CRITICAL STAGING AREAS FOR.
NATURAL DISASTERS FIRES FLOODS
PARTICULARLY AND IF YOU'VE GOT
HOMELESS BEING HOUSED THERE
THEN YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE FACILITY FOR E.
VANCE FOR WHICH YOU DERIVE
INCOME SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
NATURE OF THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
SIR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT OPINION THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I DID HAVE A
QUESTION REGARDING AT CAL EXPO
WITH FOR THERE IS. A NEED FOR.
CAL BOTH ALSO HAS HAD DIED I
MEAN TECHNICALLY THE STATE
AGENCY BUT WE HAVE OUR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY FAIR THERE
IT'S ALSO A STAGING AREA. WE'RE
ACTUALLY HOUSING SOME HOMELESS
OVER THERE BUT- MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY THE PROBLEM IS
THAT NORMALLY IT SUSTAINS
ITSELF THROUGH THE ACTIVITIES
AT THE FAIR BOTH DID THAT
HASN'T BUT YET WE CONTINUE TO
FIND IT FOR STATE EMERGENCY
ROOM UP INTO WHETHER FOR. FUN
FOR THE BEARS ALSO INCLUDED CAL
BUT SOMETIMES GETS TREATED
DIFFERENTLY THAN THE OTHER
DISTRICT FAIRS BECAUSE IT IS A
STATE AGENCY OFFICIALLY.
FINANCE FINANCE YES YES- ON
BOTH SIDES CENTER NIELSEN AND
SENATOR PANTS QUESTION I WANT
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE RESOURCES
TEAM SO THEY SHOULD BE UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
RESOURCE TAB- ON THE LINE AND
SEARCHABLE OUR ON OUR TEAM
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HANDLE
QUESTIONS. RIGHT NOW DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION THAT'S ENOUGH TO LOOK
OVER REGION BILL REALLY FOCUSED
ON THE LEGALLY AMANDA ACOSTA
HORSENS. NEEDED FAIRS AS LITTLE
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE DOES NEED
TO CANCEL THAT WOULD. MAKE YOU
ELIGIBLEFOR. SORRY I HAD
TROUBLE HEARING YOU IS CAL EXPO
PART OF THE FUNDING. THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDING AS
THEY ARE ESTATE THAT THEY
NEEDED FAIR OKAY THANK YOU
ELIGIBLE OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIRTY
NIELSEN. THIS IS THE DESIRED.
OR IS IT STILL THE GOAL THEN TO
PLACE THE END TO THESE
FAIRGROUNDS HOMELESS PEOPLE FOR
THEIR RESIDENCY IS IT ARE WE
STILL MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION.
FINANCE. RIGHT WELL I AM
FORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION I'M NOT SURE OF MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS COOK WHO DEALS
WITH A HOMELESSNESS I HAD ANY
FURTHER INFORMATION YOU'RE NOT
LOOKING AT BACKING. WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND GET BACK TO ME THAT
IT IS. OF SOME IMPORT OKAY.
THAT PARTICULARLY FOR THE
STAGING AREA WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE- FACILITIES ENCUMBERED.
FOR PURPOSES OTHER THAN THE
NEED TO RESPOND TO THAT
EMERGENCY OR THE HIGHEST VALUE
CAN BE ATTAINED BY THAT
PARTICULAR DISTRICT FAIR. TO
RUNNING FACILITIES LEASING
FACILITIES. AND I'LL REMIND US
I THINK THAT THERE THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES HAVE A
PROPOSAL OF EXTENDING THEIR-
PROJECT ROOM KEY IN TERMS OF
PERMIT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
IN WAYS IN WHICH THEY HOW ARE
ON MOST FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS DURING COLD AND
THERE. ARE TERM PLAN AND SO WE
MAY BE HEARD ABOUT THAT THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE TO THE BUDGET
AS WELL. ALRIGHT WE CAN MOVE ON
TO THE FINAL I. ON OUR- AGENDA.
WHICH IS SUB FIVE PUBLIC SAFETY.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL BAND THE BOX TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE PAGE EIGHTY FOUR.
L. L. YES THIS IS JERRY SORT OF
WORK WITH LA- AGAIN ON THIS IS-
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
POST SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS FROM ASKING ABOUT
AN APPLICANT'S CRIMINAL HISTORY
AT ANY TIME BEFORE A FINAL
DECISION IS MADE ON THE
APPLICANT'S APPLICATION DOES
EXEMPT- PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS
HOST ACADEMY COURSE WORK. THANK
YOU IN THE COMING FINANCE. NO
COMMENT BUT AS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS BY CALLING YOUR
ADWORDS IS ON THE LINE AS WELL
GREAT CITIZENS BILL SEN. WELL
THIS IS A MAJOR POLICY ISSUE-
OR WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING ON THIS ISSUE ANOTHER
POLICY COMMITTEES. FINANCES AT
ALL. EIGHT IT IT IT IS A PART
OF THE SENATE PROPOSALS I'M AS
I RECALL AND I BELIEVE IT WAS
HEARD IN IN SUB FIVE. WAS IT.
THE SKINNER. COULD YOU BIG TO
BAN THE BOX DID YOU HEAR IT IN
SUB FIVE YES WE DID. WELL AS
READERS MAY BE MY ONLY PLACE
TO. RAISE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ISSUE THEN. OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT POTENTIALLY VERY
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS. AND IT
CONCERNS ME THAT'S I GUESS
THAT'S MY POINT WAS WAS THAT
THE SUBJECT SENATOR OF YOUR
DISCUSSION AND SUBCOMMITTEE
ABOUT THAT THE SENATOR SKINNER
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT
ADDRESS THE ISSUE NINE EIGHT
AROUND THE ON THE BOX- AND- I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE
REFERENCE STATE BUT BECAUSE IT
WAS NOT IT WAS AN AD CODE ITEM.
WE COULD NOT- IN THE- INITIAL
HEARING WAS NOT ON WE DID NOT
CLOSE ON IT IN OUR INITIAL
HEARING WE WAS STRESSED. IT WAS.
IN THE CON OF A VARIETY OF
OTHER- ITEMS THAT WERE RELATED
TO SUPPORTING THE
ADMINISTRATION. COST SAVINGS IN
THE FUTURE YEARS IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS BASED ON SOME OBJECTIVE
STAT BOTH THE LEGISLATURE HAS
HAVE A PAST AND THE GOVERNOR
HAS STATED IN THIS BUDGET AND
IN FACT ONE ONE OF THEM IS THE
CLOSURE BE PRIVATE PRISONS AND
FIVE THERE'S IN THE BUDGET AND
TAX EXPEDITED TOP LINE ON THE-
AND OF. TWO A- TWO WHICH THOSE
OBJECTIVES THREE ENTRY SUPPORT
AND RECIDIVISM REDUCTION WHICH
REENTRY SUPPORT HELPS IS
ESSENTIAL. AND THE ABILITY TO
WE NOW AS I THINK OF MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW PROVIDE MUCH-
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN OUR STATE FACILITIES AND
THOSE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE WHO THEN
LEAVE OUR STATE FACILITIES AND
WANT TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION DE. IT COMES OKAY AND
PERHAPS SENATOR NIELSEN WAS
REFERENCING IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS AND
POST SECONDARY- LICENSING
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE NOT YOUR
TYPICAL A- NOT A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL- THE SETTING THAT IS
REQUIRED FOR THE DEGREE MIGHT
PROHIBIT A PERSON. AT A RECORD
FROM BEING THERE AND SO THAT IS
WHY IF YOU LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE
IT COMPLETELY EXEMPTS WAS
ENTIRE. THERE ARE CERTAIN ONES
THAT SHOULDN'T EXEMPTED AND
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE WILL. I DISCUSS IN A
FUTURE BILL. BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S A MUCH MORE DETAILED
DISCUSSION HOWEVER THERE IS NO
EXISTING. EXCLUSION OF ANYONE
WITH FORMER UP WITH THE FORMER
RECORD FROM A REGULAR COLLEGE
CAMPUS FOR IN PURSUIT OF THE
REGULAR DEGREE AND SO THAT IS
THE PURPOSE OF THE ITEM IS.
SENATOR ROBB. MADAM CHAIR SINCE
THE GENDER REFLECTS WE'RE
ADOPTING PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL BILL LANGUAGE IN IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE PER
CONVERSATION ABOUT CLOSELY
RELATED TRAILERS I ASSUME ONCE
THE LIGHT HIS PEN DOWN THIS TOO
WILL COME BACK THROUGH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. YES SIR IT
WILL THAT SHOULD ADDRESS MY
COLLEAGUES. FROM TO HIM IS SO
CONCERNED THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS CENTER DORADO
YES AM I HAVE A QUESTION IT AS
I UNDERSTAND THIS. IBM THE
PROHIBITION APPLIES BEFORE THE
INSTITUTIONAL THE FINAL
DECISION. ALL NOT INCLUDING THE
THAT RELATE IT IS AN EXTENSION
OF OUR STATE POLICY WE FOR
EXAMPLE ALREADY INSTEAD TO BAN
THE BOX ON. SINCE FOR STATE
EMPLOYMENT EXAMPLE IN A VARIETY
OF SO IT'S JUST AN EXTENSION OF
THAT ON THE APPLICATION TO A
COLLEGE PROGRAM NON
PROFESSIONAL. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM MANAGER
YES SENATOR MORE LINE AS A
MEMBER OF SUB FIVE JUST MAYBE
THAT. CORROBORATE WITH MY CHAIR
I DON'T MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT
WE DID NOT DISCUSS IT WAS A
HOLD OPEN. ITEM AM I WRONG
THAT'S WHY REFERENCE THAT WE
DID NOT COME CLOSE IT BECAUSE
IT WAS NOT IN OUR COAT. BUT I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE MUCH IN THE
WAY OF DISCUSSION ON THE WELL I
REFERENCED IT IN MY COMMENTS.
IT WAS A WITH A NEW OR OF OTHER.
FIVE ITEMS RELATED PROP FIFTY
SEVEN CREDIT IF THINGS LIKE
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGER AND SO IT AND AGAIN TO
CLARIFY ON THAT THAT THIS BUT
WHAT WE WILL CONSIDER IS THE
ADOPTION OF A PLACE HOLDER
LANGUAGE NOW WE HAVE ALL FERN
CLEAR THAT WILL COME BACK TO
FULL COMMITTEE ONCE THE
LANGUAGES. OVER RULED OUT UP TO.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS. ONE ISSUE
EIGHTEEN UNDER SUB FIVE PUBLIC
SAFETY. ONE FINAL CALL IF THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL ITEMS ON THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR THAT YOU
WISH TO MOVE INTO DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE AT THIS POINT WILL
INVITE THE PUBLIC TO CALL IN
FOR TESTIMONY. I LIKE TO THINK
DEPARTMENT FINANCE IN LA- FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AND IT
MIGHT INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING
TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL AND NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE. SIX TWO TWO SIX
FIVE FIVE EIGHT AND IT'S ON
YOUR SCREEN. FOR ADDITIONAL
REFERENCE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'M INSTITUTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
EACH PERSON PROVIDING COMMENT
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
ONE. MAY HAVE TO SHORTEN THE
TIME LIMIT ON THE NUMBER OF
CALLERS THAT WE HAVE AND WE
WON'T KNOW THAT UNTIL THE
MODERATOR LETS US KNOW. NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH. IS THAT ARE
HERE IN THE GALLERY THAT CHOOSE
TO TESTIFY ON ANY OF THE-
DISCUSSION ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD. LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
GALLERY AND ONE MINUTE APPLIES
TO YOU AS WELL THANK YOU. YES
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE
CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I JUST.
YOU UPDATE SEVENTY ITEMS.
THIRTY EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE
WHICH IS THE ANNA WELL
SUSPENSION IN THE TAX CREDIT
LIMITATION WE HAVE DONE AND
WELL SINCE BEEN TWICE BEFORE IN
OUR BUDGET DEFICIT SITUATIONS
IN BOTH OF THOSE INSTANCES THEY
WERE ONLY FOR TWO YEARS.
PROPOSES AND SECONDARILY WE DID
DO SOME ENHANCEMENTS TO THE
SUSPENSION WHEN IT CAME BACK
INTO EXISTENCE SO WE WOULD
ADVOCATE FOR A SHORTER TIME
LIMIT THEN THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED TO SEE PERHAPS
REINSTATE THE TO YOUR KERRY
BACK EXAMPLE ALL THE CREDIT
TATIAN OUR- THIS TAX CREDIT.
ACTED IS THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX. OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO THE HIGH TECH AND
BIOTECH INDUSTRIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CREDIT IS
CALCULATED BASICALLY ON NOT SO
MUCH EQUIPMENT BUT ACTUALLY
WAGES PAID TO HIGHLY SKILLED
AND HIGHLY PAID. THAT'S WHAT
QUALIFIES YOU CREDIT AND FORCE
THE RESEARCH HAS TO BE DONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
WOULD RAISE QUESTION WHETHER OR
NOT YOU SHOULD PROCEED WITH
THAT SUSPENSION THANK YOU ABOUT.
THANK GOODNESS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICK LOUISE
US ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS BOB
DURING THE SUB ONE PROCESS CAP
EXPRESSED SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE IMAGE
CARE RATE CUTS PROCESS HERE
RATE CHANGES ON THE CUTS IN
COMBINATION. FURTHER WE WILL-
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. WHAT WERE
YOU SEE THAT THE SENATE IS
POISED TO REJECT MANY OF THOSE
CUTS INCLUDING THOSE FOR MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THE
RESTORATION OF OPTIONAL
BENEFITS IN THE RETURN OF PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDS WILL HELP
MAINTAIN ACCESS TO SERVICES AT
FULL TIME- PAPA CENTER FOR TWO.
THE AMERICAN BUT WE ARE. THERE
IS A NEW. TO JUST THE TAX ON
MAY CARE BY A FULL BILLION
DOLLARS. MEMBERS HAVE YET TO
SEE THE FINE DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL THOUGH SOME OF THOSE
WERE DISCUSSED TODAY. IN THE
DETAILS CERTAINLY MATTER- ON AN
ISSUE- WITH THIS LEVEL OF
IMPORTANCE AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THOSE AND HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AS A RIGHT UNDER THE CURRENT
NCAA. ONE THAT IS IN PLACE I
WAS ACTUALLY REJECTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEFORE WAS
MODIFIED IN APPROVED. ON TAKING
THE NEW. RULES REGULATIONS IN
VARIOUS INTERPRETATIONS OF THE
EXISTING RULES INTO
CONSIDERATION. FEDERAL WILL GET
ENOUGH ZERO TAXES COMPLICATED.
BOMB AND NOT A SLAM DUNK FOR
LACK OF. A BETTER TERM. SO WITH
THAT. FEW UP FOR BUT FURTHER.
THANKS Q. ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY. SERGEANTS ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
COMMENT. FIFTY NINE GIVE ME ONE
SECOND COLLEAGUES.
LET ME
CLARIFY IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
COMMENT VERTICALLY TO THOSE WHO
ARE IN THE GALLERY THIS IS YOUR
TIME TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR NOT ONLY DISCUSSION ITEMS
BUT VOTE ONLY ITEMS AS WELL.
AND SO IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
GALLERY WHO ARE WE SPOKE THAT
WANTS TO COME IN AND VOTE ONLY
FEEL FREE TO GO BACK TO THE
MIKE SEEING NONE AND IT LOOKS
LIKE YOUR ROOM TWENTY FOUR IS
EMPTY. SO FOR OUR. CALLER SO
WE'LL MOVE NOW ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE THIS IS
PUBLIC COMMENTOPPORTUNITY FOR
BOTH THE DISCUSSION ITEMS WE
JUST REVIEWED AS WELL AS THE
VOTE ONLY AGENDA THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BOTH SECTION THE
GENDER MODERATE. CAN YOU PLEASE
TELL ME THAN TOTAL OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
BOTH DISCUSSION ITEMS AND VOTE
ONLY. CURRENTLY WE HAVE SEVENTY
FIVE THAT ARE USED UP. I YES
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVEN'T SEVENTY
FIVE. HANG ON ONE SECOND I'M
GETTING SOME INSTRUCTION FROM
HERE IN THE ROOM I'VE HEARD
SEVENTY FIVE. WE WOULD YOU LIKE
ME TO PURSUE A BALLOT CHAIR AND
WHAT I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO DO IS
MAKE SURE YOU GIVE THE FULL
INSTRUCTIONS SO PEOPLE WHO WILL
BE PARTICIPATING FOR THE FIRST
TIME KNOW WHAT TO DO IF YOU'D
GIVE. ALL INSTRUCTIONS THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
HAVE TO COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES ONE.
TWO NINETY SEVEN. RIGHT
PARTNERSHIP OF THE QUEEN YEAH
YOU WE ARE THANKFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. ON THE BUDGET WELL
YOUR PATIENT TO WORK WITH
CONGRESS TO THE CLINIC THE
CALIFORNIA DURING THE CALL DOWN
THERE. WE CAN ONLY THE FOR THE
SENATE PROPOSAL AND HOW HERE
COULD. ON THE ISSUE NUMBER AND
LET ME. YOU CAN HELP YOUR
PROVIDER RATE. WE'RE GRATEFUL
AT GREAT HOPEFULLY TO CLINIC
YOUR TO THE CAPTAIN OF THE
NEEDS OF THE TO REOPEN WE'RE
OFF THE RECORD AND IF YOU
NUMBER FORTY ONE ON THE FIFTY
FIVE MILLION FOR WORK INSURANCE
MOST VULNERABLE FAMILY. THE IF
THE COURT. HE PATIENTS ARE PUT.
IN FOR LUCKILY CAL. WE SHOULD
TO CREATE HIGHER TYPE THE CREEK.
THANK. LINE. TWO EIGHTY NINE.
LIKE EIGHTY NINE RELY IS. SHOP.
I'VE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
LINE THREE YES GO AHEAD OF. FOR
HELLO YES WE HEAR YOU. WE CAN
I'M MY NAME IS I'M A AND LIKE
HERE GOVERNOR NEW. HEARING AID
PROGRAM IN THE MAY REVIVED THE
WORKING PERSON TRAINER EIGHT
FIVE NINETY EIGHT SELECT COULD
YOUR ACT EVERY I WILL GIVING
THE LIVING THE STATE UP WITH
EVERYBODY OUR STATE THE FIFTH.
HOLDING A PUBLIC. THIRTY EIGHT
ONE IT'S NOT RECEIVED INNER.
OUR SPECIAL OCCASION ANOTHER MY
COUPLE. THIS IS THE PROBLEM
BACK TO DECADES THE COST OF THE
GOVERNOR OF NINE EIGHT FIVE
NINE EIGHT IS MINIMAL BUT THE
ACTON. ADDRESS DEVELOPMENTAL.
WALKING TO COST STATE HOW.
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL. FIRST THING I
ASKED HANDING EACH AND THEY
WERE LOOKING AT. THAT WE CAN'T
GO BEYOND THAT CAN YOU WENT ON
TO THERE ARE CRITICAL TO
DEVELOPING AND WE DON'T THINK
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE WINDOWS
OF NOT LIKE WE CAN GO BACK AND
THAT. HERMAN ACTUALLY WAIT
RATED DEVELOPED. IAN HAD
DEVASTATING TO NEWBORN WE NEED
TO BE A BY MONTHS OF THE.
OTHERS NEED THE HEAR THE
PARENTS TALK. THINK THEY THE
FOUNDATION FOR BRAIN. AND THEY
TELL WITH MY DAUGHTER WHO NEED.
A LOT OF HOT NEED SEPARATE THAT
WOULD MANDATE TO HELP PAY FOR.
FROM. CHILDREN SHE FELT CALLED
YOU THE WHITE. PLEASE LIKE HOW
K. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF PLEASE ROOM ALL OF US
Q. AT THAT THEY HAVE WE ME
BECAUSE MY UNDER THAT WE NOW
CLOSE TO KNOW PEOPLE AND QUEUE
MORE WAY TO GET A- MR MODERATE
PLEASE ANNOUNCE THE NEXT. YES
MADAM CHAIRMAN. THE ACTUAL IS
LYING REPORTER. ONE HELLO MY
NAME IS TORY I NOW I WITH THE
WORKERS CENTER AND ANGELES
SURVIVE BUDGET DOES NOT ANY
LOOK AND SUPPORT FOR AND
COUNCIL. AND I'M LIKE THAT
EXCLUDING INTO ON FOR NEW
WORKERS FROM THE BIG SAFETY NET
DUE TO IMMIGRATION HAS COME TO.
ONE CHILD TAX CREDIT YCP AND
INCLUSION OF TREATING SHOULD
HAVE BEEN THE GATE BUT FOR THAT
I'M TALKING IMMIGRANTS HI
INCLUDED CALIFORNIA I COULD NOT
RECOVERY SHOT A THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
LINE THREE FORTY FOUR. YOU CAN.
HELLO THIS IS ADAM FRANCIS BUT
THE CALIFORNIA CAN IN DIVISION
IS ONE THAT TANK THE THINK THE
SENATE SO MUCH FOR THEIR ACTION
SO FAR HOW PROTECT. REALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO HELP. ACT
TO PER CARE. PARTICULARLY THE
SONG BROWN PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN TRAINING AND
FINANCIALLY. TO A VERY. TIME I
ALSO SUPPORT AND THE- CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE WHICH
WERE PROVIDE IN LIFELINE. YOUR
PRACTICE THAT ARE. RIGHT LACK
OF FISCAL RESOURCES AND CAN BE
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO BUILD A
FOUNDATION PRIMARY CARE AND-
THANK YOU. ONE SIX. YEAH JEREMY
MICHELLE GIVEN THE COUNTY HOW
INSPECTOROF THE CALIFORNIA WE
WERE FOR THE LOCAL DEPARTMENT
THROUGHOUT THE I WONDER IF I
ASK THE LEGISLATURE I LOOK BACK
FILL THANK YOU NINETY ONE THE
ONLY MINUTES WELL. AS HELP THAT
WOULD KIND OF BE A ONE AND
FIFTY THREE DOLLAR DEFICIT IN
THE COURT CURRENT YEAR AND A
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR DEATH IN THE
BUDGET YOU AND THIS IS ON OF
THE THAT LOCAL THE HEALTH OF
THE COUNTERS ARE RIGHT HI AND-
MILLION. THANK LEVEL
DEVASTATING MAY RESULT IN
FURTHER AT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAM AND THE STAFF ESSENTIAL
WITH THIS RIGHT NOW TO ENSURE
THAT OUR ARE STATE WE ARE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE THINKS THROUGH
AND CONSIDER BACK HEALTH
REALIGNED AS WELL AS A RE TO
BOLSTER THE. THE FINE PRINT
DOCUMENT THAT WORKERS BE
INCLUDED IN THE JUNE FIFTEENTH
BUDGET MOBILE CALLING IN ORDER
AB FIFTY NINETY THREE WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE I THINK BY LATELY
THE CALL OUT THE I. T. C. AS WE
KNOW THAT DEMOCRATIC CONTRIBUTE
GREATLY TO TELL IN. THEIR 10%
OF THE WORK. THE THREE BILLION.
EVERY YEAR. I'M ALSO GOOD FOR
MAINTAINING IN THE STATE BUDGET
THE FEEDING IT SHOULD HAVE
WHICH WILL HELP OUR STATE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS THE
LONG TERM ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF
THE STATE. AND FINALLY- BOTH
THE MADE REVISED BUDGET THAT
MEDICAL ACT. THANK FOR SENIORS
FRONT DOCUMENTED THANK YOU. BY
THREE OR FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS IN THE NON WITH THE
EACH DAY LABOR CENTER AT AND I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
DEPARTING IF YOU DELICIOUS IN
THE STATE BUDGET. OKAY YEAH ONE
OF THE FORTY BUT IF YOU DID
THAT IT WILL PROVIDE AND
DOCUMENT CAL BUT MAKE A
STRAINING TO START ROAD THAT
THE AND MORE COOPERATE. IT IS
REALLY PART AND ESPECIALLY WITH.
HANGING BY A THREAD WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF I CAN
FILERS BURKE OUT EIGHTY FEET.
ALTHOUGH FOR WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS- AND YOU DIDN'T HAVE
THE FUNDS FOR LABEL I'M FORCED
ME TO PROTECT WORKERS THANK YOU.
ONE THREE FOURTEEN. I WAS THE
MONTH THERE WITH THE NEWS DAILY
LABOR CENTER I ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE CONCLUDED BACK IT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECT THE CORD
FEET OFF. VERSION OF I CAN FIND
USING YET THREE AS WELL AS FROM
MEMBER TO CIRCLE LOCAL WE
INCOME REPLACEMENT KIND ARE NOT
GONNA WORKERS. AND THEIR
GENERATION OF THE WORK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE SEVEN
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT I'M
HEARING MEMBERS JUSTIN RAN OF
THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO GET RID
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN AND YOUR GRANDPARENTS
TALKING CARE TEACHERS ARE NONE
THE CALIFORNIA IN DUBLIN SURE
THAT THEIR BENEFITS ARE NOT CUT
OUT. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN THAT
REJECTED BOTH CUT IN YOUR
COVERAGE INSURANCE ALL SENIORS
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL
ADDITIONALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE RIGHT DRAW YOUR VOCAL
LOGIC OUT COMMUNITIES. IF I.
RICHARD TO ENSURE THE-
IMMEDIATELY TO CONNECT YOU'RE
CANNOT WAIT. SENATE RECRUITING
HOW FINDING IT BUDGET PLAN WE
ARE GOING TO MAJOR DEPARTMENT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE PROGRAM
NOW WE ARE ARE IN I THANK
GEORGIA CAL YOU MEAN BE AWARE
THE ELEGY. YEAH OR MAYBE IT IT
DIDN'T. TO HOLD IT. ADVANTAGE
OF THE HOW. AT AGE SORRY.
ADVANTAGE OF THE HEALTHCARE UP
TO DOUBLE THAT WE KNOW WHEN WE
OVER THE DOOR TO MORE FAMILY
MEMBERS MORE. ALL THE GET EVER.
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE
PROJECTING CUT THE OTHER.
APPROVED PROGRAM SUCH AS THE-
HELP HER AND REJECTING THE PROP
FIFTY SIX RODNEY. THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN HELLO HAVE OR WHAT MET.
OR DELAYED YEAH THE COMPLAINT
DURING OPEN NINETY. PUBLIC
HEALTH RIGHT WILL BE AN MANY.
ARE UNHEARD OF HELP YOU USUALLY
WOULD YOU FALLING. I ORDER THE
BUDGET PROCESS DIGITAL
PARTNERSHIP CAN TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH ME ACCORDING TO
HELPING CHILDREN ABOUT YOU KNOW.
WELL I THREE ADE. ROLL ON MY
NEW IS ARE YOU IN A THREE ON
THE BACK PRESS BACK AND GET
DIRECTOR OF THE THERE WOULD BE
NO THANKS VERY MUCH AND I URGE
THE COMMITTEE CONCLUDED
DOCUMENT AND AGREE AND
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
LIKE THE PLAYING FIELD AND NEXT
AND IN THE EIGHT THANK YOU WE
THINK. NEED A INCLUDE ACT ABOUT
EIGHT IN MY IN THE HOME CARE IN
WHO ARE A LOT OF CARE GIVER ARE
THAT YOU KNOW AND THERE A GREAT
I'LL BUT TO CREATE A QUALITY
JOB AND PROMOTING WORK THAT MY
BY FEED BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT
WHAT OWN COOPER CAN. NINE THREE
WHAT YOU ARE HELP BOOST THE
ECONOMY AT WE COVER I WE ALSO I
QUITE AT I CAN REMEMBER HOW
READ OLD BOOKS A WEEK INCOME
REPLACEMENT THANK. VERY ALSO IN
I CAN FINALLY IN. I THREE YOU
WILL HAVE THE FOR LABOR ALLY
FOR DIFFERENT WORKERS AND AT
THE JANUARY VERY OF WORKER WITH
HE SHOWED FINE EIGHT YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. MODERATOR JESS
ON. TAKE A MORE TO REMOVE. ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TO
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS ONE MAY. IF
YOU HAVE HEARD ISSUE ARE RAY.
FEEL FREE TO SAY DID AND GIVE
US THE TOP. WE ARE NOW UP TO
NINE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE IN THE QUEUE. AND WE STILL
HAVE TO VOTE AFTER WE HEAR ALL
OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY. SO I'M
GONNA ASK ALL OF YOU TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE CALLERS BEHIND
YOU. SO WE CAN GET HE WE CAN
HEAR YOU ALL KNOW YOUR
PERSPECTIVE BUT DON'T FEEL
OBLIGATED TO READ YOUR ENTIRE
WRITTEN STATEMENT. DITTO AND
REFER. TO I'M IT'S MADE BY
PREVIOUS CALLERS. IS ACCEPTABLE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN LINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE'RE
GOING TO LINE THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. KELLEY BEAN CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND POSITION MEMBERS HE
MAY HAVE FIVE THE SENATE FOR
CRAFTING A BUDGET PLAN THAT
PRIORITIZES ACCESS TO EVERY
HEALTHCARE HEALTHCARE FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA. AT A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY AND THE MEDIC HOW
KIDS THOSE EXPECTED TO INCREASE%
BY MORE THAN TWO MILLION AND WE
MUST FOR SERVICES FOR THOSE WHO
NEED THEM MOST. THE SENATE
BUDGET INVESTING PROGRAMS THAT
IMPROVE ME PULL ACTED TO CARE
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
SUFFICIENT HEARING PROPHETIC
HELP PATIENTS. BUDGET THIRTY
MINUTE VALUE AND THIS PLAN
SHOWS THAT ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS ACT WITH THE
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING LOW
INCOME RURAL AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IS A
CORE CALIFORNIA VALUE THANK YOU.
WINE. FOR THIRTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MATT
INSURANCE MANY MEMBERS CHILLING
CORMACK WITH THE CHILDREN BOB
FENNER CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
THIRTY THOUSAND CHILDREN UNDER
DEPENDENCY COURT JURISDICTION
LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND
PLANT THE COUNTY WHEN THE UPPER
QUIET WE WANT TO THANK THE
MEDICAL TWENTY FOUR THE BUDGET
TO PROTECT CRITICAL CHILD
WELFARE PROGRAMS. THE
CRITICALLY ITEM THIRTY PEOPLE
NINE AND ITEM FIFTY SEVEN IN
SUB THREE VOTE ON THE BUDGET.
WE ACTUALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR RETAINING THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF FUNDING FOR THE PENALTY
KHALKHAL THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY KILLED. IN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE BUDGET.
WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO THE
COURT A GROWING BACKLOG CASES
IN AN EXPECTED INCREASE THE
FOSTER CARE POPULATION. THE
OTHER COULD BE NEEDS OF OUR
YOUNG CLIENTS ARE MORE CRITICAL
NOW THAN EVER. WE HOPE YOU ALSO
CONSIDER ADOPTING PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD PROTECT. TRANSITIONING
AND YOU DURING THE- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR MAKING SUCH A
DOCUMENT TO THE HELP EIGHTY.
AND WELL BEING OF THE SIXTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN AND YOU. THE.
LINE OR THREE. HI MY NAME IS.
WITH A CLEAN CAR WASH CAMPAIGN
AND I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
IN CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
FOURTEEN THAT THE INITIATIVE WE
ALSO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAUGHT
CHOLERA PROPOSAL. FOR A WEEKLY
INCOME REPLACEMENT FIND FOR I.
DOCUMENTED WORKERS. FOR USING
FINDS FOR LABOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO PROTECT WORKERS AND WEEK WE
TOOK MORE THAN. REVISION OF THE
WORKER RECOGNITION THANK YOU.
LINE THREE EIGHTY FIVE. TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MAY ONE THREE EIGHTY FIVE
UP. FIND FOR NINETEEN. BERMAN
TAKING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
KLAY ABOUT- EIGHT TO TEN SOME
THREE NUMBER FIFTY NINE THE
REALIGNMENT BACK. APPRECIATIVE
OF THE SENATE RECOGNIZED IN THE
COUNTY I NEED SOME OF THAT BILL
OF THE- REALIGNMENT DROUGHT- WE
DO HAVE A NUMBER PROGRAM
HOWEVER NOT JUST CHILD WELFARE
WE ALSO HAVE TO GIVE UP ALL
PROGRAMS INCLUDING CHILDREN YES
HE TEETERED. ABOUT PUBLIC. ONE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT OR BACK BILL FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR AND THE CURRENT
YEAR OF THREE POINT THREE
BILLION TO FUND BASELINE UP
SERVICES PROVIDED BY COUNTY OF
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE I WANT
TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TEND TO THE- ISSUE. MADAM CHAIR
I'M- TURNING THIS OVER. TO MY
PARTNER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO NEW MODERATOR
NEXT OPEN THE CALLS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SPECTACLE TO MY
NUMBER FOUR THREE EIGHT ONE
FOUR THREE EIGHT YOUR LIGHT IT
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF ANOTHER IF
YOU KNOW WHAT KEEP YOU PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF IN OUR FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP. WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE PLANET'S
MODIFIED TRIGGER AND PROTECTION
NOT FUNDING FOR THE BLACK AND
HEALTH PROGRAM AND NOT A CAL
NAVIGATOR. WHICH WILL BOTH HELP
FAMILIES GET THE HELP AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED RIGHT NOW
WHAT WILL BE A DIFFICULT
RECOVERY. HOWEVER WE ARE GOING
TO BE THE ONE TIME REDUCTION
MACAU WORK COME VISITING
PROGRAM FUNDING. WE ARE TALKING
TO SOME OF THE FISCAL SITUATION
IN WHICH WE FIND OURSELVES. NOT
PRESERVATION OF ELIGIBILITY AND
BENEFITS. HOPING FAMILIES MAKE
IT THREE. HOWEVER I THAN PLEASE
VISIT PROGRAM LIKE AND IF YEAR
A CRIMINAL TO GET THE VISION.
WHO FOR TEN POWER FROM THE
FAMILY ARE SIR IN THE WE BUILT
ON THE IN THE FUTURE. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THEY WERE GOING ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION ALLOCATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN DEDICATED
TO COUNTIES FOR HOME VISITING
PURPOSES ONLY AND CLOSE THE
LEGISLATURE AND MINISTRY AND
HE'S THE FUNDING IMMEDIATELY
PRESIDENT PROGRAMS MADE HOW
MANY THAT WERE NOT MADE HOLE
FOR THEIR HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS.
VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET. MEXICO
TO LIE NUMBER FOUR SIX THREE
LINES SIX THREE YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. I THANK YOU MADAM SURE-
EVER RESTOCK APOLLYON ACHING ON
BEHALF OF THE VALLEY INDUSTRY
AND COMMERCE ASSOCIATION- WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING THE LACK OF
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IN THE
NAY REVISED BUDGET PROPOSAL. WE
BELIEVE THE CAP AND TRADE
OPTION PROCEEDS LIKELY WON'T BE
ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING WHICH
WAS GIVEN SECOND PRIORITY IN
THE ME REVISED. AND WITHOUT
THIS WORK BY OUR DISTRICTS
CLEAN UP LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
WILL CONVICT ONLY SLOW DOWN OR
STOP ALTOGETHER. MILLION AND
EMPLOYMENT FUNDING SHOULD BE.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE THAT THE
HEALTH COMMUNITY THE SECOND.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT. YOU CAN
COMMON PATIENT FUNDING AND
CARBON POLITICIAN FUNDING
SHOULD BE GIVEN TIME LEVEL
PRIORITY. AND WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE YOUR ARM. WITH A MISSION
GREED VERSION OF AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND DOLLARS FOR NON
AIR QUALITY PURPOSES. EIGHT
STATION. YOUR AND SHOULD BE
AGAIN THIS YEAR I THANK YOU
FOR. ISSUE TAXABLE TO LINE
NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY ONE LINE
FOR SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CORPORATION RECALL THING I'LL
BE SPEAKING ON THE COMMITTEE-
NUMBER FOUR ISSUES STARTING
WITH ISSUE NUMBER FOUR HOUSING
CHERRY COKE OPPOSING FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMUNITY AND
STAFF BERKELEY IN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND AND KIDDING. ON A BY
RELIEF FUND TO SUPPORT LOCAL.
OF HOME OF. AMONG PEOPLE AT
RISK OF DEATH COKE AND- IN HER
GOING THE COMMITTEE CENTURY
COME TO BRING READ THAT FOR A
FUTURE THE STREET. WE ARE JUST
MARK ON GOING FOR THE OPERATING
COSTS NEW HOUSING. BY SHOULD BE.
STARTING WITH THE- DOWN PAYMENT
OF THIRTY DOLLAR TOUBLES
YEAR'S BY AND THAT COULD BE
PART OF THE CURE FIFTY NINE
WITH A THIS OPERATE FUND THESE
PROJECTS CAN NOT BE FIVE. AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE AND TO USE
THESE FUNDS TRANSACTION AND
PERMANENT HOUSING. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO TOUCH ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD TAKE
THEM. WE ARE FROM THE CHAIRS
HOUSING FIRST LEGISLATION
PASSED AND TWENTY SIX. I THANK
PLACE HOLDER MY GET FINAL WHICH-
OPPOSE ACTS HERE CONSENT. WE
ARE FROM HOUSING FIRST
PROVISIONS ABOUT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FROM TWO THOUSAND SIX.
THIS TRAILER BILL WILL
CURRENTLY RESULT IN MORE
HOMELESSNESS LONG PEOPLE
EXITING OUR CHRISTMAS. FINALLY
WE APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS ALLOCATION OF STATE OF
ON COME HOUSING TAX CREDITS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS WHEN THE CAMARO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
HEALTH NETWORK YEAH THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT WITH
GENERAL FUND THE HEALTH
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE SENATE HAS
PROPOSED AN OPTION FOR THE
FUTURE. PRIVATE PLAN BUT ONE TO
REITERATE THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE
NOT GUARANTEED WE ALSO WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT BY NOT
INVESTING IN HEALTH NAVIGATORS
WE ALSO NEED A MATCHING DOLLARS
ON THAT PEOPLE. OUGHT ON A
CENTRAL PART OF THE WORK THAT
ARE CURRENTLY HELPING PEOPLE
GET INTO HEALTHCARE IN THE FACE
OF INCREDIBLE JOB WALKED IN
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP WE CANNOT. GO
BACK NOW WHEN. NEED ALL THE
ALCOHOL. THE SENATE INCLUSION
OF HELL WELL AND- EIGHTEEN
YEARS. AND HOPE THAT THAT
EXPANSION BE AMPLE AND WE'D
ALSO LIKE YOU A- THE PLANET. OF
ME. THE ADULT DENTAL. WE KNOW
THE PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES HAVE
BEEN CHANGED BY THE WHOLE
RESTORATION AND WE DON'T WANT
TO GO BACKWARDS WHERE PEOPLE
WORK EXTRACTING THEIR OWN HELP.
HE TO HAVE. ME BACK BECAUSE
ONLY FAULT. OF ALL. AND WHAT
THE BLOCKING BEEN HELP PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CARE THE- ADAM HEALTH. I'M
THINKING FOR YOUR TIME AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON THE
BUDGET. NEXT CALL TO THE LINE
OF FOUR EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE FOR EIGHTY ONE. ADAM
CHEN MEMBERS BRANDON NOT BEHALF
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. WHAT IS THE FIRST
ACTION ON THAT CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
IN THE AMOUNT OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY PROTECTION
PROGRAM. IN JUNE BUDGET. AIR
DISTRICTS ARE DROPPING THEIR
BUDGETS IN JUNE AND WILL GO
ALMOST A QUARTER OF THE YEAR
WITHOUT KNOWING. IF THIS IS
GOING TO PROVIDE ANY FUNDING
FOR. THIS STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON THE PROGRAM AND-
COURSE. SEATED PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. NEXT
PHOTO NUMBER FOR EIGHT SIX LINE
FOR YOU TO FIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU YOU TOO-
CHAIRWOMAN MITCHELL AND ARE
SENATE CHAMPION FOR ELEVATING
THE- IMMIGRANT IN YOUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT SORREL THOMAS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER. NOT ON THE
AGENDA ABOUT BROUGHT UP BY
SEVERAL CALLERS BEFORE ME I
WANT TO ECHO THE SUPPORT FOR
THE SEATED MISSION THERE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS INCOME
REPLACEMENT PLAN. ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR PROPOSALS
TO EXPAND MEDI CAL TWO ONE
DOCUMENT ELDERS. AND EXPAND THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM TO THOSE THAT FILE WITH
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS. WE WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN IMPLEMENT
THE MEDI CAL EXPANSION- THAN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND IT WOULD
PROVIDE THE INCOME TAX. ALL I
CAN VIOLATE. THOSE THAT HAVE A
CHILD AT SIX YEARS OF AGE OR
UNDER. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR REJECTING THE MAY
REVISION PLANNED TO. REVERSE
THAT FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE. FELLOWSHIP
THANK YOU. HOLD THE LINE NUMBER
FOUR EIGHT FIVE NINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN SPENT
ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA TWENTY AFTER MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SEEK MAKE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN IS JUST NINE A
COG OF COURSE LIKE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
CREATIVE THINKING THE PLAN
BEFORE US. EIGHT EIGHT PROPERTY
QUICKLY WITH AND SUPPORT YOUR
PLANTS PRESERVE MEDI CAL
PAYMENT FOR POSITION SERVICES.
THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX.
INDIVIDUALLY SEEK MAY LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATE PARKS
RECOGNITION OF THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF OPTION BENEFIT
COVERAGE IN PARTICULAR
PODIATRY. INCLUDING SUCH
COVERAGE IN THE BUDGET PLAN.
OKAY BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY
PLEASED WITH AND SUPPORT ABOUT
THE SENATE A POLL TO MAKE.
FUNDING AND THE STASHED
AUTHORITY THAT EXTENDED MEDI
CAL PROPOSED PERMANENT BUT THE
TERM MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
WELL HOPEFULLY PROPOSALS WE
MADE IN THE BUDGET AS
NEGOTIATIONS BEFORE. FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF CHEN I HAVE TO THE
SENATE CONTINUE CONSIDER FISCAL
SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL TELL THE
PROGRAMS MOST NOTABLY ECON. AT
OUR STATE MEDICAL. YET ALLOW ME
COMMENT TODAY. PRACTICAL TO
LINE UP FORTY THREE LINE IS. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KIND OF IF I EAT
LESS THAN NINE WITH A BALLOT
THAT LUKE. LUKE AT COMMITTED TO
GETTING INCOME REPLACEMENT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS IN THE
BUDGET BECAUSE POVERTY
EXACERBATE OR HELP SHELTERING
IN PLACE REQUIRES A HOME
WASHING YOUR HANDS REQUIRES
ACCESS TO WATER REDUCING STRESS
WHICH DEEPLY THIRTY NEW
REQUIRES THE ABILITY. OUR
HEALTH LIKE OUR ECONOMY IS
INTERTWINED FOR PREVENTION TO
WORKING FOR SHARED PROSPERITY
TO PREVAIL WE MUST INVEST IN
EVERYONE THIS WEEK WE THOUGHT
THE STAGGERING NEED OF OUR
COMMUNITY DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT ISN'T BEING MET AT THE
DISASTER RELIEF AT THE TEMPER
IMMIGRANTS FIND OPENED WEBSITE.
ONLINE HE CROSS EIGHT CRAFTED
FAMILIES WHO HAVE. GOTTEN
WITHOUT. I THANK THE NEXT WEEK
ON AND RUSHED FOR A CHANCE T
THE FIRST HELP AVAILABLE TO
THEM THE OUT OF THE VIRUS
BEFORE FUNDS RIGHT NOW. MEETING
AN UNPRECEDENTED EMPLOYMENT
CRISIS WITH A SINGLE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR GRANT IS LIKE
GIVING AWAY ALL. TAX IT IS NOT
ENOUGH THAT'S WHY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF A
WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT FIND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEEN
IN THE JUNE BUDGET THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL THE LINE NUMBER FOUR
NINE SIX NINE FOUR NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALAN AB TO
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I'D LIKE TO
START OUT BY DRESSING-
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ISSUE THIRTY
WILDFIRE SMOKE CLEAN AIR
CENTERS AND SUPPORT. THE SENATE
THE PROPOSAL TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THIS PROGRAM OUT FROM
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET THIS IS A
CRITICAL PROGRAM. THAT IS
ALIGNED WITH WILDFIRES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE ENCOURAGE
THE SENATE TO. CONTINUE TO
ATTEMPT TO UP ON THIS PROGRAM
TO THE FUTURE I ALSO LIKE TO
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE BRENDON TO WORK FROM
THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS FUND. ABOUT
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY AMPLE. AND
ENCOURAGE THE SENATE TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IN THE
JUNE BUDGET SO THAT THEIR
DISTRICTS HAVE BUDGET
CERTAINTY. FOR NEXT YEAR AS
WELL TO ADDRESS- SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES. IN THE BAY AREA
SPECIFICALLY THAT THE RICHMOND
SAN PABLO BEST OAKLAND POST
ALSO WORK THAT WE DO IN VALLEJO
EASTER- SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
JOSE THANK YOU. GO TO LINE
NUMBER FOUR SEVEN EIGHT ONE
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTER MIGUEL ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE VERY
ENCOURAGED BY THE SENATE
PROPOSAL TO DELAY TRIGGERED
CRIED. I MEANT FUNDED BY
PROPERTY. AND APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATION THAT
STOP INCLUDED TO CONTINUE THE
EVENT ARE YOU GOING AN
ALTERNATE FUNDING TOWARD THAT
NECESSARY- WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
THAT THE SENATE RECOGNIZES.
THAT PROPERTY SIX HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL FOR SPEAKING UP
PROVIDERS INCLUDING HAD SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK TO
ENSURE ACCESS FOR MEDI CAL AND
FAMILY KAKHETIAN AND HERE TIME
TODAY. BOTTOM LINE NUMBER THREE
FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LIMIT FOR
PREVENTING CHILDREN NOW AND WE
WENT OUT ON THE SENATE AND
AFTER THEIR HARD WORK TO PUT
FORTH THE BUDGET PACKAGE FOR
YOU TODAY ENTER THE PROTECTION
AND KEEP BOTTLED FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION EARLY LEARNING AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE.
PROGRAMS WE THANK YOU FOR
KEEPING. FAMILY DEREK BONTA
THEM REJECTING THE PERCENT.
RATE CUT TO THE S. R. OUR IN
OUR CHILDCARE PROGRAMS AND
REJECTING THE PROP FIFTY THINK
MEDI CAL CUT. NAME A FEW. WE
ARE YOU TO THINK STRONG AND
CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS THEIR
BOARD AT. THE INTERESTS OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUR- HEALTH.
KEEP HER PROTECTING INVESTMENT.
LAST AND HOPE THAT ONE WE GET A
DETAILED BUT THE- PLAN AROUND
THE TRAILER THE- OVER FOR HOW
MUCH NOT THAT THAT. INCLUDE THE
SENATE FOR YOU AND THEN YOU
FIND. I YOU DOWN THE PATH YOU
BUDGET MICHAEL THANK YOU. NEXT
TO OPEN A LINE OF FIVE ONE ONE
NINE FIVE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIVE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSIBLE TO
LINE FIVE TWENTY LINE FIVE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DENISE VELASCO FROM THE MBTA.
STATEWIDE WATCHDOG ORG THAT
MONITORS LABOR VIOLATIONS IN
THE NON UNION JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY
PARTIAL INCOME REPLACEMENT FUND
FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY COLD BUT
NINETEEN IN THE JUNE BUDGET. WE
ALSO WANTED THANK SENATOR ABOUT
THE PERSON COURTING ASH
CONGRESS PLAN TO PROPOSE THE
SAFETY NET FOR ALL. THE EMPTY
TEA EVERY COMMITTED TO GETTING
INCOME OR FRIEND DOCUMENTED
WORKERS BECAUSE IT IS NECESSARY
TO HELP FAMILIES LIKE. THE
MANDATE FAMILY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. GOT BACK HAVE BEEN CUT
IN HALF. THEY LIVE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN ANAGRAM WHO IN HER
FINAL STAGES CANCER. THEY ARE
BEING FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
BUYING FOOD OR PAIN RELIEF
MEDICINE FOR THEIR GRANDMOTHER.
WE CANNOT LEAVE FAMILIES LIKE
THAT BEHIND. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF ITUNES
VIOLATION THE CALLIE I TCM
INCLUSION SEAT AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE IN THE STATE BUDGET. THANK
YOU. THAT WATER LINE NUMBER
FIVE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BECAUSE I'M WITH THAT
THAT WE HAVE ACCORDING. IF
YOU'RE- AND I'M CALLING AT
ABOUT. WE GET SPECIAL TREATMENT.
WHAT. ONE EIGHT. I HOW WILL
WORK YEAH. BUT YOU DID THERE.
YOU ARE WERE PULLED BY. BUT I
SHOULD. THANK YOU. TOP OF THE
LINE UP FOR NINETY FIVE LINE
FOR NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THE KNOWN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
HARKIN I'M IN ORGANIZER WITH
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AS AN
ORGANIZER I RECEIVE A LARGE
AMOUNT OF CALLS EVERY DAY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS TO TICKLE
BUT NINETEEN BUT ARE UNABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT OR ANY
OTHER BENEFITS TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS MAKE UP ONE TENTH OF
THE POPULATION I SHOULD HAVE
ACTED WORKING NOT REALLY.
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
TOPPING CREATION OF THE TO. I'M
BUT WE ALREADY SEE THAT ONLY
COVERS STRUCTURE OF THE CAN. IN
NEED. I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOME REPLACEMENT FUNDS. FROM
DOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY CALL THE
NINETEEN. IN THE JUNE BUDGET. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE POLLUTION OF
AYE COMPILERS AND- THE CAL. THE
ITC. AND THE WHITE THE TO SEE
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL TO LINE
NUMBER FIVE TWO NINE FIVE FIVE
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIM WILL LET
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
AID AT WORK. THE MAJORITY OF
WORKERS WHO HAVE LOTS WORK AT
THE RESULT THIS CRISIS ARE NOW
ELIGIBLE FOR ANYWHERE BETWEEN
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY AND ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY PER WEEK IN
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND CALIFORNIA'S
PETE OUT OVER NINETEEN BILLION
IN UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THE
START OF THIS CRISIS. HOWEVER
ONE GROUP HAS BEEN ENTIRELY
INCLUDED. AND THAT IS
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS TO MAKE UP
ONE TENTH OF OUR WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A GLARING
INEQUITY THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED
IN THE GYM BY. WHEN YOU'RE
ADVOCATING FOR THE INCLUSION
WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT
PROGRAM FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN COMMON
EMPLOYED YOU TO CALL BACK TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE GYM BUDGET. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF
AYE COMPILER IN CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT THE
INCLUSION OF THE SEAT
INITIATIVE AND THE EXPANSION OF
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE
UNDERSTAFFED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT ABOUT A LINE NUMBER
FIVE THREE TWO ONE FIVE THREE
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU AND MEMBERS IN THAT
AND REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
SPEAKING ON ISSUE TWENTY THREE
AND BUDGET SUB. ON HEALTH. UBER
HELP COUNSELORS AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS IN THE NAY REVISED
THIS PROGRAM WAS PROPOSED TO BE
ELIMINATED THE SENATE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL. THANKFUL FOR
THIS WITH A SPECIAL THANKS TO
SENATOR PAN WHO DISCUSSED THIS
PROGRAM IN THE SUB THREE
HEARING. MANY HAVE DESCRIBED
THE ONSET OF THE CODE ENDEMIC
AS AN EARTHQUAKE AND FOLLOWING
TSUNAMI WILL BE CALIFORNIANS
SUFFERING FROM PAPER HEALTH
ISSUES. CALPERS IN THE MERCY
DEPARTMENTS IS A PROVEN PROGRAM
THAT HELPS CONNECT PATIENTS
WITH PAPER HEALTH ISSUES TWO
THIRDS THAT THEY TRULY NEED.
THIS PROGRAM IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME IN YOUR SUPPORT. AND NEXT
OPEN THE LINE OF FIVE THREE ONE
NINE FIVE THREE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ANOTHER PART OF WHAT YOU THINK.
ASIAN I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE OUR
OPPOSITION TO IT AND THAT WAS.
AT THE BUDGET AND MEET YOU.
SOMEDAY RELATE THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THE PROPOSAL THAT
HAPPENED A NICKNAME REQUIRES
THE CREATION OF A TRAILER BILL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE. AFTER
MAKING. HI ELEMENT THAT
HAPPENED THREE PROGRAM WE'RE
HAPPY TO HEAR THE TRAILER BILL
COULD BE COMING BACK TO HOLD
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND THERE'S NO
JUSTIFICATION. STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. HAPPENED REYES
WORKING. CALIFORNIA KIND OF
PROGRAM TWENTY TWENTY GOAL. FOR
YEARS EARLY IN THE PROGRAM WILL
ONLY BECOME MORE STRINGENT AT
THE CAP THE CLIENT. RIGHT IN
THE ONLY. OTHER THEIR THE
LANGUAGE TO THEM THAT WILL
MAKING. SPEAKERS ACT WOULD
BROUGHT THE PUBLIC. PARTICIPATE
IN A WAY THAT IT NEEDED COOLEY
IMPORTANT AND FINALLY THE
NINETY ONE RECORD HELLO THE
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE THE LA. THE WHICH
INCREASE AT THE DANCE LIKE
EVERY YEAR AND INDICATE THAT IS
THE COST THAT WILL BE BORN WITH
THE LEAD BY CALIFORNIA FOR A
PROJECT THAT HELP. OTHER
GRANDPARENTS AGENT. HAPPENED
TRADE GRAHAM. THAT'S ALL MY
NUMBER FIVE THREE FIVE ONE FIVE
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK YOU TURN MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS ROBERT UNIONS WITH FILIPINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA. WE TO- COMMAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN TO REJECT CUTS TO
SENIOR COVERAGE EVER CONCERNING
TO PRIORITIZE THE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL.
FIFTEEN YEARS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS A DISABILITY
HOWEVER WE ARE THE LEGISLATURE
TO WORK IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY
AND NOT WAIT UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IN LIGHT OF CURRENT
EVENTS. WE ALSO AGO COMMENTS
MADE IN SUPPORT OF HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
POST PARTUM MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS
AND EXPAND KALECKI I. T. C.
AND- TRUMP CRAP TAX CREDIT I. I
T. I AND HIGHWAYS. WE ARE
HOWEVER CONCERNED WITH CUT TO
COVER. TO COVER TO COVER
CALIFORNIA IS CENTS POTENTIAL
PORTABILITY ASSISTANCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING TO
PURCHASE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
AND WE LOOK FOR. PROTECT YOUR
SENSE. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TO
OPEN MY FIVE THREE ONE HIS FIVE
THREE NINE LIGHT LINE FIVE NINE
JULY IS OPEN. KIDNAPPING MY
NAME IS RANDALL BIRD AND I
UNITARIANS WERE FULL BASE
CALLED ME TO ACT IN ACCORDANCE
WITH MY BELLY AND COLIN TODAY.
IMMIGRANT AND UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS TO CIRCLE THE NINETEEN
DISASTER RELIEF ASSISTANCE
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
MANY OF. AND NO SAFE NET MARK.
THEY'VE BEEN AMONG THE LOWEST
PAID WORKERS TO BEGIN WITH.
THESE ARE OUR NEIGHBORS. ERICA
MY SCHOOL STUDENTS EITHER OUR
FELLOW HUMAN RESIDENTS PLEASE
INCLUDE WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS IMAGINE BUDGET THANK
YOU. TO OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE
FOUR THREE NINE FIVE FOUR THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
CHRISTIAN BEER WITH AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION WE BELIEVE
THAT NOW MORE THAN EVER WE MUST
BE SURE HEALTHCARE ADEQUATE
ACCEPTABLE AND AFFORDABLE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND WE ARE
CLOSE TO SEVERAL THE CUT
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
MAYBE VISION. AS THEY MAY
UNDERMINE GOAL. OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN RELATE TO CUTS IN
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY IN
COVERAGE WE SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSED BUDGET TO PROTECT ALL
THE NEWS OR THE AGE OF FIFTY
FIVE. TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL AS WELL THE JACK
IN THE PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
OPTIONAL BENEFIT UNDER
MEDICARE. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
YOU REJECTED THE PROPOSED CUTS
THE THONG RUN HEALTHCARE
WORKERS TRAINING PROGRAM AND
REJECTING THE ELIMINATION OF
CORPORATE COMMUNITY CLINICS.
ACTUALLY THAN OTHERS WILL HELP
ENSURE CALIFORNIANS AXES THE
HEALTHCARE ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITH CHRONIC. THANK YOU. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE THREE FOUR
NINE FIVE THREE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI WHAT I CAN PUBLIC
ON BEHALF OF THE SALTON SEA OF
GORDY- WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
VESTMENT. PART OF SUNDAY'S SUB
TO HEARING THE BUTTONS WILL
PROVIDE DESPERATELY NEED A
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF POLLUTION
IN THE NEW RIVER. OR OR FORM IS
OFTEN FOUND THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND NINETY TYING THE FEDERAL
LIMIT. IN ADDITION TO DOLLARS
WILL ENABLE ANOTHER PHASE OF
THE PERIMETER MAKE OUTLINED IN
THE FALL HE MANAGED ON ANY.
GAME CHANGER FOR THE EAST.
VALLEY AND PINE ONE JOB
CREATION WILL BE DESPERATELY
NEEDED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ARE YOU
DEVELOP THE FINAL TRAILER
BUILDING WHICH REFLECT THE
MOODY'S CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
BUT AGAIN APPRECIATE YOUR
APPROVAL. THANK YOU AGAIN. YEAH
TO OPEN MY NUMBER HOW. LINES
ZERO THEY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAMCHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PUBLICADO
FROM THE COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO
SPEAKING ON ISSUE NUMBER SIX
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE ONE. OF THE
COUNTY UNDERSTANDS THE CURRENT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REGARDING
ACCESS TO REST AS A PLACE
HOLDER. BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
OPPOSE THE CURRENT LANGUAGE AND
ARE IN STRONG AGREEMENT WITH
THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
SENATOR BELL. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO MEETING WITH BUDGET STAFF
MEDINA LEFT WORK ON A
RESOLUTION TO THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
FIVE SIX TWO ONE FIVE SIX TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. NINE
FIVE SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NO RESPONSE TO OPEN NINE FIVE
SIX EIGHT NINE FIVE SIX EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T.
MODERATOR DO WE DROP THAT CALL.
YES THE LINE PROTECT ROCKED BUT
IF I CAN LOCATE THE LINE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU. MY
PLEASURE. THE LINE TO DROP.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER.
OKAY WELL OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHUNKY PRASAD
FROM CALIFORNIA FIFTY ASIAN AT
THE BANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT YOUR OVERALL APPROACH
LEADING WITH VALUES TO PROTECT
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY THE
TRIGGER APPROACH TO PROTECT I
THANK YOU GRANT. AND OTHER
BASIC HUMAN SERVICES AND THE
PROPOSAL TO RESTORED SIXTY
MONTH CAL WORKS CLOCK. THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING IMMIGRANT TAX
FILERS WITH CHILDREN UNDER SIX
IN THE KELLY AGENCY AND WHITE.
HE HOWEVER WE REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE INCLUDE ALL IMMIGRANT
TAX FILERS TAX CREDIT. WE'RE
SEEING A 73% INCREASE IN
EMERGENCY COULD DEMAND SO WE
SUPPORT YOUR INCLUSION OF THE
ME REVISED PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY
MILLION PER TO BANK FUNDING AND
SIXTY THREE MILLION PER CHILD
NUTRITION. ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS WILL HELP BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN RESPONSE TO RECOVERY
AND CONTINUED HER ADDRESS
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES FOR THOSE
OF US WHO ARE LOW INCOME
SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES LGBTQ IMMIGRANTS
AND BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE.
THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
TWO TWO SEVEN LINE TWO TWO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER
LAURIE FROM WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW ANDPOVERTY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE HEALTH ISSUES. WE
COMMEND THE SENATE FOR LOOKING
BEYOND CUTS IN INTO SOLUTION TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR
ELDERS BY NOT REINSTATING THE
SENIOR PENALTY. NOT EXPANDING
ESTATE RECOVERY POLICY TO
DESTABILIZE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
MAINTAINING CRITICAL MEDI CAL
BENEFITS. WE APPRECIATE THE
EXPANSION OF HEALTH BROUGHT
ELDERS AND URGE THE TIMELINE TO
BE MOVED UP TO COVER ELDERS TO
UNDOCUMENTED DURING THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. WE ALSO WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE REJECTION OF
CUTS TO THE BLACK IN GOOD
HEALTH PROGRAM AND THE POST
PART IN THE TERM MENTAL HEALTH
THAT THE BENEFIT GIVEN THE ON
GOING TO TURN ON BURKE
DISPARITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY CONSIDERING BASS NUMBER
OF PEOPLE RECENTLY LOST THEIR
HEALTH COVERAGE WE REQUEST
CONSIDERATION BE GIVEN TO
FUNDING THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
TO ASSIST PEOPLE AND ROLLING
AND- CAL. IT SENATE LEADERSHIP
ABOUT FOR TOPPLED SO. THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE SIX
FIVE NINE FIVE SIX FIGHTER LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR BERKELEY DELGADO ON
BEHALF. OF HEALTH DIRECTOR OF
ASIAN WHAT THE PHD A APPRECIATE.
KNOWLEDGE OF THE NEED FOR WE
ALIGN BACK SO WE URGE TO CHANGE
JUST ABOUT COME OUT FIRST WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE PUBLIC THEY
HAVE A HEALTH. TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IT A LOT. REALIZE THAT
AND EACH. YEAR THAT FEDERAL
MATCHING OF THAT SHALL. BE
UNLAWFUL FOR NOTHING VERY.
SERVE ANY CHILD MEDI CAL MENTAL.
NEEDS AND YEAH HE SHE WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE BACK THE ONLY
ALLIED WITH FOR HHS AND KATELYN
PROGRAMS INCLUDING YES. YES SB
KEEP. WE ASK THAT THE FUNDING
OF REALIGNMENT NOT BE TIED TO
TRIGGER WHAT WE NEED TO FIND
MEDI CAL MENTAL HEALTH YEAH
CONSIDERATION OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL. DHEA ACOSTA OF
THE OUT CLINIC. WE ARE THANK
YOU. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE
THREE SIX NINE FIVE THREE SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY- MY COMMENTS
RELATED TO ITEM TEN ON AGE
EIGHTY. FIVE IT IS REGARDING
YOUR CALL OUT IN CLINIC. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR RAY REAL BEFORE
I MEAN HERE'S A COLLEGES WILL
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS I
HAVE BEEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THE PAST EIGHT YEARS. ON
BEHALF OF THOUSAND MENTALLY ILL
CRUELTY WHO ARE YOU READING IS
LIGHT. AND CRITICAL THE- ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
PRISON ALONE I WOULD LIKE TO.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO THREE
YEAH. I AM I FEEL THE ALL. A
CLOSING WILL GRAHAM. AND RAISES
THE CRIME IN THE COMMUNITY AND
GOING BACK TO PRISON WOULD GO
OPPORTUNITIES AND WOULD WOULD
BE INCREASE AND THEREFORE
DEFEAT THE PURPOSE OF BALANCING
THE BUDGET I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OU- MANAGER NIELSEN
BOOKLETS POINT. TO THAT YOU
HAVE WITH A COLLEAGUE BECAUSE
THE COUNTY ARE NOT OF THE BABY
HE IS ME NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
READ REQUIRED CRITICAL LIKE.
THAT FROM COOPER CLINIC THANK.
YOU SO MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
BEST. AND NEXT ALL MY NUMBER
FIVE TO THREE NINE FIVE SEVEN
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU SIR AND SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FRANK
ROBERT YES WITH THE CENTRAL
COAST ALLIANCE UNITED FOR
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY I'M HERE IN
SANTA BARBARA- INDEED- TO THE
INCLUSION OF WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOME REPLACEMENT. FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEEN
IN JUNE BUDGET THE CONCLUSION
OF I TEN FILERS AND CAL THE IDC
AND WHY. THE I'M GONNA TO
INCLUSION OF HE DID IT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN THE STATE BUDGET- AND
ALSO THAT TO SUPPORTING HELPS
OUR SENIORS- AND THE SERVICE.
ECONOMY HAPPY ECOSYSTEM HINTON
A BARBER WE ARE SEEN TRUE THIS
THAT ARE MISSING RECESS SHOWING
THAT NEARLY ONE IN FOUR
PANDEMIC JOB LOSSES IN
CALIFORNIA HIT NON CITIZEN
IMMIGRANTS. AND REALLY WANT TO
SEE- HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A STAKE IN A PRODUCT AND
THAT IS SUPPORTING EVERYONE.
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OPEN NUMBER SEVEN
NINE. FIVE SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MADAM
CHAIR IN SENATORS MY NAME IS
LYNN CURSING AND I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS IN LOS ANGELES WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATE CREATIVE
FUNDING AND REJECTION OF HUGELY
IMPACTFUL CUTS. LIKE C. PEN WE
WANT TO REITERATE THERE IS NO
PRIVATE FOUNDATION FUNDING FOR
NAVIGATORS AND ASK THAT THAT
PROVISION FOR PRIVATE FUNDING
IN EFFECT TO CUT. BE REJECTED
AND THAT THE NAVIGATORS BE
REALLY REINSTATED WITH A GROUP
OF PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED JUST LAST YEAR WITH
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS. THESE
NAVIGATORS ARE ROLLING IN CASH
CARDS PANDEMIC HEALTH PRESS
ROOM PROGRAMS AND OF COURSE
HEALTH CARE THAT KEEP PEOPLE
ALIVE RIGHT NOW. DESPITE DAILY
NEWS PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO
GET TESTED FOR COVERT WHETHER
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE THAT THEY WILL
BE CHARGED. AND OR OR DEPORTED
FOR ACCESSING THIS CARE THEY
TURN TO TRUST ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS. WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SENATE FOR
RECOGNITION OF EXTENDING MEDI
CAL FOR WOMEN WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS. AND
FOR NOT CUTTING OPTIONAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS MUCH NEEDED
AND ONLY RECENTLY RESTORED
DENTAL CARE FOR ADULTS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
FOUR SIX FOUR NINE FOUR SIX FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BACK YOUR
COLOCATION CONNECT HE BRIEFLY
AS TUCKER OF THE POOR SO
ARTICULATE WE ARE NOT A
DUPLICATE SERVICES WE PROVIDE
AND HOW SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
RISK ASSESSMENT TO MENTALLY ILL
PAROLEES WHO HAVE JUST BEEN
RELEASED FROM PRISON WE PROTECT
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU. STE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE SIX ZERO
NINE FIVE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT THOSE WERE BACK AGAIN
DOLLARS FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE WANT TO
THANK TE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR THE SENATE PROPOSAL THAT
HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD AS A
SCALED BACK THE MOST DRACONIAN
CUTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IN PARTICULAR WERE THANKFUL
THAT CUTS WERE INJECTED FOR
SENIOR HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ABOUT INSURE THAT ALL PLAYERS
REGARDLESS OF AGE DISABILITY
THE AMOUNT OF THEIR SAVINGS AND
ASSETS- IMMIGRATION STATUS. ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FALLS GOT MEDI CAL
BUT WE REQUEST THAT THE
PROPOSAL FOR COVER AND
DOCUMENTED SENIORS BE
IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY WE WERE
ALSO THANKFUL THAT THE
REJECTION OF HAD THE SO CALLED
OPTIONAL BENEFIT THE MEDI CAL.
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED IN CUTS TO
COVERAGE AND COVER CALIFORNIA
WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S BACK ALREADY
ALLOCATED AFFORDABILITY. FUNDS
AND WE ALL MADE. THANK AND- BY.
AND CONSIDERING THE ECONOMIC
PAIN MANY CONSUMERS ARE. ALSO
WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FEET AND- WEEKLY COME UP FUND
DOCKING WORKER. PLEASE EXCUSE
ME BE. TO ALL IN ACT FILERS NOT
THOSE WITH CHILDREN UNDER.
LASTLY WE WANT TO BE YOU FOR
OUR- AND THOSE AT THE BILL.
RECEIVE AS I AM A HE BENEFITS
AND ALSO WE IN THE SIXTY NINE
TIME PARK IN. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER FOR SEVEN LINE FIVE TEN
SIX LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE FIVE
SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS DOCTOR GEDDIE
KLEIN PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO MITIGATE
HARM TO OUR ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN COLLEGES DURING THE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WE
RECOMMEND ELIMINATING
CALIBRATE. THIS REDUCTION WOULD
OFFSET PROPOSED CUTS IN THE MAY
REVISED THAT WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT INCLUDING CUTS
TO STRONG WORK FORCE PART TIME
FACULTY SUPPORT AND THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO ADDRESS
THE LONG TERM FLAWS OF THE
FUNDING FORMULA AND ENSURE
ACCENTED PRIORITIZED WHEN
DEMAND INCREASES IN THE COMING
YEARS A 10% PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING ALLOCATION SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED. FINALLY WE URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE ANY EFFORTS TO BLOCK
GRANT THE UPS CATEGORICAL
EIGHTEEN YOUR PS FUNDING AT
CURRENT LEVELS WILL ALLOW THE
FINAL PROGRAM TO CONTINUE
SERVING IN SUPPORTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER FOUR
SEVENTY LINE FOR SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. AND THE THIRD
JHANA GARY WITH LEGAL AID AT
WORK WITH ADVOCATE THE RIGHTS
OF LOW WAGE WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SPEAKING TODAY AND
PART OF THE FOR ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN IT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS MOVING
THEIR JOB AND THEY TAKE LEAVE
FROM WORK TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES IN YOUR CHILD. OR
FAMILY MEMBER. IT PROBABLY DOES
NOT REQUIRE EMPLOYERS RIGHT
HE'D LEAVE RATHER INSURANCE
EMPLOYEE NOT THAT THE PAID
FAMILY BENEFITS THEY THEMSELVES
PAY FOR WITHOUT BEING FIRED FOR
DOING ABOUT. FORTY MILLION THE
CALIFORNIANS NOT COVERED OUR
JOB PROTECTION LAWS BECAUSE
THEIR EMPLOYERS TO SMALL ISSUES
BETWEEN THEIR FAMILIES HELP
THEIR INCOME WHAT THE PROBLEM
BEFORE THAT AND I MAKE. BUT
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS THE
CARD FROM THOUSANDS OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS ACROSS THE CLINIC AND
HELP LINE ONE THING IT BECOME
CLEAR THE CONTINUATION OF THAT
THE NEXT LITTLE AT THE MIDLAND
CONTRA BALK. NOW IS THE TIME TO
ACT TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
ECONOMIC. WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND. BEYOND THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE
ZERO ONE NINE FIVE ZERO ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE FIVE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
NINE FIVE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. OKAY DROPPED ONE ON
THAT PLACE. NEXT PHOTO MY
NUMBER TWO SEVEN TWO ONE TWO
SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YEAH MY NAME IS VALERIE YOU CAN
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEVEL AGREEMENT
DOCTOR. WHO CALLING REGARDING
HUMAN SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTY FAR. I AM ASKING THAT THE
SENATE REJECT THAT MAY REVISION
ALTHOUGH THAT WHATEVER THE
FUNDING. OF PLAN FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT TO ALICIA.
ONE OF THE GREATEST BARRIERS WE
HAVE DEDUCTIBLE CALIFORNIA IS
LEGAL SERVICES FOR MOCKING ANY
THE IMMIGRANTS IN PARTICULAR
ELIMINATING THE FELLOWSHIP OF
THE LATE WOULD BE A MAJOR
SETBACK FOR A VERY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY. IN ON OUR BELIEF IN
THE MARK EIGHT. THOUSAND TO THE
LIVE IN BATH AND THAT WILL BY
THE HANDS OF THOUSANDS POINT IN
THE FUTURE BY CRITICAL LEGAL
SERVICES FOR THE LOCAL.
COMMUNITY HEALTH NOW MORE THAN
EVER. IT WAS DESIGNED TO
GROWING FIFTEEN IMMIGRATION
LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND
REPRESENTATION FROM ALL
COMMUNITIES AND OUR EIGHT. IN
PARTICULAR IT WOULD REMEDY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND CENTRAL
CALLED. A LACK OF WE STARTED TO
TAKE ON A COMPLEX INTEGRATION
CASES. AND PROVIDE.
REPRESENTATION IN A LITTLE BIT.
THE PROVIDER MODEL WITH WHICH
MORE RESEARCH WE DIDN'T THE BAY
AREA PARTNER WITH LONG WEEKEND
TO ENSURE FLOW OF THE- OF THE
TECHNICAL THE- END OF OUR- LONG
TERM. TO PASS IN THE WORLD WE
AND. NATALIE O'BRIEN AND I
REPRESENT- PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC. AND I AM SINCE THE- I'M
CLOSING. THE ELIMINATION OF
PAROLE OUTPATIENT CLINIC WE ARE
NOT A REDUNDANCY SERVICE. WE AS
THERAPISTS WORK CLOSELY WITH A
PSYCHIATRIST. AND WE HELP IN
THE TRIAL OF MEDICATION.
ESPECIALLY TO HELP WITH.
TRANSLATION OF DOCTOR TO
PATIENT VICE VERSA OF
INFORMATION MANY PAROLEES DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY IN SPITE OF HAVING
MEDI CAL BECAUSE OF THEIR
CRIMES. UNPREDICTABLE HABER
EMBOLIC KHILADI PLEASE
RECOGNIZE THAT PEROT OUTPATIENT
CLINIC IS AN ESSENTIAL SERVICE
TO CDC ARE WE ARE THE ARE IN CD
C. R. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE
BYE. ECHO BUT MY NUMBER FIVE
EIGHT THREE LINE BY THE THREE
YEAR LINE IS NOW OPEN. CHRIS
RESPONDED WITH THE COALITION.
RIGHT CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
AMERICANIZATION CURRICULA
BEGINNING ABOUT HOW MANY
STUDENTS AND WORKERS. BUT YOU
MAY BE AWARE CHIRLA WAS ONE OF
THE TALK YEAR OLD WHO WERE
SELECTED RIGHT YEAH YEAH. TO
DISTRIBUTE AFTER A WILL BE
ASSISTANCE. FOR IMMIGRANT. ON
THE ORGANIZATION IS OVER A
MILLION CALLS COULD TRYING TO
NEED AND DEMAND OF RELIEF BURKE.
DESPITE DIFFICULT WITH THEM
FIRST WORRY TO PROVIDE ALL UP
OVER SIX ALL OF THE CASE CHIRLA
SURVEY PROP TO DOGGONE MEMBER
BETWEEN MARCH MAY AND ARE FINE
INCLUDE SEVENTY PER. HAVE AN
IMPACTED WITH REDUCED WORK
HOURS WHEN THEY ARE ABOUT 42%
AND UP WITH THREAD WAS ON THE
RISE. FORTY PERCENT- BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S A MIDDLE DEEPLY
WITHIN TWO WEEKS THAT'S WHAT I
TECH WILL BECOME FROM MY
COLLEAGUES CALLED. STATE. ON
COME REPLACE. UP FRONT WORKERS
USED BUDGET ALSO ECONOMIC AND
OF EXPENSE CARRIER YOU SEE ALL
I CAN PROUD ALL FOR THE YEARS
THE SEAT INITIATIVE AND ALL
ISSUE BEFORE ASKING THAT THE
IMMIGRANTS FOSSE BE KEPT THANK
YOU. FIND EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS NAME I'M WITH THE ONE
COMMITTED TO INCLUDE ALL
IMMIGRANT FILE AND THE CALL
YEAH I YEAH I DO THREE OKAY BUT
WE ALL BEFORE THE DAY MISTER ON
A WEEKLY RETAIN. FINE BROWN DOC
THEIR WORK OR EXCLUDED FROM I
MEAN FOR INSURANCE. CORDY BABY
NOT FOR ALL YEAH. ONE THREE
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME A CAT NUMBER THE
PHONE FOR ACCESS WE SECOND THE
CALM BY OUR THAT PLAN
PARENTHOOD. REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL TO SHARE
FIFTY SIX DOLLARS A FROM PLAN
SERVICES ADDITIONALLY WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE SENATE IS
PROPOSING TO MAKE A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
COURSE TRANSMITTED PREVENTION
AND TREATMENT PROGRAM HERMAN
IN. THIS IS ESPECIALLY HE AS WE
EMERGE FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY BECAUSE WHILE ASKING
BEAVER THE EPIDEMIC THAT
EXISTED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AN
ADDITIONAL OUTBREAK OF AND HE
IS EXPECTED ACT CODED. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS
ISSUE. NINE FIVE A FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. A
NEW TIMING PLAN ON GOING ON
BEHALF OF INNOVATIVE AN ADDICT.
I'M. IN ORDER UNLISTED
PROGRAMMING NINE SPRING BREAK
BUT WE WILL ALL KNOW POPULATION
AND WE ARE YOU TO ACT IN THE
PROGRAM. THAT MODEL AND
CRITICAL BE YEAH AND WITH THAT
ARE THANK. IN MIND THREE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI. THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHARLOTTE
PLAYING WITH THE PRO OUTPATIENT
CLINIC I'M OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE TO END OUR PROGRAM WE
PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL
TRANSMISSION SERVICE FOR
MENTALLY ILL INMATES HELLO INTO
THE COMMUNITY WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT ACT THE THIRD
BOTH WILL. WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE SIGNIFICANTLY POPULATION
INCLUDING THOSE CONVICTED OF
VIOLENT CRIMES WENT BACK THE
PHONE. OUR PROGRAM IS A
SPECIALLY AFFECTED BECAUSE WE
WORK IN CONCERT WITH FEDERAL
AGENT IN ADDITION WE MAY HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO GENERATE
REVENUE BY SECURING MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS HELLO. WITH THE
INCREASING PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS AND INCREASED
RELEASE OF INMATES OUR PROGRAM
IS MORE ESSENTIAL THAN EVER.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THE STATE OF THE ART I AM A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITHOUT COOPERATION CLINIC
REGARDING COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
ISSUE NUMBER TEN I AM OPPOSED
TO ELIMINATION UPON- OUTPATIENT
CLINIC. WE ARE THE FIRST LINE
OF DEFENSE FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PROVIDERS THAT MEANS
ANY EASY ACCESS TO OUR SERVICE
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THE SAME
PHYSICAL LOCATION BUILDING WITH
A QUALITY GAMES ANY METHANE
BEACH LANCASTER FROM AN IT'S
AWFUL. AND AGAIN ELIMINATING
OUR OUR P. AS THE WILL BE A
DETRIMENT FOR THE PUBLIC
SPEAKING. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY
FIVE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS A-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS MARLIN I SEE
ALL AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HAPPY
UP AND I WANT I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE GIRL OUT THE
ASIAN CLINIC- I THANK YOU- ALL
MY COLLEAGUES- AND I DON'T WANT
TO REPEAT WHAT THEY SAID BUT I
WANT TO SHARE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING CONTINUITY OF CARE WE
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE ARE PRESENT
WHEN THE PROBABLY ARE RELEASED
I HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR A LONG
TIME- IN CLINIC. AND I CAN. HOW
WORKING WITH THE WERE GOING TO
BE. AFTER BECAUSE LOANS L. AND
THEN. NUMBER RIGHT. OF CARE
WITH WITH I THOUGHT. BEST
SERVICES ON A DAILY BUT THIS IS
NOT AT ALL RIGHT OF SERVING.
AND IT CANNOT BE HER RIGHT IN
COMMUNITIES WE THAT IN PAST
OTHER BILLS THAT. WERE ARE AND
ENDED UP GETTING TO ME SERVER
THE THING UP COMING BACK TO US.
SO THE WAY THAT I BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO- URGENCY IS THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO PUBLIC SAFETY COST
FIGHTING COSTS THAT THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE A SAVINGS IT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE A COP IN
BOTH WAYS FOR THE NETS CLINIC.
ALL OF THE OTHER. WE'RE GOING
TO BE NEEDED MORE THAN. PLEASE
RECONSIDER AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TIME. MINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS-
CARL LUNDEN OF LONDON AND SALAS
ADVOCACY REPRESENT YOUR WINE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL. DISABILITIES WHEN
I THINK THE SENATE LEADERSHIP
AND CHOOSING A DIFFERENT PATH
RELATIVE TO COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES CALIFORNIANS WITH ID
DE AND THEIR FAMILIES WE STAND
READY. TO ASSIST YOU IN PURSUIT
OF YOUR PLAN- WE BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATE PROGRAMS
OF ALL TYPES AT A TIME WHEN
THERE ARE NO REPLACEMENTS. HE
TO LIKE THIS SHOULD NOT BE MADE
DURING THIS CRISIS. GOAL REALLY
SHOULD BE ABOUT SURVIVAL SO WE
HAVE A PLATFORM FROM WHICH TO
BUILD. COMING OUT OF THIS
CRISIS. SECONDLY ABOUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. LIKE TO MENTION WE
SUPPORT YOUR PROPOSAL TO REJECT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO ELIMINATE PHYSICAL THERAPY
FROM MEDICARE ALL MAKES NO
SENSE THAT A PATIENT FOR
EXAMPLE. COULD GET A KNEE OR
HIP REPLACEMENT BUT NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE NECESSARY
PHYSICAL THERAPY THE FOLLOWS.
THAT PROPOSAL SEEKS FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION A LOSE LOSE OVER
FOURTEEN MILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS MAKES NO SENSE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. NINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THREE DIFFERENT
ITEMS ONLINE IN THE HELP YOU
NEED SERVICES BUDGET. THIRTY
EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE ITEM
TWELVE AND SIXTEEN RELATED TO
SEE BASS AND THE AND THE
PROGRAM. ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
COMERS LA ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE
COUNTY AND ALZHEIMER'S SAN
DIEGO WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
REJECTION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
NEWLY REVISED PROPOSAL WE DO
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE FOR
ALL POTENTIAL CUT. FIRST IF WE
ARE UNABLE TO YOU GET FEDERAL
ON. AND SO WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR. TO
AND SEE THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
VERY MUCH COST SAVINGS TO OUR
SENIORS AND KEEP THEM IN THEIR
HOMES. A VERY VALUABLE
POPULATION ADDITIONALLY ON
ITEM. ON PAGE THIRTY NINE
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BUDGET ITEM FIFTEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
ANESTHETISTS. WE AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE OUT PUSH AND THE
REJECTION OF THE MAY REVIVE.
BUT THE PUSH OCTOBER ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY HOWEVER THERE ARE
GOING COUNTY WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OUT OF THAT YOU.
WOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO.
SERVICES SURE THIS PROPOSAL GET
PUSHED RAIL. PEOPLE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE BABIES AND
WILL CONTINUE TO NEED SURGERIES.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS.
COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE CUT
AND WE AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF OF
DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER BY THREE ONE
FIVE FIVE THREE RELY IS OPEN. A
LITTLE OF AFTER THE LOOK
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATE EFFORTS
AND PROPOSED ACTIONS UNDER THE
SUB ONE ON EDUCATION.
SPECIFICALLY THE ADOPTION OF
ISSUE NINE RELATED TO EIGHTY A
HOLD HARMLESS AND INSTRUCTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. WE ALSO URGE THE
STATE PROVIDE STABLE FUNDING TO
AVOID MADE YOUR CUTS. ON THAT
NOTE WE DO HAVE A DIFFERENT
POSITION FROM A PREVIOUS PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ISSUE FIXED
ON THE ACCESS YOU ROUGH ON ME
WHICH WHICH WAS PULLED FOR
DISCUSSION. THE CURRENT MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL INTENDS TO
ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING
PRACTICE OF MISCALCULATING
ACCESS IRAQ BY CERTAIN COUNTY
THAT RESULT IN AN ANNUAL LOSS
OF THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IN PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE INCLUDED AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEEING. BY
ENSURING THAT COUNTY ARE
ACCURATELY CALCULATE ACCESS
YOUR AFTER ACCORDING TO THE
ALLEY- REPORT FROM MARCH BUT
THREE IRAQ MISCALCULATION
IDENTIFIED RESULT IN JUST OVER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD. IF THIS
LANGUAGE S NOT ADOPTED. NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING WILL GET AN
ADDITIONAL ONE BILLION DOLLAR
CUT ON TOP OF CUTS THAT WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING. FOR
THE- FROM ENFORCES EXISTING LAW
TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL RECEIVED LEGAL
ENTITLEMENT OF LOCAL PROPERTY
TAXES FORTY THREE THEN. URGED
OPTION THE GOVERNOR ACCESS YOUR
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN
MIND FOUR HOW YEAR LAW IS OPEN.
I'M HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. MY
NAME IS THERE AGAIN AND I'M A
pCALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS FOR ALL. AND I WANT
TO CALL THE VOICE MY OPPOSITION
TO THE MAIN BUDGET REVISE ITEM
ELIMINATE GIRL OUTPATIENT
CLINIC WE WORK WITH AN
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE AND AT
TIMES FOLLICLE POPULATION THAT
STAYS HOME. YOU FILE AND-
INDUSTRY. PRINTER WITH THE-
BUDGET AND I'M QUITE. YOUR
THEIR CRIMINAL HISTORY. I DON'T
WANT TO BE REDUNDANT TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES OF OUR ANY
ELOQUENTLY SPOKEN. I WILL JUST
SAY THAT I KNOW WHAT THE
CURRENT CO THAT NINETEEN CRISIS
WE'VE STARTED CHALLENGED
EVERYBODY I'M NOT THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC CRISIS IS FORCING A
HARD LOOK AT. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGED ARE. AND DEMONSTRATE
THE NEED FOR MENTAL. THE
COMMUNITY WE DO PROTECT
COMMUNITY SAFETY BY PROVIDING
QUICK ACCESS TO TREATMENT AND
ASSESSMENT THAT PROTECT THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER FIVE SEVEN TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THAT MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
WILLIAMS WITH THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT WE
WANT EXPRESSED CONCERN WITH YOU
PROPOSAL THE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
PORTION OF THE PROPOSED BUDGET.
MAINLY ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN THE
CONSOLIDATION OF INMATE FIRE
CAMPAIGN ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX THE REALIGNMENT AND THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND THAT MAY LEAD TO THE
CLOSURE OF THE PINE GROVE YOUTH
CONSERVATION CAN'T. MY CONTRACT
WITH YOU CONSERVATION CAMPS AND
TO HELP MITIGATE HIGHER RISK.
YOU ASKED AROUND YOU
COMMUNITIES. BUT AND THE EAST
BANK THE FIRE RAISING CAMP ARE
IMPORTANT FOR REGIONAL RESOURCE
DURING FIRE SEASON PREPARATION
AND PROVIDE VALUABLE TRAINING
AND- AS YOU AND IT'LL- THE
CLOSURE THE HERE WHAT A- RANDY.
AND EVEN THOUGH IT FROM CURRENT
LEVELS FUEL AND EDUCATIONAL
MATH FOR PROTECTION YOU HIGH
FIRE RISK AREA WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO YOU CAN YOU THE
IMPORTANCE THESE CAMPS HAVE.
HELLO COMMUNITIES AND THE EAST
BAY AREA AS WELL AS THE
BENEFITS TO THE CREWMEMBERS
GEARING CONFEDERATION OF THE
BUDGET THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. NEXT TO OPEN MY NUMBER
FIVE EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING ARE
COMMON TODAY. MY NAME IS EMILY
FERRY IN SUPPORT OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES MY COMPANY
PROVIDES SUPPORT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
POPULATION. WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATE AND WITH HER
SUPPORT FOR THE SAME PROJECT
HUTCH. SERVICES OUR LIFE
CHANGING AND THEY ARE
LIFESAVING ESPECIALLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HIGH RISK
FOR CALL THE NINETEEN WE NEED
THE SUPPORT MORE THAN EVER NOW
AND WE ALSO HAVE. HE BEAT
CLEANING SUPPLIES AND OVER TIME
AND MANY OF OUR STAFF. OR ARE
INDIVIDUALS TWENTY FOUR HOURS
FOR INDIVIDUALS GOVERNOR
NEESON'S CUT WOULD BE
DEVASTATING AND THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ALREADY UNDER FUNDED. STATE
THE REQUESTED STUDIES SHOW THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY IS ALREADY
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE CUTTING FUNDING
FOR ONE OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT IN
COOKING SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER FOUR SIX NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GRAY RUSSIA-
WITH YOUR BOOKS IN BERKELEY WE
OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES PROGRAM
IN THE PROP NINETY EIGHT K.
TWELVE CATEGORICAL CUT.
DISCUSSION ISSUE Q. ONE TODAY'S
AGENDA HE DIDN'T GOING ON
RESOURCES EQUALLY SERVE ALL SIX
MILLION COST PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN THE STATE. THEY'VE
BEEN USED OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE MILLION TIMES IN
THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
SUPPORT EARLY CHILDHOOD
STANDARD RESEARCH AND LITERACY
EDUCATION. LEARNING LICENSE
RELATED TO COMPETE NINETEEN
SCHOOL CLOSURES IN THIS
STATEWIDE INVESTMENT OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS SAVED KELLY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR. WE
SUPPORT THE SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO FUND THE PROGRAM
AND MAKE NO CUT TO THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT K. TWELVE
CATEGORICAL FUND. REGARDLESS OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THANK YOU. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FOUR THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS DEBORAH FOR SPELL YOUR
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THE- PROP NINETY EIGHT K.
TWELVE CATEGORICAL CUT IN
DEFENSE OF THE ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES PROGRAM.
92% OF OUR CHILDREN. ALL OVER
THE STATE OF ARE USING THESE
RESOURCES. AT THE COST OF. LESS
THAN THREE MILLION DOLLARS WE
SAY THE DISTRICT. THE WE SAY
THE STATE. MORE THAN ALMOST A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. EVERY STUDENT HAS
ACCESS EVERY TEACHER EVERY
FAMILY EVERY PARENT IT'S AN
AMAZINGLY EFFICIENT USE OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS DURING A
TIME WHEN TEACHERS WERE SENT
HOME WITH A LITTLE PLANNING A
LITTLE TRAINING AND HOPE TO
TEACH THESE A DISTANCE LEARNING
RESOURCES GIVE EVERY STUDENT
ACCESS TO CURRENT VALUABLE
INFORMATION. AS WELL AS
PROVIDED TO THEIR PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS WHO HAVE TO USE THAT
TO PLEASE SAY THE ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES PROGRAM.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE TWO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS
IS CHRISTINA BOUGHT HIM A TEN-
HERE OF REPRESENTING. YOU WU
NOT DOMESTIC WORKERS.
REPRESENTING I'D JUST THAT'S
WORKERS AROUND THE STATE. WE
WANT TO THANK THE SENATE FOR
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS TO CUT IT JUST THAT'S
BY SEVEN PERCENT. TO REJECT THE
IDEA OF- HAVING A TRIGGER FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING AND IN FACT FOR
REJECTING. MOST OF THE- CUTS
PROPOSED AGAIN JUNIOR AND
PEOPLE DISABILITY PROGRAMS.
THESE CUTS MAKE NO SENSE WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
I CHECKED THAT KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES AND OUT OF NURSING
HOMES WHERE WE KNOW MOST OF THE
DEATHS FROM CALL THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN OUR STATE. IT
MAKES NO SENSE THAT WE WOULD
ACTUALLY BE MAKING IT MORE
IN A NURSING HOME RATHER THAN
STAY IN THEIR OWN HOMES WHERE
THEY WILL WORK- TAKE YEAH. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THE NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER THREE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THREE SIXTY
ONE OF DROPPED WILL OPEN THE
LINE NUMBER FIVE THIRTY LOOK
FOR LINE FIVE THIRTY REALIZE
NOW OPEN. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THESE CRUCIAL ISSUES MY NAME IS
MARJORIE CALL THE THOUSAND
OAKS. DISTRICT TWENTY SEVEN. MY
UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST FAITH
CALLS ME TO ACT IN ACCORDANCE
WITH MY VALUES AND TO REITERATE
THAT IMMIGRANT WOMEN AND MEN
AND THEIR FAMILIES INCLUDING
ELDERS BABIES AND CHILDREN.
HAVE BEEN THE HARDEST HIT
ECONOMICALLY BUT ALL GOOD
BECAUSE 30% OF IMMIGRANT WOMEN
AND 20% OF IMMIGRANT MEN HAVE
LOST THEIR JOB OR HOURS. ENTER
COUNTY IS THE TENTH STATE WHY
IS TEMP STATEWIDE IN THE
PROPORTION OF UNDOCUMENTED
RESIDENTS. THESE ARE OUR
NEIGHBORS AND CONTRIBUTING
MEMBERS OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THERE CAN BE NO JUST RECOVERY
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA SO LONG AS ONE POINT
TWO MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
SHUT OUT OF THE ECONOMIC SAFETY
NET. REVISED BUDGET NOT INCLUDE
ANY FORM OF INCOME SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS. THIS
IS. PEOPLE WHO ONE IN TEN CAL
WORK FROM THE SAFETY NET DUE TO
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS
COMPLETELY. IN A CRISIS OF THE
SCALE AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
DEMANDING THE WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS SHOULD
BECOME UNEMPLOYED DUE TO COLD
NINETEEN INCH INCLUDED IN THE
JONES BUDGET. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO YOUR MIND OPEN.
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME RIGHT YES
WE CAN GO AHEAD YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. I THANK- HELLO MANY IN
A GIVEN YEAR AND I AM LIKE
WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THEWEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND FOREIGN
DOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY COVERED
NINETEEN AND IN THE JUNE BUDGET.
CALIFORNIA IT. IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED UNEMPLOYMENT
CRISIS YET ONE HAND OVER
WORKFORCE IS UNDOCUMENTED. AND
IS NOT ABLE TO ACCESS ANY
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. THERE SHOULD BE A
SAFETY NET FOR ALL. OUR
DOCUMENT CANADIAN MUST NOT BE
LEFT BEHIND OTHER STATE WORKS
TO KEEP ALL CALIFORNIANS
INSTRUCTOR WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOME REPLACEMENT IS NEEDED
BECAUSE YOU CAN NOT ADDRESS A
HISTORIC UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS
WITH THE ONE BEHIND ON PAYMENT
GRANT IT WILL HELP FAMILIES GET
BY THE WEEK BUT WITH NO AND-
PRETEND THAT MAKE ANY RIGHT. ON
GOING SUPPORT WILL BE CRITICAL
TO SHORE OUR END UP IN A
COMMUNITY IS NOT LEFT BEHIND ON
THE NINE ALL CALIFORNIANS SAFE
AND STRONG. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO YES HI THIS IS SHOSHANA
BUT OUR AND I'M IN- WESTLAKE
VILLAGE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
WORKING WITH BECAUSE CENTRAL
COAST ALLIANCE UNITED FOR
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY AND I FEEL
AS MANY OTHERS HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN ABOUT THE UNDOCUMENTED
ALL THE WORK THAT THEY O AND
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR- TO BE ABLE TO GET
ANY INCOME REPLACEMENT SO I'M
ASKING FOR INCLUSION OF WEEKLY
PARTIAL INCOME REPLACEMENT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IN THE GYM BUDGET
THANK YOU SO. MUCH NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER FIVE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. NINE FIVE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
SORRY ABOUT THAT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MICHAEL CARLA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL. DON'T STRESS BUCKLEY
OF. THE SENATE BOB SHOES- ISSUE
THREE FORTY FOUR THAT
RECOMMENDED A GIRL MAKING- ERR
BE ON THE CALIFORNIA CAP AND
TRADEPROGRAM. LIKE MANY
MARKET- WE CAN RESULT THAT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW OF AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND IT WE
BELIEVE IT'S AN APPROPRIATE YOU
LOW MAKING AT THE TIME.
CIRCUMVENT THE COMPROMISE THAT
WAS. HE CAME TO AN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LOOK WITH THE COLOR
OF EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT
LITERACY BIPARTISAN. ANY
ENGAGEMENT CRUMBLED
ENVIRONMENTAL BUSINESSES AND
LABOR WE IT AT THE TIME THIS
FROM WOULD UNDULY INCREASE
COSTS WITHOUT ANY ENVIRONMENT
THAT THAT. AND AS SUCH WORK
CURRENTLY OPPOSED WE ALSO
BECAUSE THE EXEMPTION FROM THE
MASTER PROCEDURES ACT WHICH
WOULD REMOVE SOME OF THE
PROTECTIONS CREATED TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC IN A TRANSPARENT
AND- MYSTERY ACOSTA. THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAT
COOPER AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF BIRDS THAT COUNTY
SUPERVISOR V. MANUEL PEREZ.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THE PHONE WITH THE
FUNDING. I COUNTY IS IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
INVESTMENT FOR THE THOUGHT YOU
SEE. THE TYPICALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WHICH
CALLS FOR SUPPORT FOR THE NEW
RIVER IMPROVEMENT PROJECT.
WHICH WILL ADDRESS SOLID WASTE
AND POLLUTION EXPOSURE
CHALLENGES IN THE CITY OF
CALEXICO. ALSO FOR THE PHONE
THE MANAGEMENT PLAN WHICH WOULD
ADDRESS THE AIR QUALITY AND
DUST EXPOSURE ISSUES. IN THE
COULD TELL OF ALLEY. VALLEY
THESE CRITICAL IMPACT WILL GO
ALONG WAY TO HELPING HOW.
NEEDED PATIENTS TO THE THOUGHT
WE- AND TO MAKE. THE LIVER THE
REGION OF THE SALTON SEA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE
PHARMACY AND ITS RESIDENTS.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE NINE
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WOMEN AND MEMBERS
OF THE PHONE IT IS THE ONLY
COMES OUT OF A NUMBER OF THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER AT THE WORLD REPORT
CENTER STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY PARTIAL.
INCOME REPLACEMENT FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY COOL BUT IN
THE JUNE BUDGET. ON ME ELEVEN
BUT YOUR FRIEND OF MINE SHARED
HOW SHE'S DEALING WITH THE
CORPORATE CRISIS. THAT HAVE
IMPACTED TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
IT'S ACTUALLY ARE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY SHE SAID THAT SHE'S
BEEN IN CRYOGENIC TO CHILDREN
ELEVEN AND FOURTEEN COMPLETE
PLAN BETTER MUCH OF POSSIBLE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO KNOCK UP.
SHE EXPLAINED THAT SHE BRING
THE CRIED. FOR HER BABY THAT
THE VACATION. BRING WITH ME.
THE MORE THE RED SELECT. THE
AND THE MORE SHOULD MAKE THE
FOOD. NOT A- I STRONGLY URGE
THE BUDGET TO A WE COURSE
INCOME. ON OUR OWN BUCKLEY
WORKER IN BY. IN THE JUNE. I
THANK BETTER BARACK POINT BACK
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE WE ALSO A CO A COUPLE TO
THE COLOR UNDER. SO THE GENERAL
FUND AND WE SUPPORT THE INCLUDE
OF THE ITUNES FIGHTERS IN THE
COUNTY I TT. TAX CREDIT.
INCLUDE EVEN IF YOU LIVE IN THE
STATE BUT- THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE NINE TWO
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS
KELLY BROKE SOME TESTIFYING
THIS AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF TO
CLIENTS FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE SENATE
FOR YOUR WORK TO PRESERVE THE
SAFETY NET- PARTICULARLY FOR
THE INCLUSION NUMBER OF
REPLACEMENT- FUNDING. WELL AND
WE ASK THAT THE REALIGNMENT
PENDING BE DEALING FROM THE
TRIGGER CUTS- SECOND ON BEHALF
OF THOSE AT THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'D
TO. STAR ARE STRONG CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON EXCEPT THE RACK AND
A LINER COMMENTS AND EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION TO SENATOR BELL
FOR RAISING CONCERNS BEFORE
AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING TO DO
AND I AM REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER. I DID
NOT HEAR OR SEE ANY REFERENCE
TO THE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
AND LEARNING LOS PROPOSALS
CONTAINED IN THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE MAY REVIVE HOWEVER WE
URGE YOUR FULL SUPPORT OF THE
TWO PROPOSALS. AND WITH WITH
REGARDS TO THE LEARNING A LOT
OF PROPOSAL SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
ALL OF THE VULNERABLE STUDENTS
TO RECEIVE. EXTRA LEARNING A
LOT. WITH AN EMPHASIS FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS AND OUR DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNER CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY
HAVE UNIQUE CONSTRUCTION ONLY.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER FIVE NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY CALL. I'M CAUGHT MANY
WOODLAND I'M A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER WOULD
PULL OUT PATIENT CLINIC IN
CHICO CALIFORNIA. I AM CALLING
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE IF YOU
CAN I AM ASKING THAT YOU DO NOT
REMOVED ROLL OUT PATIENT CLINIC
WE ARE THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE WHAT PEOPLE BEING
EXITED FROM PRISON INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE THE FIRST
ONE THAT FORENSIC MENTAL HEALTH
VERY OFTEN WE ARE THE ONLY
FOLKS THAT WILL TREAT BLACK
ARNOLD LESBIAN TRANS GENDER
CLOAKS. LOCAL COMMUNITY
SERVICES VERY OFTEN TWELVE
CHERRY PICK AND NOT SEE A LOT
OF FORENSIC POPULATION. WE ARE
NOT REDUNDANT. AND AGAIN WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BOTH MENTAL HEALTH
IN PUBLIC SAFETY WE ORDERED
THAT YOU DO NOT DO AWAY WITH
COOL OUTPATIENT CLINIC THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS-
LOW THAT'S MENDOZA WITH THE
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE ALSO KNOWN AS A DJ I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS.
CHILDREN UNDER SIX IN THE CAL
YANKEE CNY CPT CREDIT- BUT I
WANT TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE ALL IMMIGRANT TAX
FILERS IN THE KELLY IF YOU SEE.
HI IN THE STATE BUDGET AT OTHER
CRITICAL. FOR THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY EFFORTS. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE FEET
INITIATIVE- AND THE PROPOSAL
FOR A WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT
FUND FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS.
COLLUDED FROM THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WE HERE- AS MANY OF
OUR COLLEAGUE AND COLLEAGUES.
HAVE HERE TODAY- DAY IT AND DAY
AFTER DAY ON THE TH AND THAT
MAKE IT STARTED EVEN EVEN
BEFORE. THE PANDEMIC ABOUT THE
NEED TO INCLUDE COAXING KELLY
IF YOU SEE AND IF THEY DO NOT
FOR ALL SO- PLEASE. LISTEN TO
THE VOICES OF THOSE THAT HAVE
CALLED IN TODAY AND CONSIDER
INCLUDING AT ALL- THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW. LINE FIVE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AND WITH NO RESPONSE ON THE
BONTA MY NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. IF YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. BUT NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER SIX ZERO ONE LINE SIX
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI ON BEHALF AND CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION BFA OPPOSES
THE GOVERNOR'S MAYOR VISION
THAT HAS A TEMPERATURE THAT.
GENERAL FUND REDUCTION TO THE
YES YOU AND YEAH HE DIDN'T
GRADUATE WILL BE KEEPING THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
ADDITION. I YES THEY SUPPORT
THE YOUTH RESERVE FUND BY
ANYTHING YOU TO ANY GENERAL
REDUCTION YES THEY ALSO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING FOR INSTRUCTION
ANALOGICAL TRAINING AND
EQUIPMENT AND MY EVERYTHING AND
NOTHING REGARDING ONLINE
INSTRUCTION FOR THE FALL
SEMESTER. AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOTE IN TUITION AND FEE
INCREASES THANK YOU. TO OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX ZERO TWO. NOW OPEN.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ARE COMING TO ON BEHALF
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY
FOOD BANK IN OAKLAND WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS
WITH CHILDREN UNDER. IF YOU SEE
AND LYFT YOU SEE. AND WE
STRONGLY- URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE ALL IMMIGRANT TAX
FILERS. IN THE COUNTY I TO SEE
IN THE STATE BUDGET. NOT ONLY
IS CRITICAL TO THE STATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. IN A MATTER
OF EQUITY AND BASIC FAIRNESS.
DURING THIS CALL THE NINETEEN
CRISIS IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER. OUR TOOLS FOR
FIGHTING HUNGER AND POVERTY ARE
INCLUSIVE OF ALL. INCLUDING
EVERYONE IN OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX ZERO THREE
YEAR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS DENNIS MEAL FROM LOS
ANGELES DEPENDENCY LAWYERS. AND
DEPENDENCY LEGAL SERVICES SAN
DIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND PARENTS WITH
DEPENDENCY COURT CASES IN LA
AND SAN DIEGO WE THANK THE
SENATE FOR PROTECTING THE
FUNDING FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES IN THE STATE. PLEASE
THE FAMILIES HAVE CHILDREN
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF A
DEPENDENCY COURT WHICH IN THE
LAST THREE MONTHS HAS CONTINUED
OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND HEARING ANY CUTS AT
ALL AS WE FACE THIS RECOVERY
FROM THE SITUATION WOULD BE
DISASTROUS THANK BEING THAT I'M
WORKING TO MAINTAIN OUR FUNDING.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER FIVE NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
DAISY LOPEZ AND I'M WITH THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER AT THIS TIME THAT MAKE
CONTINUES TO UNFOLD AS EVIDENT
THAT THE STAGGERING NEED OF OUR
COMMUNITY ISN'T BEING MET. AS A
DISASTER RELIEF. AND WEBSITE
AND PHONE NINE THE CAR THE
CRASH AND FAMILY WHO WILL CALL
WITHOUT WORK OR SAFETY NET FOR
WE- RUSHED FOR A CHANCE THE
FIRST. HELLO AVAILABLE TO AND
OUTBREAK. EATING UNPLUG.
UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS THE THING
BECAUSE DOLLAR GRANT IT'S LIKE
PUTTING A BAND AID ON AN OPEN
CHEST WOUND. THE FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED THE PROGRAM
OR OR IN THE- TO PROVIDE A
SMALL FRACTION OF UNDER. CAL
THE DIRE. BUT IT NEED. THE
WORKERS AND FAMILIES OF. FOR
THE EIGHT. TO SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PREPARING OUR FOOD
MAINTAINING OUR HOME AND TAKING
CARE OF OUR LOVED ONES. YET
THEY'RE NOT BEING PROVIDED WITH
ADEQUATE EQUITABLE. AND NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES
DURING USE. CALL OUR IMMIGRANT
MUNITY OF THEIR- THAT'S WHY
BOTH I AM THE WAREHOUSE WORKER
READ CENTER STRONG SUPPORT BY
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY. INCOME
REPLACEMENT PLANNED FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEEN
IN THE JUNE BUDGET. ABOUT THE
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS
WITH CHILDREN UNDER SIX IN THE
COUNTY I TEETH BEING AND YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE ALL IMMIGRANT TAX BY.
THE COMPANY I DO YOU SEE IN THE
STATE BUDGET AS WELL AS THE
INCLUSION OF THE HEAT EMISSION
AIR. AND INCLUSION. OF OKAY
FOREIGN. OF AB FIVE. THANK THE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX HUNDRED
AND FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTINEZ FOR
WE ALL SIT AND TURN WITH CHIRLA
AND THE REST OF THE COUNTRY IN
ORDER TO GO. ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE
A PART OF ASKING THE SENATE
INCLUDING PARTIAL WAGE
REPLACEMENT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS IN THE GYM BUDGET.
ASKING BACK HOW WE GOT A FEW.
THE ALL I AND FIVE. AND TO
BRING THE WHOLE BALL IN YOUR AS
WELL AS THE STATE IN. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX OH
SIX WITH YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AIR NOT BE WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE A MEMBER OF THE
OFF THE FF EQUITY COALITION
COMMENTING ON THE PROPOSITION
NINETY PACKAGING KERR SUCH
OCCASIONS. THE COMMANDER SENATE
ATION OF EDUCATION ON THE
BUDGET AND APPRECIATE THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT YOU DON'T
FOR THE GREATEST BARRIERS. IT'S
ABOUT YOUR PROPOSAL TO FULLY
FIND ALTHEA FAST INCLUDING THE
TWO POINT 31% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT WE APPRECIATE THE
HARD CHOICES THAT'S OTHER THAN
THAN OURS BECAUSE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOL.
WOULD BE THE MOST EFFICIENT USE
OF SCARCE FUNDING COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ARE THE ONES MOST
EFFECTIVELY REACHING MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE MOST
UNDERSERVED. SENATE PROPOSED
FOR REOPENING SUPPORT BLOCK
GRANT DOES NOT ADDRESS LAST
NIGHT. YEAH NOT DEVELOPMENT FOR
HOLISTIC STUDENT AND FAMILY
WILL BE THE WAY THAT
COMMUNITIES SCHOOL FEEL. BUT
THE PORTAL. COMMUNITY ENGAGED
AND THE AFTER DAILY AT. HOLD
HARMLESS. BUT I FOR THEIR GUIDE
OR CRY STUDENT FAMILY. AND
DECISIONS ABOUT THE YOUTH BEST
AND ALL STATE IN FEDERAL. CAN
YOU CHEN AND THE NEED. FINALLY
WE ARE STILL. TO PROVIDE DIRECT
EMERGENCY AID UNDOCUMENTED
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN ELIGIBLE
FOR CARE SPENDING ANOTHER
FEDERAL FUNDING. MAY NOT
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE TO THE
STATE'S DISASTER RELIEF FUND.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER TWO FOUR FOR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. LINE TWO FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON RENTAL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACT OF
CALIFORNIA- WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTING THE PROPOSED CUTS TO-
THAT- COVERAGE FOR CALIFORNIA
SENIORS- PARTICULARLY WE WERE
GLAD TO SEE. PARTICULARLY WE
WERE GLAD TO SEE THE BEST PLAN
REJECT THE PROPOSED CUTS TO ALL
SENIORS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE REGARDLESS OF AGE
DISABILITY AND AMOUNT OF THEIR
SAVINGS AND AFFECT THE
MERRIMACK GRATION STATUS. VERY
MUCH A- THE FACT REJECTING. OF
THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND COSTA
MEDIC PLAN DOCUMENTING AS BUT
LEGISLATURE ENSURE THAT THIS
EXPANSION HAPPENED IMMEDIATELY.
OF TO PRIMARY AND PREVENTIVE
CARE TO MANAGE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS MAY BE DEADLY WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE SENATE. BUT
PLAN TO REJECT THE DRASTIC CUTS
THE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
BENEFITS FOR MILLIONS OF ADULTS
AND MEDICAL COVERAGE WE SUPPORT
TO THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN TO
REJECT THE COMES TO PROVIDERS
AS WELL. EVEN IF FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE NOT FORTHCOMING CUTTING
PROVIDERS CUT ACCESS TO
CONSUMERS AND NOT HARM OUT
WELCOME TO OUR COMMUNITY. WE
ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED WITH WHAT
WE SAW IS CUT THE NAVIGATOR
INTERPRETERS PROGRAM WE
CERTAINLY DO THINK THE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS SHOULD BE USED TO.
FUNDED THOSE PROGRAM AND ALLOW
THEM TO MOVE FORWARD AND WE'RE
ALSO DISAPPOINTED TO THE BUT
THE CUTS THAT WE SAW THE COVER
CALIFORNIA THAT THE SENATE HAS
ADOPTED AND CONTINUE OPPOSE.
GOVERNOR SINCE REPUBLIC TAKE
BACK THE READY ALLOCATED
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE FUNDS
FROM COVER CALIFORNIA EVEN MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING
ABOUT HEALTHCARE COVERAGE WHILE
WE APPRECIATE APPRECIATE. THE
SENATE APPROACH WE ABSOLUTELY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO SEEK
REVENUE. WELL HOW TO AVOID CUTS
TO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT
COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
CONVERSATION. WILL CONTINUE ON
THE ISSUE. NEXT CALL MY NUMBER
SIX AND A LOT YOUR LINE NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GREGORY MATHIS WITH COMMUNITY
HEALTH INITIATIVE. IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I'M ADDRESSING THE
NAVIGATOR PROJECT. TODAY WE HAD
A LOCAL BUSINESS FORUM AND HAVE
PROFESSORS FROM CASTING FORTUNE
ADDRESS THE STATE OF THE
ECONOMY IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND
THEY MENTIONED THAT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND ORANGE
COUNTY RESIDENTS WILL LOSE
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE AND THAT
THREE AND FORTY THOUSAND HAVE
OR WILL LOSE THEIR JOBS. GX
MISSION IS TO CONNECT I'M SORRY
TO HE WOULD HELP INITIATIVE
ORANGE COUNTY MISSION IS TO
CONNECT ALL CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND OTHER DOGS TO AFFORDABLE
AND HIGH QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE'RE ABLE TO CARRY THIS OUT. I
AND THE NAVIGATOR PROJECT AB
SEVENTY FOUR BUT THIS PROGRAM
AS YOU KNOW AS MANY BECAUSE OF
TALK ABOUT HIS PLAN TO BE CUT
IN THE MAYBE BUDGET. TO HELP IS
THREE AND FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT COULD THAT HAVE ALREADY
LEFT LOSS OR WILL LOSE THEIR
INSURANCE AND THEIR JOB OF
COURSE WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TO KEEP IT IN THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE SIX
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
IF YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. AND WITH NO
RESPONSE TO OPEN MY NUMBER SIX
FIFTEEN POINT SIX FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS JESSICA BY
FELLOW AT THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY CALLING IN
SUPPORT. OF THE REST DURING THE
SIXTY MONTHS. LIFETIME AID FOR
THE CHARACTER PROGRAM BUDGET
AND I'M NOT POVERTY AND NEVER
BEEN IN SUPPORT OF TIME LIMIT
ON BASIC NEEDS ASSISTANCE. BUT
THIS WAS AS THE GENTLEMAN
MENTIONED THE DEAL STRUCK IN
FEDERAL WELFARE REFORM SIXTY
MONTH ALLOWED. CALIFORNIA SHUT
DOWN THAT SIXTY MONTHS AND GAVE
PEOPLE ONLY FORTY EIGHT MONTH
AND. AND NO TIME CLOCK.
REGARDLESS OF THOSE. OR A- THIS
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL THINK
THAT IT WILL RESTORED TO THE
NATIONAL. MENTAL WITHIN SIXTY
MONTH ON A IT WILL BRING US IN
CAR WITH. TWO THIRDS OF OTHER
STATES WE SUPPORT THAT DECISION
AS WELL AS THE DECISION TO PASS
THROUGH THE ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO TRY AND
CHILD SUPPORT PAID BY A NON
CUSTODIAL PARENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT PAYMENT GETS TO
THE FAMILY. AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
DOLLARS FOR ONE CHILD AND AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR TWO CHILDREN ARE MORE WE
SUPPORT BOTH OF THOSE AND THE
BOLD- LEADERSHIP OF THE SENATE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
CUT. WE DON'T HAVE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ACTION. THE NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER SIX SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
NOT A LOT OF THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION IN
RESPONSE TO ISSUE ITEM TO WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT CUTS BEING PROPOSED
IN THE REVISED TO CRITICAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
TRAINING INITIATIVES LIKE
CAREER CáC ADULT AT
APPRENTICESHIP AND THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM WE URGE YOU
TO MAINTAIN DISINVESTMENT IN
THE FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
LOBBY GONZALEZ NOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION AND THEIR TWO ITEMS
THAT I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
FIRST IS UNDER SUBCOMMITTEE
FOUR- ITEM NINETEEN. AND A WE
WANNA DO THOUGH AND SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. AND
SUPPORT WHAT GENOCIDE KERRY
SAID FROM LEGAL AID OUT WORK.
THE OTHER ITEM IS AND COMMITTEE
THREE ITEM TWENTY FIVE. ASK
THAT THEY'RE NOT BE REDUCTION
TO THE BUDGET FOR THE BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM
EXPRESSLY. DURING THIS TIME
WHEN WE HAVE A BLACK WOMAN
MATERNITY MORTALITY CRISIS
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX EIGHTEEN LINE SIX
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHEN CLEAR RAMSEY I'M FROM
JUSTICE AND AGING- I'M CALLING
BECAUSE- I'M CALLING TO THANK
YOU FOR REJECTING THE
DEMONSTRATE DATING CUTS TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE. OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND I APPRECIATE
THE SENATE BUDGET WHICH
SUPPORTS OLDER ADULTS INCLUDING
THEIR HEALTH AND WELL BEING. BY
PROTECTING THE THING ABOUT I'M
OF THE I JUST ASK PROGRAMS THAT
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE IN OUR HOME
WHICH IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER NOW DURING THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC. WE THINK YOU COULD
NOT REINSTATING WITHIN YOUR
PENALTY FOR NOT REINSTATING THE
OLD STATE RECOVERY WILL. EVER
KEEPING MEDI CAL OPTIONAL
BENEFITS- COVERAGE COULD NOT BE
MORE IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY
DURING THESE TIMES. WE THANK
YOU FOR PRIORITIZING SENIORS
AND- FOR- FINDING CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO THESE PROBLEMS ARE
NOT FOUND IN OUR BUDGET ON THE
BACKS OF SENIORS THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX TWENTY
HE LANDED TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU SIR MENTAL
SENATE LEADERSHIP AND THE
COMMITTEE NICHOLAS CHAVEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS AND
THE SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
COALITION THERE'S BE GONE OUT
THERE HAVE DISCUSSION ITEM. WE
SUPPORT THE KIND OF VERSION OF
THE BUDGET AND CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE 10% CUT TO THE ON
THE SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
BACHRACH. ARTICLE ABOUT THE
ABOUT RICO BUT TRANSPORTATION
COSTS FAR EXCEEDED THE FUNDING
PROVIDED BY THE STATE IN THE
BLOCK GRANT. AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA AT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO COVER
COVERED UNDER THE BLOCK GRANT.
AND ON THE SCHOOL TRY. BLOCK
ACTED. TO BE THE ONLY ELEMENT
OF THE LTFS THAT ARE NOT
RECEIVED CALL A- TRANSPORTATION
TRANSPORTING STUDENTS TO SCHOOL
SAFELY CONTINUES TO BE OUR
MISSION. ACTIVE IN TURN CALLED
IT WHEN DISTRICTS BRING
STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL.
TRANSPLANT CAR TRANSPORTATION
COSTS WILL INCREASE TO
IMPLEMENT YOU SEE GUIDELINES ON
SOCIAL JUSTICE. WE WORRY UNDER
10% CUT. INTO DISTRICTS OF
HIGHER TRANSPORTATION NEEDS
WHAT DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE
FUNDING CALL OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM. DENTAL CLASSROOM
THANK YOU. AND NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS PHILLIP CRAB ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT THE
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK
OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET. HAPPEN TRADE OPTION
PROCEEDS WILL LIKELY NOT BE
ENOUGH TO ALLOW FOR FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH WAS GIVEN
SECOND PARTY IN THE BUDGET.
WITHOUT THIS WORK BY THE AIR
DISTRICTS TO CLEAN UP LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
SLOW OR STOP ALTOGETHER. THIS
IS PROBLEMATIC GIVEN FINDINGS
OF EXPOSURE TO AIR POLLUTION
COMBINED WITH CODE NINETEEN
RESULT INCREASE STEPS AND
EXACERBATE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS. FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN IMPLEMENTATION I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THE HELP
COMMUNITIES IS PROTECTED. WE
BELIEVE THAT ERROR CARD PATIENT
FUNDING SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
SAME PER LEVEL AND WE CHECKED
VERSION OF AIR POLLUTION FUND
MONIES FOR NON AIR QUALITY
PURPOSES. SOURCE OF THE
APPLICATION LAST YEAR SHOULD BE
AGAIN THIS YEAR THIS IS TIME
WILL BE GIVEN NOT. TO EAT PCF
WILL BE DECIDED. THANK YOU. AND
OPEN NUMBER SIX TWO TWO ONE SIX
TWO TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THE CALIFORNIA ONLINE CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. FIRST OFF WE
WOULD LIKE TO A MINOR COMMENTS
WITH THE FACT THAT WOULD BE A
WHOLE SERVICES. WE ARE
SPECIALLY CONCERNED WITH. THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AT THE TIME
WE ALSO REQUEST EVEN FOR FOSTER
CARE PROGRAMS INCLUDING F. HEAT
AT THAT STAGE AND. THE FIRST
PROGRAM THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAME TO BE TRUE TECH
WHAT SECOND AS OPPOSED NEED
OPTION THE NET OPERATING LOSSES
BENJAMIN BUSINESS TAX CREDIT
LIMITATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
CANTIERE IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT IS
PRIMARILY BASED UPON WAGES PAID
O OUR AND THE PROFESSIONALS.
ACTIVITY THAT MUST OCCUR IN
CALIFORNIA. ESTARá NEW CREDIT
COULD BE CONSIDERED AS A CREDIT
TO HIRING KEEP COREY. OKAY ARE
INDEED. IN A TIME OF RECORD I
AM UNEMPLOYMENT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO OPEN MY NUMBER SIX THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS
IS PATRICK WHAT SHOULD THE
CALIFORNIA MINUTES WILL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
THE NOT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AUTHORITY AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
THE WHOLE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
REJECT. ACTION TAKEN BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO ON
SUNDAY RELATIVE TO CAP AND
TRADE THAT WOULD INITIATE A NEW
RULE MAKING THREE REASONS. WE
BELIEVE THE POLICY ISSUES
RAISED IN THE PROPOSAL WERE
ALREADY ADDRESSED DURING ROBUST
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
DELIBERATIONS ON THE EXISTING
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED UNDER EIGHTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT. WE BELIEVE THAT-
ANY ROOM THAT WOULD CHANGE THE
PROGRAM DESIGNED COMPONENTS AS
IN A FIGHT IN THE TRAILER BILL
COULD REACH INCREASED COST
AFTER CUSTOMERS. I'LL
STRUGGLING TO PAY THE BILLS.
THE CARD THAT NIGHT INDUCED ACT
CHRIS. AND FINALLY. WE BELIEVE
THERE THE KERR DESIGN OF THE
CAP TRADE PROGRAM WORKING AFTER.
IN CONSULTING INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN ENERGY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME HERE TO REJECT A PROPOSAL.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IF YOU SURELY DOWN THE
HAPPY CALPERS GO BIRTH AT THE
ASIAN I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY- COLLEAGUES
FROM CAT SO AS FAR AS IT
RELATE TO THE BUDGET BUT ALSO
HIGHLIGHT ISSUE. NUMBER
SECRETARY JACK YOU ROUTE. ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD NOT
GO TO SCHOOL IN ADDITION TO THE
CUTS THAT WERE ALREADY
RECEIVING WE REALLY- YOUR
SUPPORT AND A DOCKING FOR THE
BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU. NEXT
TO OPEN MY NUMBER SIX THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE AND SUMMER BAYERN'S FUND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. ITEM
TWENTY FIVE FREE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WHICH WOULD
REDUCE THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION SPACE ON BUDGET
BY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
STARTING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ONE GOING. WELL WE
ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE MANY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THIS BODY
MUST MAKE WE APPLAUD SUPPORT
FOR ACCESS TO LOW COST OUTDOOR
RECREATION. URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD BY THE CRISIS TO SUPPORT
THEIR MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH. ALSO ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY MAJOR CONNECTION
NATURE FOR ALL LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST IN
ESCONDIDO CREE CONSERVANCY
WHICH DON'T SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDED REDUCTION.
REDUCTION OF SUBCOMMITTEE TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE THE
WITHDRAWAL OF EIGHTY TWO OH
NINE AND ROOM RECOMMEND THAT
YOU DIVERSE OF HIGH THE
WESTMINSTER. ALSO INCLUDE NEW
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
DIVERSE COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROGRAM AND OUTDOOR EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER SIX THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. AFTER THE
LARGER MEMBERS- MY NAME'S POSH
ON STRATEGY WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND YOU SEE.
ACROSS THE- CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING TODAY TO THANK THE
MEMBERS AND THE COMMUNITY OPT
FOR JIM FACTORED TIME THAT YOU
PUT FORTH. IN PRESERVING OUR
MARCH NECESSARY IN CRUCIAL
FUNDING TO OUR MEDICAL CENTERS
THE MEDICAL SCHOOL AS WELL AS-
FOR REDUCING THE BUDGET IMPACT
THAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED. TO
THE UC ALL I ALSO LIKE YOU KNOW
THAT WE DO HAVE. A LOT OF THE
IMPACT STILL EVEN UNDER THE
OPTION OF THREE DEPRIVE OUR TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF A PROPOSED CUTS COULD STILL
ARE YOU ARE YOU IMPACT OUR
ABILITY. TO PROVIDE CARE
RESOURCES SO IF YOU ARE DOING
THIS TIME SEARCHING THAT WE CAN
ARE WE WOULD LOVE TO ASK ABOUT
THE SENATE YOU MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS NO COST TO THE HOUSTON
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OPEN LINE SIX THIRTY MY ME SIX
THIRTY. YEAR LINE IS NOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MONEY IS VERY DIRTY
ON THE OF THE- THIS SO
ASSOCIATION. I JUST WANNA FOR
THANK. FOR YOUR MISSION NAME IN
A DRY ALL CURRENT RECESSION YOU
COMING UP A LITTLE THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE HARMFUL CUT THE
SERVICE. INDIVIDUALS WERE.
INTELLECTUAL ABOUT THIS. THE
NINE MEMBERS OVER FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH IBV. AND BEAN
THIS IS A THIS. CALL DELAY. TO
SERVICES THAT WERE THERE LOOK
BECAUSE THEY WERE UNDER FUND.
I'M PARTICULARLY THE REJECTION
OF THE- CUTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAYBE BY TO SERVICE FOR A-
LOWER THAN THAT. IN SERVICE
THAT THEY NEED SEE WHAT THE
GLASS HEAR. AND THE CREW CIRCLE
TO ON MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE
FOR. SHE CURRENTLY ACCESS SO
THANK YOU AGAIN LEADERSHIP
YOU'RE SHOWING THE SENATE AND
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT. A
LOT THANK YOU. NEXT TO OPEN
NUMBER THIRTY YEAR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF YOUR
COLLEAGUE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
VALLEY ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY QUALITY
COUNT CHALLENGES IN THE
COUNTRY. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PRIORITIZE YOUR AT FINDING
BERKELEY NINETY FULL EQUIPMENT
FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM. AND WE
URGE THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM BE MAINTAINED AT FIFTY
MILLION AND INCREASED POSSIBLE
GOOD DISTRICT ALSO APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED FUNDING OF THE
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
HOWEVER WE DO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
ALLOCATE FIFTY MILLION.
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IN THE
GYM BUDGET AS ARTICULATED BY
KEPCO AND OTHER DISTRICT. OF
YOUR THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. CARLOS
MARQUEZ YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION REGARDING CARE
DOCTORING OFF FINDING EACH YES
THEY REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EXCLUSION OF BLENDED LEARNING
AND IT THAT STUDY PROGRAMS FROM
CARE ACT FUNDING. AS REYES
EARLIER BYSTANDER MORALE WE
SUPPORT AN AMENDMENT TO INCLUDE
ACCESS TO THESE FUNDS OR NON
CLASSROOM THE SCHOOLS WITH
PHYSICAL SIDE GIVEN THAT IT'S
PRECISELY THE STATE THAT
PROVIDE. INDEPENDENT STUDY
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
ENGLISH LEARNERS THE ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTION THAT THEY HAVE TO
GO WITHOUT THE RESULT OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES. THE ISSUE NOT
CHARTERS ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS
AVAILABLE TO DISTRICT AND I'LL
SEE ABOUT. AS SUCH WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT HOLDING ALLEY A-
HELL YEARS HER MUSTER CURRENT
YEAR EIGHTY EIGHT LEVEL THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMFUL TO
GROWING ELEAZAR. AND FINALLY
SHE'S YET THEY PAPERS THE
ADMINISTRATION SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL WHICH WE DO
WITH CARE AND IMPACTING THE
BROADEST NUMBER OF SCHOOLS. AND
LOW INCIDENCE DISABILITIES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
BUDGET CHAPIN DEAL OUT ON THESE
MATTERS THANK YOU. ANNEX TO
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX FIFTY TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS COREY CELLS A LITTLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE THE LA IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SHE IS A
SAY AS PART OF THE COUNTY-FAMILY URGES THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION. TO BACK FILL
LOS REALIGNMENT REVENUES THAT
SUPPORT VITAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN REALIGNED TO THE
COUNTIES. THIS MONEY FUND
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SAFETY
PROGRAMS INCLUDING AROUND
PROGRAMMING AND TREATMENT OF
SUPERVISED INDIVIDUALS. THAT
ARE NEEDED ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
COUNTIES ARE ON THE FRONTLINE
OF CODE NINETEEN RESPONSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD WE CAN HEAR YOU
ONE MINUTE. HI THIS IS FRANKLIN
ROUGH NON I'M A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT.
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AYE OPPOSED THE
ELIMINATION OF THE WHOLE
OPERATION CLINICS WE PROVIDED A
UNIQUE SERVICE TO UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS ARE COUNTIES ARE
NOT EQUIPPED TO. HANDLE THIS
POPULATION- THE PROGRAM IS
REMOVED IT WILL IMPACT OUR
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE JAIL
POPULATION. ARE INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC UNIT PLEASE
CONSIDER KEEPING. ANEXO OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS REGINA BANG I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOOP IN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY CAL. WE WERE TO
JOIN WITH THE CACOPHONY OF OUR
COLLEAGUE WHO ARE THINKING. FOR
INCLUDING IN A TAX FILERS
CHILDREN ARE SIX AND THE CALLEA
TO SEE IN ENTIRE CREDIT. I WANT
TO URGE COMMITTEE TO LOOK ALL
TAX FILERS. IN THE EARLY
EIGHTIES IN THE STATE BUT AS.
IT CREDIT TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. NOW MORE
THAN A- WE NEED TO IT THE
INVESTMENT FOR LONG TERM. THAT
WILL LOSE LOCAL. PROTECT ALL
HELP. WORKERS AND MOST OF. A
TRACK STAR IN A- CHORE CáC TEN
HER. YOU HAVE TO BE IN A CA.
FOR IMMIGRANT WORKER. AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU VERY. THE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX SIX
ZERO LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE SIX
SIXTY LINE AND. ROBERT MAN
WEARING FROM NOW I WON TO FIRST
THANK YOU FOR YOU EFFORTS TO
REACH FOR THE CAN TWENTY.
HOWEVER FUN WON'T BE SIX UNLESS
YOU CLOSE TO DRUM LOOP THAT THE
STATE I HAS AGAIN FOR THIS
BASICALLY. IF DESTRUCTION USE
ALL OTHERS ON CONSTANTON IN A
FIST YEAR. IN FOLLOWING YEAR
THEY TO INTO JOE PURPOSE FUNDS
DISTRICTS CAN USE THEM FOR.
PURPOSES AND THE LARGEST IN TEN
THEM. SO WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
ADOPT LIBERAL TO THAT LOOPHOLE
IN ADDITION IN IN THE POINT
NINE BILLION. OF LEARNING LAW
NEEDED FUND SENT IS TAKING A
DAY APPROACH AND I GOT. AND THE
ALLOCATE OF THE FONG. IN
PARTICULAR. THE GOVERNOR TO
OKAY ON DISTRICTS WOULD HIKE.
OF STIR TO ME. WHERE THE SENATE
IS TO MORE. APPROACH SENDS
FUNDS ALL THIS. WOULD BE THE
CALL. AS ACT COLLISION COME UP
WITH AN ALTERNATE. THAT CAN
BALANCE TWO AND PROVIDE. MORE
FUN TO ALSO BUT TARGETED AT
THIS THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
THANK YOU. AND TO OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW. LINE BY EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. AND WITH NO
RISK WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
SIXTY THREE LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIX SIXTY THREE. YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
IF YOU COULD OPEN UP TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YES MA'AM
WELL OPEN MY NUMBER SIX THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL. AFTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AT. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE THE ONE TO
THANK YOU INCLUDE A CRASH
RELIEF MEASURES IN THE VERSION
OF THE BUDGET THAT YOU. THE
RELIEF MEASURE PROVIDE USUALLY
CRITICAL PORTRAY AGENCY STATE
THEY GRAPPLED FINANCE OPERATION
IMPACT THE COVER NINE AND THEN
ACT IF ENACTED THE SPECIAL
RELIEF MEASURES WOULD COULD
FRIEND FUNDING IN SURE THAT
TREND AGENCY VERY QUICKLY TO
PROVIDE LIFELINE. THE SERVICE
IS TO COME AND GOING TO WORK
THROUGHOUT OUR WANT TO THANK
YOU YOUR STAFF. HOW CAN THAT
THE INVENTORS BALLOT MIKE. FOR
IF YOU'RE HEADING THAT DOCTOR
AND RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO THE
WILL MEASURE AND ATTENDED TO
BUDGET CAR THAT LOOK TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AND THE
LEGISLATURE COULD POINT THEIR
INCLUSION IN THE JUNE BUDGET.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON THE HOUSE
ABOUT WITH UNITED WAY THE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OUR
STATE LIKE MEMBERSHIP OF THIRTY
LOCAL UNITED WAYS COVERING
ALBEIT COUNTY I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE ICE AND
FILERS WITH CHILDREN UNDER SIX
WILL CARRY A TO BE IN THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT WE COULD HAVE.
NOTHING NINETY THOUSAND
CHILDREN HOWEVER WE MUST
HISPANIC- EXPAND THE CREDIT TO
INCLUDE ALL I CAN BUY LARGE AND
THE PHONE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN AND I
CAN EITHER HELP I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE ALL
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS IN THE
KELLY AGENCY AS IT IS CRITICAL
TO THE STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
EFFORT. I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
UNITED WAY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE FALL TEN MILLION FUNDING
FOR KELLY AGENCY OUR. REGION
EDUCATION AND WE TAX AT. THE
GYM GRANT. AT THE TIME OF ANY.
AND TO ME FOR TAX FILING.
DRASTICALLY FOR YOUR DATA CAL
COLLECTED FROM WORKING
IMMIGRANT AND FOR YOU THE DAY
HAD THE LATE CHECK HEY WITH
ACTION. INCLUDING THE HOUSEHOLD
AND LARGE THERE SHALL. WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE THIS YEAR AND WE
UPON YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS SO
FAR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR MITCHELL AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS JIM WHEN BURKE FOR THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SINCERE THANKS TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR REJECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WHICH CRAWL OF
ITS JANUARY PROPOSAL TO SIGN
MEDI CAL FOR. INCOME ELIGIBLE
SENIORS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. MOVING
FORWARD AS WE ARE IN THE MIDST
OF A PANDEMIC WE THINK IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE FIND A WAY
TO FUND THIS EXPANSION NOW.
RATHER THAN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. MEXICO TO LINE
NUMBER SIX SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI KATIE
HARDING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THAT CLAIM TO REJECT
THE 10% CUT THAT LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND THAT I'M
FUNDING FORMULA. AND DJ
ALTHOUGH THE COURT THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REGARDING
ACCURATELY CALCULATED ACT THAT
IRAQ FOR SCHOOL THANK. NEXT TO
GO TO MY NUMBER SIX SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER O'DONNELL AND I'M
WITH THE UNITED WAY OF FINE I'M
TRAINING AND WE COORDINATE A
COALITION OF OVER THIRTY
PARTNER. THE NUMBER I'M NOT
LOOKING A LAKE COMBO AND DAHLE
NOR. THE PROVIDE FREE TAX
PREPARATION FOR OVER SIX
THOUSAND CLIENTS. AND I WANTED
TO CALL TODAY TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE LEADERSHIP
FOR INCLUDING I CAN FILERS WITH
CHILDREN UNDER SIX. I'LL BE A
BIG HELP ALTHOUGH WE HAVE.
ENCOURAGE THE EXPANSION AND
INCLUSION UP ALL I CAN FIVE
MURDERS- IT WE BELIEVE IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EFFORT. AND NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE NEED INVESTMENT
FOR THE LONG TERM THAT WILL
BOOST LOCAL ECONOMIES PROTECT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS. AND
MOST IMPORTANT ADDRESS
STRUCTURAL INEQUALITIES IN OUR
CáC WITH THEM THAT CURRENTLY
EXACERBATE INEQUALITY FOR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE EXPAND. OUT HOW THE I.
T. T. AND THE CHILD TAX CREDIT
ALL I CAN FILERS. IN. THE NEXT
COURT ALIVE NUMBER SIX SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND ANY
MEMBERS OF THE GENUINE
HALFPENNY. AND I'M THINKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILY COALITION. AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER BILL WHICH
WOULD ALLOW PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS TO TAKE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE WITHOUT FEAR. OF
TERMINATION A RETALIATION RIGHT
NOW TOO MANY PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS IN THE STATE TO PAN
THE FUND. ARE NOT COVERED BY
JOB PROTECTION WHEN THEY USE
THAT BENEFIT TO BOND WITH THE
CHILD. CARE FOR AT THREE STILL
FAMILY NUMBER AND IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER RIGHT NOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FINAL
BENEFIT WE HAVE IN THE STATE-
WORKS FOR EVERY FAMILY WE URGE
YOU TO APPROVE IT. THANK YOU.
NEXT ABOUT A LINE NUMBER SIX
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS A
SOUND LIKE A CLINICAL OCIAL
WORKER. EVEN IN OPPOSITION.
SELECT COMMITTEE FLYING IN THE
NATION HELLO. UNDER COVER
NINETEEN THE STATE IS RELEASING
TO REDUCE COSTS AND THE REST OF
THE CLOSURE OF FALL OUT CLINIC
WILL TRANSFER UP TO EIGHTY
CLINICIANS INTO THE PRISON. I
NEED HELP AND SAFETY WHICH DOES
NOT MAKE MUCH SENSE. WE ARE NOT
A DUPLICATE OF SERVICES BECAUSE
I'M COLLEAGUES NOW HAVE MEDI
CAL BENEFITS. UNDERSTATED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED WE
ARE YOU UNIQUE SPECIALIZED
FRANTIC MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC
THAT WORKS OF THE KING WITH
CORAL AGENTS AND FAMILY. WE
TREAT THE MENTALLY ILL VIOLENT
SEXUAL PREDATOR INMATES WITH
CHRONIC MENTAL TRAITS THAT
COULD NOT BE RELYING TO COUNTY.
PROBATION UNDER AB ONE NINE. WE
ARE LOOKING AT THE PRO OFFICES
AND OFFER SAME DAY ON THE SPOT
THE ESCALATION OF MENAL HEALTH
CRISES. INDIVIDUAL THERAPY CASE
MANAGEMENT AND MEDICATION
SERVICES. BOB GOOD CLOSING UP
PROGRAM IS A RESPONSIBLE AND
WILL HAVE AN ADVERSE EFFECT
THINK OF ADDED BURDEN. COUNTIES
AND TO COMMUNITY SAFETY AND
PATROL AGENTS JOB OF
SUPERVISING I'M ON THE TRAIN
PROBABLY BEHAVIORS. THANK YOU
I. HOPE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR BEFORE YOU OVER THE
NEXT LINE LET ME JUST ANNOUNCED
TO EVERYONE THAT WE- HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING PUBLIC COMMENT FOR A
LITTLE OVER TWO HOURS NOW WE
WANT TO THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
THEIR PATIENTS OUT WE'VE GOT
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
CALLERS REMAINING I'M GOING TO
ASK EACH CALLER TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO UNDER ONE MINUTE.
MOST PEOPLE HAVE BEEN-
DISCIPLINED- BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN A FEW THAT HAVE GONE OVER
SO I'M GONNA ASK THE REMAINING
THIRTY FIVE TO UNDER ONE MINUTE
FEEL FREE TO SAY- THE CHORE
SUPPORTIVE CAUGHT OF COMMENTS
MADE BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS THANK
YOU MODERATOR PETE OPEN UP TO
THE NEXT CALLER. BY TWO SIX
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOU KNOW WHAT A
HORRIBLE. WELL YEAH YOU CAN ON
BEHALF OF THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA OUR MEMBERS ARE OVER
FIFTY AND SPECIALLY HARD HIT BY
COVERED NINETEEN. WE SHOULD
HAVE CONCORD MANY APPS OF THE
SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I
WILL JUST QUICKLY DOES NOT
AGREE WITH CONCORD NUMBER FOR
ITEM NINETEEN WHICH IS THE
GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WITH THEM JOB
PROTECTION FOR FAMILY EVER.
DIVERSE TAKING THEM. I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE REJECTION OF
MANY HARMFUL CAUGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE OCEAN BUDGET THAT
WOULD HAVE FORCED SOME OF THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. HOME IS A
VERY TIME WHEN THEY HOSPITAL
HOME AND THEY SHOULD NOT BE IN
THE HOME. SO WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR CONTINUED ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF OLDER CALIFORNIAN AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YOUR NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
WHAT THE WIDENING GROUP FIRST
REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON TO ITEM
THE FIRST ONE IS. ISSUE SEVEN
UNDER SUB THREE- WE SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT
ADMINISTRATION WITHDRAWAL OF
HEALTH FOR ALL BUT OPPOSE THE
DELAY OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM A LITTLE LIKE THE-
ACTING FOR UNDOCUMENTED I'D BE
IMPLEMENTED AFTER URGENCY. WE
ALSO WANTED JOIN PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS ON THE COMMENTS ON
ISSUE FORTY UNDER SUB FOR.
WHICH ONE THING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE INCLUSION OF IBM FILERS
WITH CHILDREN. AGES SIX AND
UNDER INTO YEAH I DO SEE AND
THE YOUNG CHILD THAT TAX CREDIT
BUT WE WANT TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE- YOU HEARD FROM MANY
SPEAKERS INCLUDE. ALL IDENTIFY
ALERT TO BE. ELIGIBLE FOR YET
YOU SEE THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME AT THEM
TOGETHER WATCHING NUMBER
REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. ALL I
MY COMMENTS WITH A PREVIOUS
SPEAKER CANING PART OF MEN FROM
PTA AND JUST MAKE. A QUICK
POINT ONE BEING THAT WE OPENING
OUR SCHOOLS WILL REQUIRE MORE
NOT FEWER RESOURCES TO ENSURE
PROPER AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
REOPENING GUIDANCE AND THAT'S
WHY WE URGE THE USE OF THE
THING TRAINING DAY FINE. FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL AND SECOND WE
URGE THE CREATION OF A SPECIAL
EDUCATION FORMULA FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT ON THE BAND. THAT
FUNK BASED O MODERATE. COULD
THE NEAR THE ABILITY THANK YOU.
AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. I GET AFTERNOON THIS IS
LISA KNOX I'M WITH CENTRAL
ABOUT THAT ACROSS AN OPEN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE YOU TO
PLEASE SAY THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
WHICH IS A PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
GROW AND GAIN IMMIGRATION LEGAL
ASSISTANCE AND REPRESENTATION
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE. AND I CAN PERSONALLY-
ATTESTED EFFECTIVENESS OF
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS PROPOSAL I
PARTICIPATED IN A PILOT FOR THE
PROJECT THAT ALLOWED THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS FOUNDATION TO
BUILD AN IMMIGRATION PROGRAM.
REPRESENTS DANGER ABOUT ABOUT
GETTING AND- IMMIGRATION COURT
SO I KNOW THAT THIS PROGRAM
WORKS AND I URGE YOU NOT TO
ABANDON WILL COMMUNITIES IN THE
HIGHLAND CLICHE. THE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM THANK YOU. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS
DONNA ENGINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS I WANT TO ECHO WHAT WAS
SAID BY NINA WYLER HARD WELL
AND JUNIOR CASSIDY. A REGARDING
FOR ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN THAT
ENSURES THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN CARING FOR A
LOVED ONE AND LOSING THEIR
JOBS. AND THAT ALSO JUST WANT
TO SAY WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
NOT A TIME TO WEEKEND BUT
STRENGTHENS THE CARE GIVER
SUPPORT. GIVEN BY THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS IN AT
THAT P. AND FEEDBACK AND OTHER
IMPORTANT- PROGRAMS THAT HELP
OLDER ADULTS AND THE FAMILY
ACROSS GENERATIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GREETINGS BUT
I'M SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS-
TROUBLE ROGERS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY- PROVIDING COMMENT
TODAY LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES- TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR INCLUDING ALL I CHEN
HOLDERS IN THE CALENDAR TCN
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. AS WELL
AS THE INCLUSION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AN HOUR EACH FUNDING
FOR THE CAL YET YOU SEE
INCREASED TAX PREPARATION
ASSISTANCE. WITHOUT REACH
FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO LEADING
THOSE NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CAL YET YOU SEEN YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT NO ABOUT THE CREDIT
AND A WAY TO FILE THEIR TAXES
FOR FREE NEEDS DIRE ECONOMIC
TIMES- WE'RE ALSO EXPRESSING
SUPPORT OF DECEIT INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING ON BEHALF OF THE
WORKING PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
THANKS I NEXT OPENED MY NUMBER
THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW I'M OPEN. AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS TRUTH OF ALLAH LIKE THE
LOCAL SOCIAL WORKER AT CDC ARE
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE CROW
OUTPATIENT CLINIC. PLEASE ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL POPULATION THANK YOU.
CONNECT TO OPEN MY NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. OKAY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND WE
SEND OUR THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION AND OF COURSE TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW ITEMS OF
IMPORTANCE TO BE ON THE-
COMMUNITY NAMELY THE
ELIMINATION OF PHARMACY
SERVICES ON YOUR MEDI CAL WHICH
WE OPPOSE. ON THE ONGOING NEED
FOR A SATISFIED WITH THE BIG
NEED FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAS LAID OUT BY
OUR COLLEAGUE JOURNALISTS
EARLIER. ON THE ELIMINATION IN
WHICH WE OCCUPY THE FEEDBACK
AND OTHER SUPPORT FOR SENIORS.
THE SHIP AND POP THE DEFECTS
FUNDING AWAY FROM GOVERNMENTAL
PAYMENT THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT- ABOVE A FEW ADDITIONAL
ITEMS LAID OUT IN A LETTER TO
SUBMITTED. TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU AGAIN. AND NEXT LINE
SIX EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON BODY HUNG
ON BEHALF OF THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE- WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIA WITH MICROGRAM. IN
TRAINING THE STAR HI GOOD.
GOODNESS WORKER COOPERATIVES
EVEN THE SHOULD WOULD HELP TO
CREATE QUALITY JOHN PROMOTE
WORKPLACE DEMOCRACY AND BOLSTER
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE ALSO AFTER
SUPPORT FOR WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT ON FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS INCLUSION OF AYE
COMPILERS IN CAL THANK YOU HE-
AND PRESERVATION OF THE
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP.
IN ADDITION IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WORKERS BE ABLE TO RECOVER
THEIR STOLEN RGION ESPECIALLY
DURING THE- FOR THE REASON WE-
YOU CAN FUNDS FOR THE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT WORKERS.
AND THE JANUARY VERSION OF THE
WORKER RESTITUTION THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
EVEN SEPTIC OFFENDER ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
THE STRONG THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK WHERE TRUMP
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S PEAK
FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
PARENTS THE CARE GIVERS ARE
COVERED BY. DEBORAH AND
THEREFORE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BOND THAT
THEY ARE PAYING INTO WITHOUT
RISKING THEIR JOB. WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS WITH
CHILDREN UNDER SIX AND THE CAL
YANKEE HE AND YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT I WANT TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE ALL
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS IN THE
CALLIE I TT AND THE STATE
BUDGET. AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT
WAS DURING THE SIXTY MONTH TIME
LIMIT ON CAL WORKS AID. AS
REVISED IN UNDER FEDERAL LAW
THANK YOU. NEXT PHOTO LINE
NUMBER FIVE TWO TWO SIX ONE
FIVE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HERE IN MEMBERS ONLY
IF THE REQUIREMENT CALTRAIN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WITH
RESPECT. SHE RELATED TO CAP AND
TRADE WITH. ALL SENATE BUDGET
ON SUNDAY WITHOUT QUESTION AND
MEET YOU I DID TELL BY SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES. MALAYSIAN BUT
THREE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING.
OUR REALTOR WILL MAKE YOU MAJOR
COMPLETED. I CAN GET HAPPENED
POLICY IN WAITING PROTECTION
FOR MAKING ABOUT APPROPRIATE.
CREDIBILITY CALL BY PART
RECOUP. MARKET VIEW CARBON
EMISSIONS PROGRAM AS WELL THERE
WILL BE. THERE ARE SEVERAL
QUICKLY THE NATIONAL BUDGET
LIKE A WE REJECT ON APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE- BRING TRAILER
FACTOR FOLK FOR CONSIDERATION.
WE ALSO PROVIDE A NUMBER
NINETEEN IN FRONT COMMITTEE FOR
THAT WOULD OVERWHELM NON PLAYER
BY OPPOSING A TWELVE WEEK WITH
A BACK HOME ON EMPLOYERS ARE
GOING WHAT IN KUWAIT. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE YOU CAN
LEAD TO DRESS COME IN NINETEEN
IN THE RECORD ON THE. POLICY
ISSUES. OUR BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THIS IS THE KING OF THE
SAME CALLING CARE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE OF THE SHIP.
AS YOU HEARD FROM PREVIOUS
POLICE HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN ON
THE CALL YOU KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE LARGEST AREAS WE HAVE IN
OUR DAY IS LEGAL SUPPORT FOR
IMMIGRANT IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
ELIMINATING THIS PROGRAM FROM
THE BUDGET WOULD BE OF USE THAT
ACT OR COMMUNITIES WERE VERY
VULNERABLE ESPECIALLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN FEDERAL COURT
CONTROL CALLED EXCUSE ME WHERE
WE HAVE LACKED RESTORED. IT
TAKE ON COMPLEX IMMIGRATION HE-
ACTUALLY PROVIDE REPRESENTATION
IN REMOVAL DEFINED. THIS
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM WOULD BE A
SOLUTION TO THE LONG TERM
EQUITY CHALLENGES AND IN THE
TIME MORE THAN EVER THIS
PROGRAM IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
THE MODEL IF YOU HEARD BEFORE-
REGIONS- LIKE OURS CAN PARTNER
WITH THE BAY AREA. AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL. WORK WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY HELP THE FOR A FLOOR
RESOURCES ON TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP OUR LONG TERM CAPACITY
SO I FINALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT TO
THE. FELLOWSHIP THANK YOU. AND
NEXT OPEN LINE SIX TWO YEAR
LINE NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE BERMAN BEHALF THAT YOU YOU
CAN S. YEAH YOU APPLAUD THE
SENATE FOR DEVELOPING- MUCH
MORE BALANCED APPROACH THE MAY
REVISION. IN PREFERRED-
PRESERVE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE
HOWEVER IT STILL RELIES TOO
HEAVILY ON. BORROWING AND NOT
ENOUGH ON REVENUES WE ARE JUST
SENATE YOU SEE GREATER BALANCE
THROUGH CREATIVE REVENUE
MECHANISM. THAT DON'T PLACE
TOMORROW'S BURDENS ON THE BACK
TO THE DAYS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND FROM MINE HEROES. PLEASE
DON'T RICH REPEAT THE MISTAKE
OF PAST RECOVERIES. WE ASK THAT
YOU. CONSIDER RAISING REVENUE
AND INVESTING IN THE RECOVERY
AND AVOID THE ARE GARY.
APPROACH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NEXT OPEN SIXTY SIX LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
BUDGET PROVISIONS FOR THE
SALTON SEA THE LARGEST LAKE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE CITIZENS ARE
SUFFERING WITH THE MOST SEVERE
CONDITIONS THE BEAGLE SYSTEM
COLLAPSE. AND ECONOMIC DISTRESS
DUE TO THE CHAIR RATING
ENVIRONMENT AT THE SEA AND ALSO
THE NEW RIVER. MY NAME IS CAST
LIST ALLEN I SERVE AS VICE
PRESIDENT ON THE BOARD FOR THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
AS WELL AS CHAIRMAN ON THE
SONGS YOU FORTY. THE SENATE
BUDGET PROVIDE HOPE FOR
IMPROVING CONDITIONS THAT THE
NEW RIVER ONE OF THE MOST
PUNITIVE EVERYTHING AMERICA
IMPACTING HUMAN. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. THE
SENATE BUDGET ALSO LUNCH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. IN THE
NORTHERN PORTION OF THE SOUNDS
HE TO PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH FROM
EXPOSURE. THE LOAN FROM THE
EXPLOSPIDER PRESERVES VITAL
WATERFOWL HABITAT FOR THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY. AND RESTORED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
STRUGGLING RESIDENTS WHO ARE
AMONG THE POOREST IN OUR STATE.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE BECOME.
THE MOST CATASTROPHIC HUMAN
HEALTH. SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SEVEN ZERO
TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SUFFICIENT
CROCKETT PATIENT EDUCATION.
WRITING ISSUE NUMBER Q.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE WE APPRECIATE AND ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS STRONG WORK
FIRST PROGRAM FUNDED AT CURRENT
LEVELS SPENDING FEDERAL AID
JUST DEPEND ON FEDERAL FUNDING.
FIRST EXTRA WORKERS PROGRAM TO
ALLOW THEM TO. WHO THEN
CONTINUE PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
ENOUGH BAKER EDUCATION IN THE
COUNTRY WE URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN
A STRONG WORKER SPENDING IN THE
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU. I NEXT
OPENED MY NUMBER SEVEN ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS JULIAN WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY GIVEN THE SHORT-
OUR STATE INVESTMENT SHOULD
PRIORITIZE EQUITY AND JUSTICE
INCLUDING UTILITY RENTAL IN
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE IN THE
SHORT TERM AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRESERVATION AND
PRODUCTION IN THE LONG TERM.
PROPER SAFETY MEASURES
PROTECTIONS AND PP PERSON TO
WORKERS INCLUDING CARMEN FOOD
WORKERS AS WELL AS PATHWAYS TO
JUST CLEAN JOBS IN THE LONG
TERM. AND ALSO UNIVERSAL
BROADBAND ACCESS INCLUDING IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES WE ALSO
SUPPORT INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY
DRIVEN AIR QUALITY CLEAN SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICE. AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE PROJECTS
THE TIME OPINION WE PROVIDE
JOBS LASTLY DID A ONE EIGHTY
THREE FOR AYE COMPILERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. FOR
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATIONS THANK
YOU. AND NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
FOUR ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI IAN GOLD REPRESENTING
ENCYCLOPEDIA BRITANNICA PRO
QUEST AND TEACHING BOOKS. WE
WANT TO SAY DITTO TO PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY ACCORDING TO SENATOR
EFFORTS TO RESTORE VITAL
FUNDING FOR ONLINE DIGITAL
RESOURCES FOR CALIFORNIANS TAKE
YOUR TWELVE FAMILIES TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS THANK YOU. THE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SEVEN ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ADDRESSING ISSUES.
COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE IN ISSUE
NUMBER TEN AND OURS
PARTICULARLY WANT TO SAY
SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATOR
NELSON FOR HELPING US HELPING
TO CLARIFY THIS ISSUE THERE'S
OVER TWO HUNDRED OF US
LISTENING TO YOU SENATOR WE
APPRECIATE YOU CLARIFYING THE
ISSUE. MY NAME IS DARK IN THE
BURGER AND WE ARE OPPOSING. THE
ELIMINATION OF P. O. C. AND-
FEEL THAT WE WANT TO SAY. IS MY
PROGRAM I WANT TO BE REALLY
GREAT. MOST PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHAT HE'LL SEE DOES IT BRIDGES
THE GAP BETWEEN INMATES COMING
OUT OF THE PRISON AND GOING
INTO THE COMMUNITY IF THEY
HAVE. WILL HEALTH PROBLEMS
THEY'RE GOING TO APPEAL SEE WE
GET MEDICATION MAKE A
COUNSELING TO GET. BUT THERE'S
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF WILL ALSO
HAVE SOME BEER LIVES- ILLNESS
THOSE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
GRATITUDE DRESS. IS MATH
PROGRAM. THERE IS A HUGE
MISUNDERSTANDING. THAT THE
COUNTY CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICES
BUT THEY CAN. HAVE THEY HAVE
PRESCRIPTION THE EXPERTISE THE
MAN POWER OR THE SPECIALIZED.
SO LIMóN EIGHTEEN PROGRAM.
ELIMINATED USED PROGRAMS WILL
CAUSE A HUGE IMPACT ON OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY I THANK YOU
COMMITTEE LISTENING TO ME LET'S
SAY THE IS NOT UNLESS STATE
APPEALS THE PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE SEVEN OF SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY AND HIGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
APPRECIATE THE PHONE A
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO
BALANCING THE BUDGET AND
CONTAINS THE HEALTH CARE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FUNDS
PROPOSAL TO REJECT DEVASTATING
PAT IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM BOTH
FOR. THE PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING
AND I DAHLE DENTAL BENEFITS
UNTIL THERE IS TIME FOR FEDERAL
ACTION AND THEN PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL REVENUE SOLUTION IF
NEEDED ALSO QUICKLY ONE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN OF THE CARE
COALITION FOR THE FENCE
PROPOSAL TO REJECT ELIMINATION
AT THE MANY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS. CREATED UNDER PROP
FIFTY SIX WE HAVE SUBMITTED
WRITTEN COMMENTS THE. COMMITTEE
AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. NINE SEVEN TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
IN THE WEST WING I REPRESENT
THE ASSOCIATION OF REACH OUT
BETTER AGENCIES WHO WANTED TO
BRIEFLY THANK THE SENATE OR ITS
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED TO
ENSURE STABILITY SERVICE
DELIVERY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THIS
SYSTEM ALLOWS US TO NOT ONLY.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE BUT ALSO TO DRIVE DOWN
BILLIONS OF FEDERAL DOLLARS
OKAY APPRECIATE THAT SENATE'SRECOGNITION OF THE CUMULATIVE
THE IMPACT OF ALL OF THE
PROPOSED. ON PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES ARENA RANGING
FROM MY AGE AT THAT- TO THE
PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF SEA
BASS SO THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK. NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EMMA
MOVEON TO MIND SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHT. I GET AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON AND I'M SURE MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE NAPA COUNTY
pBOARD OF SUPERVISORS I SPEAKING
ABOUT THE ACCESS YOUR APP ISSUE
MEDICATION PROVISIONS OF THE
BUDGET. BOTH OF THOSE COUNTIES
HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY TO THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE FOR
YEARS AND HAVE NEVER BEEN FOUND
AT FAULT FOR THE AUDIT
CONCLUSIONS THAT THEY MADE AND
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT AS
PART OF THE BUDGET AGREEMENT
THERE WOULD BE GUIDANCE GOING
FORWARD FOR THE CALCULATIONS
THAT THEY ARE BEING PUNISHED
FOR. OUR SOMEHOW INACCURATELY
CALCULATING THE ALLOCATIONS
WITH- GUIDANCE DOESN'T EXIST
YET SO WE ASK YOU TO HOLD ON AN
OPEN CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES AND COME TO A
CONCLUSION THAT EVERYBODY CAN
LIVE WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DIMITRIUS
SAUNDERS AND I'M A CLINICIAN
WITH THE PALAU OUTPATIENT
CLINIC AND I WANT TO GET-
EVERYTHING THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SAID AND I ALSO WNT TO
THANK THE- THE SENATORS ON THE
COMMITTEE TODAY FOR JUST TAKING
THE TIME OUT TO SPEAK WITH US
IN HERE ALL OF OUR BOARD I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THEM. AND
IF YOU GUYS HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO LOOK AT AND REVIEW EXACTLY
WHAT THE PAUL OUTPATIENT CLINIC
THE WITH THE CHRONICALLY
MENTALLY ILL. I WOULD JUST
BESEECH YOU TO DO THAT. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KEVIN CAN
EARN I'M A CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER IN THE PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M
JUST CALLING TO SAY THAT I AS
WELL A POLL OF THE CUTS TO THE
PAROLE OUTPATIENT CLINIC. WE
PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL AND
IRREPLACEABLE SERVICE TO
PAROLEES AND MH WE LOSE RELEASE
FROM PRISON TRANSITIONING TO
PAROLE THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS RECALL
MONSTER TO NOT- WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND- BOTH MY
COMMENTS ARE IN REFERENCE TO-
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEETO ON YOUR
AGENDA FIRST ITEM NINETEEN I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE REJECTION. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL TO
TERMINATE THE EXPANSION OF THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND AND
THE TRANSFER OF EIGHTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
BIODIVERSITY FONT APOTEX
CONSERVATION BOND IS ALL ABOUT
BIO DIVERSE THE JOB THERE'S
THREE MAIN OBJECTIVES ARE
HABITAT RESTORATION AND CANCEL
WILDLIFE ORDERS AND- HISTORY-
SECOND COMMENTED LIGHTING
TWENTY THREE. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR REJECTING THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD BE THE FIRST INVESTMENT
ESTABLISHES PROGRAM INCREASE
THE ABILITY OF UNDER CERTAIN AT
RISK POPULATION TO PARTICIPATE
NOW DOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION EXPERIENCES THAT THEY
PARKS AND OTHER PUBLIC LANDS
WHERE OUTDOOR EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TAKE PLACE. THIS IS
CORA MISSION I REALLY
APPRECIATE. WILL WORKING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ONE SEVEN
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO THIS
IS MAUREEN CAN ON BEHALF
MOVEMENT AND THEN FOR REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT LAND TRUST
THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS OF THE LAWS
AND BURKE BYRON FUND. I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THAT'S
RECOMMENDED REJECTION THE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN- REFLECTED IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO ISSUE.
I WOULD WOULD HOLD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THEY FIND FUNDING AND PROTECT
THE COUNTRY CONTINUED FUNDING
OF THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND AT. THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND AGAIN NINE
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. HI MY
NAME IS RAJ DYLAN MY LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER WITH THE
PROHIBITION CLINIC HERE KERN
COUNTY. NUMBERS COLLEGE FOR
BOYS BY STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE THE
PRO OPERATION CLINICS. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SAID WE ARE IN
THE CENTRAL SERVERS. WE HELP
BRIDGE THE GAP LEVELS- INMATES
WHO ARE PULLING AND RE ENTERING
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. AND MINE SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS FRANK MECCA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. LIKE TO
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH ALL THE
THANK THE SENATE COMMITTEE FOR
PRESERVING VITAL SAFETY NET
SERVICES AND I'D LIKE TO LINE
MY- SUPPORT FOR A REALIGNMENT
BACK STILL WITH MY OTHER COUNTY
COLLEAGUES. IN THE ABSENCE OF A
SUBSTANTIAL BACK STILL FOR
DECLINING REALIGNMENT REVENUES
COUNTY ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES THAN CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM. COULD BE
LOOKING AT A REDUCTION AND
PROTECTED SERVICE LEVELS. IN AN
AREA OF 3240% BECAUSE MUCH OF
WITH FUNDED BY REALIZED THAT.
OUR ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS THAT
AFFECTS. MANY THE PROGRAM AND-
REALIGNMENT ARE ARE. BUT JUST
DOUBLE TO SOME DEGREE OF WE
WOULD HAVE NO OPTION BUT TO
TAKE CUTS IN THE FINAL PROGRAM
WE ALSO- YOU TO THE LINK A
REALIGNMENT BACK THOUGH FUNDS
FROM THE FEDERAL- FUTURE
FEDERAL REVENUES BECAUSE
WITHOUT THE CERTAINTY OF THE
RECEIPT OF THE BOND. REDUCTION
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEGUN IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WILL CONTINUE TO
ACCELERATE THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES CONCERNING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION. DID OKAY ITEM
NINE UNDER SUB ONE THAT RELATED
TO EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS AND INSTRUCTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. ALSO DID TO THOSE
WHO SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF THE
REJECTION OF THE OLD STUFF CUTS
AND SHE KEY LASTLY WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOL
WHICH IS IN THE NAY REVISION
AND HAS PROVEN TO BE VERY
EFFECTIVE ACROSS THE COUNTY.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY ANGER I'M A FAILURE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS IN OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PLAN TO I'M
GOING WHICH REPLACEMENT IN THE
SEAT INITIATIVE WE SUPPORT
REJECTION ISSUE SEVEN FROM SUB
THREE SO LOW INCOME SENIORS CAN
OCCUR QUALITY HEALTHCARE. IS
SUPPORT REJECTING ISSUE FIFTY
FOUR AND SAID THREE TO PRESERVE
ACCESS TO COUNSEL FOR
IMMIGRANTS UNDERSERVED AREAS
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NINETEEN FROM SUB FOR TO CLOSE
THE GAP FOR CALIFORNIA WORKERS
THAT THEY CAN TAKE THE PAID
THESE. THAT THEY PAY FOR OUT OF
THEIR OWN PAYCHECKS AND WE
SUPPORT INCLUDING ALL AYE TEN
FILERS AND CALLIE A. I. T. C.
BUT ALSO SUPPORT REJECTING
ISSUE EIGHTEEN FROM SUB THREE
FOR HELP PREVENT THE CLOSURES
OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
CLINICS. WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ISSUE TWENTY
THREE FROM ABOUT FIVE TO RETAIN
FULL FUNDING FROM THE ADULT MAY
ENTER GRANT PROGRAM AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESS NOW TRAILER. BILL
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
ZERO NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS VICTOR PACHUCO I'M A
PSYCHOLOGIST THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL FACILITY IN VACAVILLE
I- REFER PEOPLE TO THE POLE
OUTPATIENT CLINIC I WOULD HATE
TO SEE IT GO AWAY THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS VIOLENT SEX
OFFENSES. AND CONDITIONS THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS SET UP TO HANDLE.
ALSO I'D LIKE TO MENTION- BEING
OPPOSED TO THE LOSS OF
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
THEY ARE SERVING A POPULATION
THAT HAS DIFFICULTY FINDING
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY. ARE
THERE ARE NO- ADOLESCENT
TREATMENT BEDS IN MY COMMUNITY
SANTA ROSA WE SHIP FROM- AS FAR
AS FRESNO SO THIS POPULATION
WILL NOT GET SERVICE LOCALLY
THEY HAVE FAILED OUT OF OCAL
PLACE WHEN. THEY FAILED OUT OF
JUVENILE HALL AND- THEY NEED
THE SERVICES. THANK YOU. FIND
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
FRIENDS GET COLLEGE. LIFE
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER- BUT THE
PRO OUTPATIENT CLINIC WITH CDC
ARE AND CAN BE A DON'T. AND I'M
SPEAKING ON THE ISSUE NUMBER
TEN THE CDC ARE I AM ASKING
THAT YOU OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF THE P. R. OF THE PLC PROGRAM.
I WANT TO PIGGY BACK ON MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENT AND ADD THAT
A NUMBER OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
PAROLEES ARE RELEASED FROM
STATE MENTAL HOSPITALS. LOOTING
NOT TO MENTION PATENT
ATASCADERO SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN NAPA. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY SERVICE CERTAIN
SERVICES ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO
MEET THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION. THEN YOU'D BE
ELIMINATED. THE BOC THE OUTCOME
COULD RESULT IN SEVERE A
AFFECTS. BOTH TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND FOR PATIENTS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. NINE SIX
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX
THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
SHERRY JONES I'M A CLINICIAN.
IN THE COLLABORATION CLINIC PSE
IMPENDING ACCOUNT. CALLING IN
REFERENCE TO SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
ITEM NUMBER TEN FOR CITYC. R.
AND ASK YOU TO POST ELIMINATION
YOU SEE. I SUPPORT ALL THE
PREVIOUS CALLERS REGARDING
OPPOSITION OF ELIMINATING PO
SEE. YOU SEE IS NOT REDUNDANT
AND IF IT'S BAD VITAL TO
SERVING A POPULATION THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDS RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE. WHENEVER I GET A
LIFE AFTER PRESIDENT. HE HAS A
FOR FORENSIC KNOWLEDGE AND
TRAINING TO WORK WITH A
SPECIFIC POPULATION. WE ON THE
FRONT LINES WE PROVIDE MUCH
MORE THAN MEDICATION THERAPY.
WE ALSO PROVIDE RISK ASSESSMENT
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED SERVICES
SUCH AS ASSISTING TO APPLY FOR
MEDI CAL AND APHRODITE. SO
DEFINED HOUSING A PENNY JOBS
MODEL DOCUMENTS. THAT CAN
SIMPLY BE TREATMENT CENTER AND-
AND WE DISCUSSED WITH THE
SUCCESSFUL COMMUNITY
REINTEGRATION AND WE BEGIN
PREPARING TREATMENT PLANTS
PRIOR TO RELEASE. SEVERAL
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS WILL NOT
SERVE THIS POPULATION. HEALTH
STABILIZED AND DUE TO THEIR
PROPENSITY FOR VIOLENCE. HE
WORKS WITH THIS POPULATION
REGARDLESS AND THAT'S WHAT
STABILIZATION FROM PRISON TO
THE COMMUNITY. SEVERAL
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS WILL NOT
SERVE THE POPULATION TELL THEY
ARE DESTROYED FROM GROW. ALL
WHICH LEAVE THEM UNSERVED
APPEAR TO GET ELIMINATED PLEASE
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE TO
CLOTHING TSTT OUTCOMES CAN
RESULT FOR. ADVERSE EFFECTS CAN
BE COSTLY TO THE COMMUNITY WITH
AN INCREASE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
WHEN CARS RATIONS FOR THE
CHRONIC. CENTER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THE NINE SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN LINE IS A- PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR KERR
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO THANK YOU
IN THE CANADIAN SCALPEL
PROPOSING A THOUGHTFUL BUDGET
THAT PROTECTS PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS BY
REACHING THE CRITICAL PROGRAMS
THAT KEEP THEM IN THEIR HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES AND IMPORTANTLY
SAFE. WHICH INCLUDE THE SEA
BASS MS US BE HSS EXERCISE MEDI
CAL SERVICES ALSO ENOUGH THANK
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE ON
GOING NEED FOR ASSURING THAT
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE PROTECTED
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN. AND NINE
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LESLIE ADULTS YES W.
E. R. COSTA MESA CLINIC LA
CENTRAL I COOL AGENT AN ADULT
INSTITUTION COMMISSION BECAUSE
ITEM AND THE CULTURE HERE WE DO
NOT THERE BUT I CALLED NEEDS
WITH PERSISTENT CHRONIC ILLNESS
AND ALREADY DISENFRANCHISED
KOLIJAN. OVERWHELMED MEDI CAL
PROVIDER. AND HOW STREAMLINED
WITH BUT OF THE PART OCT FROM
THAT BUT THE BIG TREAT TEAM.
ACCORDING TO GREET US CONDITION
LOCAL BUT YOU'RE NO GET IN
CONTACT MANDATORY BETTER
TREATMENT I'M HERE IN THE
TREATMENT WILL BE INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO MONITOR SHOULD BE
SERVICE SHOULD SERVICE. WILL BE
BY READY TO MEDICAL PROVIDER.
OUR GOAL IS WITH THE BEER
MENTAL ILLNESS ARE READY HAVE
LONG FRUSTRATED TOLERANCE AND
NEED EXTRA TIME FOR
INSTRUCTION. THERE WAS A ALL
MEANINGFUL CALL THESE PROVIDED
BY FEW THE COMMISSION COULD
MAKE THEMSELVES AVAILABLE IN
MUCH SHORTER TIME FRAME. WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDER PLEASE
RECONSIDER CULTURE. TIMOTHY AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. IN MY
SEVEN FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I'M GOING TO. THE FOR FEW
CALLER TO PLEASE BE COGNOS OF
THE TIME AND NOT TO BE DONE TO
IN YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
ELLIE MONTHS MORE- HERE
REPRESENTING YOU BASED ON THE
EIGHTH DAY WORKING PARTNERSHIP.
ON VALLEY COLLEGE ON THE
CENTRAL COAST LANE IN LOS
ANGELES WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESOURCE CENTER IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE- COURT IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE THOUGHT ON POLICY
INITIATIVES SAN DIEGO. TOGETHER
WHERE THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR WORKING
FAMILIES AND I'M HERE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE LETTER
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
THIRTEEN OTHER LEGISLATORS
THANK YOU SENATORS MAY BIND BUT
ALSO FOR YOUR SUPPORT. TO
PROVIDE WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT IN THE JUNE BUDGET
THE PROPOSED BUDGET COMMITTEE
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OF
THE PPO EIGHT WHICH MEANS THAT
THE ONE GROUP THAT WE STILL
NEED TO NOT LEAVE BEHIND IT THE
STATE. IS UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
POLITICAL. JUST CHECKING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NINE SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THE MOMENT
I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIGHT THE
GUERRERO REPRESENTED THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDED ACTION TO REJECT
THE REDUCTION IN. THE COMMITTEE
I- NUMBER ONE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AND TWELVE FOR CHILD
CARE RATE. SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE-
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAMS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AND
THIRTY NINE PER CHILD WELFARE
PROGRAMS YOU'RE NOT A NUMBER
FORTY TWO. WE APPRECIATE ON THE
RECOMMENDATION GIVE YOU HAVE
PROVIDED THERE AND ALSO
APPRECIATE- FOR PROJECT ONE KEY
THE ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND IN THE MY COMMENTS
WITH THE COOPERATION OF THE
PART OF HOUSING AND WITNESS
SHOWN REPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JACKIE
GONZALEZ IMMIGRANT DEFENSE
ADVOCATES COLLIE IN SUPPORT. OF
PARTIAL WEEK REPLACEMENT
PROGRAM FOR AND DOCUMENTED FOR
COURAGE EXTENSION OF CALATHEA
EIGHTY FEET ALL I TO FILERS AND
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL SENIORS. I
NEED WITH RESPECT TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GREAT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP COLLEEN STRONG
SUPPORT I'M THANKFUL FOR THE
ILL CHAMPIONING THIS REALLY
CRITICAL ASKED LAST YEAR AND-
FOR THE SENATE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT- TO REJECT THE
REPLICATION OF THAT PROGRAM.
PARTICULARLY AT A TIME WHEN THE
COLD AND THEN THE CONTENTS
ACTING UNDER RESOURCE REGION IT
WOULD BE DEVASTATING TO CUT
THIS PROGRAM IMMIGRATION
DETENTION AS A TO TRIPLE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
FAMILIES WILL BE TORN APART
DEEPLY AFFECTED AND WITHOUT
CRITICAL SERVICES IN THOSE
REGIONS WHICH ARE VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT TODAY OUR FAMILIES
WILL ONLY BE FURTHER IN
PACKAGE- FOR YOUR STRONG
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE I'M
LOOKING. FORWARD TO SEEING IT
TO THE FINAL BUDGET. AND NINE
SEVEN FIFTY YOUR IS OF PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM
CHAIR AND MY THIS IS DANNY AT
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE IN
LOS ANGELES. SO MANY ADVOCATES
HAVE ALREADY TRIED IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS THE INCLUDED IN
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY PLAN
ACCORDINGLY WE ASK THE SENATE
TO PRIORITIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COVERAGE PROPOSAL FOR PARTIAL
INCOME ASSISTANCE BUT EACH
WORKERS IN DAY JAILING BADGE.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO SENATORS DRUGS
THAT WERE LAID AFTER SUPPORTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLLEGE
PROPOSAL ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION AS CAL
YET YOU FEED YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
STATUS AS WELL AS THE INCLUSION
OF THE FEET INITIATE AN AGING
PROJECT. FINALLY WITH THE COURT
REJECTING ISSUE THREE IN FACT
MANY FOR DIVERTING THAT HARD TO
FIND A SIGN DEDICATED TO LOW
WAGE WORKERS TODAY GENERAL FINE
AS PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISED
IGNORES THE VERY REAL NEEDS OUR
STATE WORKFORCE. CALIFORNIAN
LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE MORE
VULNERABLE AND EXPLAIN WILL
THEN HAVE ARE USED FOR THEIR
THE PAGA FUND FOR USE BY THESE
WORKERS RATHER THAN LEARNING IT
OUT. TO THE GENERAL FUND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY SIX NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. YEAH MARC OPERATE ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
QUESTION EIGHT SENATE'S
REJECTION OF THE MERIT ASIAN
CUT TO ALL YEAH THAT NUMBER
ABOUT A CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS TO
COMPLIMENT YOU ON THE PROPOSED
A TRIGGER AND THAT CUTS TO
AVOID THAT- LASTLY I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SENATE ACTION ON ITEM NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER SIX NUMBER SEVEN
AND NUMBER NINE I'M TOLD SCHOOL
DISTRICT HARMLESS ON THE EIGHTY
EIGHT FUNDING FOR NEXT THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR. HOPING ANOTHER
DOCTOR CALLING OUT FOR THE
STATE CREATION OF A FORMULA TO
FIND. STUDENT DISABILITY THANK
YOU. AND OUR LAST COMMENT COME
FROM THE OF FOR. SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LOUISE
CAMINO AIM A SOCIAL WORKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORAL. REEF
AT ADAMS KERN COUNTY. AS MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES- DIMENSION I'M
CALLING TO- CAN IT- TO CLOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF THE CROW
LOCATION CLINIC- LIKE LIKE I
SAID MOST OF MY COLLEAGUES
READY MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS PROGRAM HOW CAN WE
UNIQUE WE ARE- WHAT KIND OF
SERVICES WE PROVIDE. AND AGAIN
I LIKE TO CLOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF THE COLLABORATION CLINIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH TWO
MORE IN CUTE IF WE'RE AVAILABLE
YES PLEASE I WAS JUST GOING TO
ASK YOU TO SEE IF THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC YES THANK YOU MODERATE
HERE. THANK YOU. AND IF YOU DO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL TAKE THE LINE
OF FIVE EIGHTY. I'M SORRY NINE
FIVE EIGHTY NINE IF YOU COULD.
THERE YOU ARE OF. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE NO I BOTTOM
ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE ON
BEHALF OF OUR FARMWORKERS
CONSTITUENTS SUPPORTING THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
POLITICAL MEDI CAL UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS IMMEDIATELY. OF
INCLUSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM. AND URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE ALL
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS IN THE
CATHOLIC YOU SEE. YEAH BUT SEE
PROGRAMS AND THE STATE BUDGET
WE SUPPORT. AND YEARLY ALSO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FOR WEEKLY
INCME REPLACEMENT FOR AREN'T
FUNDS ARE DOCUMENTED WORKERS.
AND USING THE PARK UP ON TO
PROTECT OUR WORKERS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU LISTEN TO OUR
COMMON CLICKS ALSO MADE A
COMMENT. TO THE PORTAL ONLINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
EVENING. IN LINE FIVE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO TERRY CARTER THIS
IS MY TEETH AND SAID THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY INSTITUTION I WE ARE
QUICKLY APPROACH. TO COMMITTEE
THE CRIB ALL AND ISSUE THREE
ARE WHICH REQUIRED. TO CONDUCT
IT WILL MAKING OUR CAP TO TRADE
WITH A CRAFTSMAN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
THE RECOMMENDATION AT THAT
INTERFERES WITH THE MARKET AT A
TIME WHEN IT IS ALREADY IN
STUDY. THAT WERE IN THE MIDST
OF AN ECONOMIC RECESSION IF THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO DO IT IS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE PROCESS AND
NOT THE BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NINE SIX TWELVE YOUR MIND
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEDICARE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE ON A
HEALTHCARE AND SUBSIDIARY
PREMIERE HEALTHCARE WE SUPPORT
THE SENATE'S PROPOSED ACTION
RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX. AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO REJECT THE MAY
REVISE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TRIGGER
CUTS ESPECIALLY THE CUTS TO
RUNNING THE SERVICES OF THESE
SERVICES ARE ALREADY OPERATE ON
A VERY NARROW MARGIN. BARELY
COVERING MINIMUM WAGE COSTS
THESE COSTS WOULD MEAN RATES
ARE SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER THAN
MINIMUM WAGE LEADING TO REAL
CUTS IN HOURS OF SERVICE AS
WELL AS JOHN. BOTH OF WHICH
WILL EXACERBATE OUR ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES THANK YOU. TEN NINE
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BEVERLY ON
A PSYCHOLOGIST WORKING WITH
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THE
CLOSURE DJJ WITHOUT ME JJ THE
DENSEST POPULATION OF VIOLENT
AND MENTALLY ILL KIDS WILL BE
SENT TO PRISON. DJJ CONTRIBUTE
THE PUBLIC SAFETY BY REDUCING
RECIDIVISM ESPECIALLY SEX
OFFENDERS COULD BE DONE WHICH
IS GREAT THE COMMUNITY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS YOU OFFER COST
EFFECTIVENESS FOR THE MOST
ROBUST TREATMENT PROGRAM. FOR
JUVENILE OFFENDERS AND WE ARE
NOT. A DUPLICATE OF COUNTY
PROGRAM. WHAT IT DOES HAPPEN TO
CRUNCH MANY HALL ARE COSTING
THREE HUNDRED TO. HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER USER PER YEAR
MAKING DJJ NOT COST EFFECTIVE
CHOICE. DJJ OFFERS FULL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR SEX
OFFENDERS MENTAL HEALTH IN
PATIENTS IN COMPLEX TRAUMA
PROVIDER. WHERE COUNTY JUVENILE
HALL WITH ONLY A FEW YOU CANNOT
OFFER THERE. PLEASE SEEK
ALTERNATIVES TO DJJ CLOSURE
THANK YOU. TEN NINE TO SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU FOR CHECKING TO
SEE IF THERE WAS ANYBODY LEFT
HERE GOOD AFTERNOON I NEED TO
DO ANY OP COAST ON THE
CONSTITUENTS. SENATOR STERN'S
DISTRICT AND I'M ASKING THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. ACTED BY
CULTURES NINETEEN IN THE JUNE
BUDGET. I'M THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY ACCREDITED
LEGAL REPRESENTATIVE FROM MY
**** TECH- INDEED HE NOT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT
FOR TWENTY YEARS MY CAUCUS
SUPPORTED ORGANIZED AND
EMPOWER. THE INDIGENOUS
MARGARET COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST.
CHECK ME OFF ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
INCLUDING A BY TIM FILERS AND
CALIFORNIA INCOME EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT AND INCLUSION OF THE
STATE INITIATIVE. THANK YOU.
AND NINE SEVEN FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS DOCTOR JEAN MARIE
MITCHELL I'M A PSYCHOLOGIST
WHICH A DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE I WANT TO TAKE IN THE
INFORMATION GIVEN BY DOCTOR
LEON AND PICKED UP THE CHECK-
AYE OPPOSED THE CLOSING OF DJJ
WE OFFER A CENTRAL SERVICES. TO
THE STATE MOST DIFFICULT TO
TREAT POPULATIONS AND YOU GET
THE KIDS TO THE COUNTY CAN'T
TREAT SO WHAT WE DO IS
ESSENTIAL ALSO THERE ARE FIRE
CAN'T THAT WE PROVIDE NEWS. AND
THEY GET TRAINING THEY LEAVE JJ
WITH SKILL THAT THEY CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
DJJ IS AN ESSENTIAL SERVICE AND
I URGE YOU. TO NOT. THANK YOU.
AND NINE SEVEN FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT COULD BE BECAUSE OF KEVIN
ABSOLUTELY AND I'M CALLING
FROM. CALIFORNIA WHAT THE RIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS. URGING THE
COMMITTEE TOOL SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE COMMITTEE COULD NOT. THE
SIXTY BUT THE VISION MORE WORK
WHICH BOTH. YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SIX MONTHS CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE THRILLED STATE.
COUNTRY THAT LIMITED TO FORTY
MONTHS FOR CALIFORNIA HI
LIMITS. IT ALSO WOULD FIZZLE
PANDEMIC A WHOLE BUNCH OF
LITTLE BIT BARBARA COMMENT.
HAVE TIME DEL IN THERE WOULD
NEED ONE YEAR OF ADDITIONAL
TIME TO MAKE WILL GO BACK TO
WORK. STRONG THERE IS A
COMMITTED TO ADOPT THE SIXTY
MONTHS. WILL SIX MONTH TIME TO
BID FOR POWER THANK YOU. AND
NINE SIX TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
EDWARD LITTLE AND I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA'S YOUR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SHOWN FIVE. ISSUE TWENTY
APARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AUTOMATICALLY LEAD AB TEN
SEVENTY SIX. WE HAVE TO
DISAPPEAR ABOUT THE NAY WOULD
GET YOU THANK YOU. AND NINE
SEVEN THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS MOVE THAT YEAH WELL
FROM- SO THEY CAN LEGAL CENTER
NONPROFIT OUT IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE COACHELLA VALLEY WE ARE
CALLING. TO URGE. OUR COMMITTEE
WE SUPPORT- I OF THE EXPANSION
ABOUT EIGHTY FEET QUICKLY I
CAN. HOLDERS ARE AND THAT IS
OUR COMMUNITY. THE A LOT OF.
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS OUR
DOCUMENT COMMUNITY ARE
IMMIGRANTS BUT WE'RE AT WORK
URGING- THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT ALSO THANK YOU FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIANS AND WE ALSO- GENE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ON HEALTH
WELL ELDERS. AS WE ARE NOT VERY
PORTABLE STAGE I WE HAVE. HAD A
LOT OF. MEMBERS THAT HAVE
PASSED AWAY AND- THIS IS A VERY
PERSONAL SO WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE SUPPORT ALL
THESE MEASURES THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR THE LAST FIVE CALLERS
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO FOR
THIRTY SECONDS THIRTY SECONDS
PLEASE THANK YOU. AND NINE
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M CARE MEMBER THANK YOU
THIS IS TREAT ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARK AND UCBCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION WE
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK AND
LEADERSHIP SENATE INCLUDING FOR
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT SEEKS
TO AVOID DEEP CUTS THE CRITICAL
SERVICES. AND SUPPORT FOR
PEOPLE OF INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE WILL
COMMIT WRITTEN COMMENT THAT
THERE ARE SPECIFIC TO. THE AREA
IN WHICH WE SUPPORT BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SAY- WE CREATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO OUR
COMMUNITY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON A TOUGH
BUDGET ISSUES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOUNG. AND SEVEN
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I'M SURE
MEMBERS INJURY ANTS WE WOULD
SHOW YOUR HAND WHICH WALDRON
LYING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
WELL WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT. FOR THE STAFF PROPOSAL
TO AUGMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED LANGUAGE AND BUDGETING
ON PROJECT ROOM KEY. AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
GENERAL FUND WE EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT. AND NINE SIX
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YEAH THIS
IS MICROBES AND ON BEHALF OF
THE GLASS PACKAGING SHOULD
SHOULDN'T WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IT WAS
ADDED BY SUB TO REQUIRE CARBON
OPEN A LITTLE MAKING ON CAP AND
TRADE. GLASS ACTUALLY USED TO
BE AN ISSUE WORKFORCE
SUPPORTED- THEN WE
AUTHORIZATION CAP AND TRADE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. HAD
PROTECTIONS FOR JOBS IN
MANUFACTURING IN CALIFORNIA IN
THIS PROPOSAL UNDERMINES. THAT
GET BUT WAS VERY PROTECTIONS.
AND SO WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL AND MOVED
TO A POLICY COMMITTEE WHERE IT
BELONGS THANK YOU. AND NINE SIX
OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI HI THANK YOU
THIS IS KATHY VAN NOT STAND
REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU. AND I'M
WANTING TO COMMENT ON THREE
ITEMS TODAY FIRST VITAMINS-
UNDER SUB ONE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION- ABOUT. REJECTS
THE ADMINISTRATION BUYER TO
BRING DIRECT CATEGORICAL FIND
OUT FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. REGULAR EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND FROM THE NEXT UP
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES CRITICAL
ON CAMPUS. FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
FORMER FOSTER YOU NUMBER Q.
UNDER SUB AYE AYES SECURITY
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY TWO-
TRADITIONAL HELPING- PROGRAM-
AGAIN FOR SOFTER YOU WE SUPPORT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION- THAT-
OPPOSED. ABUSING OUTGOING
FUNDING ABOUT YOURS. IT'S VERY
HIGHLY PROGRAM LASTLY WE- UNDER
DISCUSSION ITEM NUMBER FOUR ON
HOMELESSNESS- WE JUST WANT TO
REMIND STATE AND URGE YOU TO
ANSWER ABOUT CAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT HOMELESSNESS FUNDING THAT
YOU. ARE SET ASIDE FOR YOU THE
DIFFERENT POPULATION THEY ARE
NOT CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE AT LEAST A 10%
CERTIFIED- IF YOU CAN SET ASIDE
NO WAY OUT BUDGET YEARS THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION. AND
THERE ARE NO FOR COMMENTS IN
MONEY COMING Q. MODERATOR WE'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HELPING US MANAGE- THREE HOURS
OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN. A BASED
ON MY BACK OF THE NECK IN MATH
OVER OE HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO PROVIDED TESTIMONY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME WE
DID HAVE ONE LAST PARTY A QUEUE
UP FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM ONE
ASK PARTY THIRTY SECOND SET
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND YOUR LINE IS A-
WELL I ALWAYS. DID TALK TO
YESTERDAY **** AND GOT
DISCONNECTED AND FOR THE SENATE
COM AT LEAST MORE REVENUE FOR
THE SENATE. RECEIVE YOUR THIS
WITH EIGHTEEN T. HELLO BEING
BILLED SO YOU GOT A HUNDRED
COMMENTS THAT WERE A LOT MORE
OUT THERE THAT COULD NOT GET IN.
THE LAST COMMENT I WILL MAKE.
OR JUST YOU. I'M IN THE FUTURE
GET A JUMP START AGAIN. THERE
IS OLDER WHICH ORDER. AND I'M
HOPING YOU MORE REVENUE
STARTING WITH THE SCHOOLS. ON
THE BALLOT THANK YOU. AND
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE COMMON AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
WE APPRECIATE THAT. WICKS THANK
YOU. HAVING HEARD FROM THE
PUBLIC WE WILL NEXT MOVES
PROCEED TO VOTING. GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF ISSUES WE HAVE ON
TODAY'S AGENDA I'D LIKE TO NOTE
THAT ALL ACTIONS ARE SUBJECT TO
RECONCILIATION WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF TO ENSURE INTENT OF
COMMITTEE ACTIONS ARE
ACCURATELY REFLECTED. SO
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH. THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS. WE
HAVE A STAFF HAVE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION. AND THERE ARE
SOME ITEMS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ASKED
LET ME JUST TRY TO GET MYSELF
IN ALL OF THIS PAPER ORGANIZED
ROOM. ALL THE ALL THE ICE. SO
WE'RE STARTING WITH
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE. ISSUE ONE.
WE'RE GOING TO ENTERTAIN ON AND
TAKE TO VOTE MR MORALE- YOU
WANTED TO MAKE A MOTION WANTED
TO- MAKE THAT FORMAL MOTION NOW
WILL TAKE DEVELOPMENT WILL
GOING TO THE SECOND MOST. OKAY
YES I MAKE A MOTION ON
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ISSUE ONE. ARM
TO SUPPORT THE BLOCK GRANT. NOW
HELLO OKAY THE BOX SAY THAT
AGAIN ORDERS YEAH FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS OKAY LET ME READ WRITE
A RIGHT RIGHT THIS IS A HOLES
ALL EXCLUDES THE NON CLASSROOM-
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS I MOVED
TO A MAN TO ALLOW THOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
FUNDING SIMILAR TO THE OTHER
SCHOOL BASED ON. OUR ONE ON OUR
PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS OKAY THANK
YOU- IS THERE ONE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT MOTION WAS THE MORALE IS
MAKING. AND AGAIN THAT THEY'LL
BE A SECOND MOTION FOR A SECOND
VOTE OKAY SO- IS THERE A SECOND.
IT'S A SECOND ALL AND DO I GET
FIFTY ROLL CALL SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
SERVICE CENTERS MITCHELL NOW
NIELSEN. HI INTO YOUR MIKE
THIRTY WE CAN BE AVOIDED THE
JIM NIELSEN. HI DAWALY ASKING
THE QUESTION IS FOR THE
AMENDMENT THIS IS FOR THE
MINUTE CRACKED IT'S A THE
MOTION THAT HE JUST MADE THANK
YOU. FOR THIS SERVICE HE IS
EVERYONE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT'S ON
THE TABLE YES THE FORMS MISTER
SECRETARY WE START THE ROLL
CALL OVER PLEASE. CENTERS
MITCHELL NO NIELSEN. HI.
COPYRIGHT AND I KNOW. NO THIS
IS TOM HI I THE RAZA DEL
TRATADO. NOW MY LEYVA NO WIRE.
PEOPLE IN THIS HI. MONNING NO
MORE LOCKED HI. MORALE HI AND.
ROTH NO NO NO HAN KNOWN IN YOUR-
ROCK. SKINNER BY THIRD NO. IN
THE NARROW. STERN NO THIS IS
OURS BY CASKEY NOW. WE HAVE A
KNOWINGLY MEN WILL BE MEN
MILLION. YEAH THE MAN. WAS IT
WAS CERTIFIED COPIES VOTE
RECORDED I'M SORRY. HE DIDN'T.
YES WE KNOW CONSIDER WHAT
CAUSES THE NO. BUSH THIS WEEK
AB YES. SO THE SALES WAS THE
WAY TO GO AROUND. YEAH YEAH YES
SEVEN. A MAJORITY PRESS ONE.
I'M SORRY DID YOU COMPLETE ROLL
CALL. IT TOO I THOUGHT THE
VOCALIS. HI FIVE KNOWS TWELVE.
FIVE FIVE NO SWELLED THE MOTION
FAILS. CONTINUING ON WITH-
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THE RECOMMENDATION IS THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION AGAIN THIS
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS OF SCHOOL
RE OPENING SUPPORT BLOCK GRANT
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT PROPOSAL
IN PLACE FULLER CHILL BIT BILL
LANGUAGE I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION REMOVED. THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTERS
MITCHELL FIVE NIELSEN NO. WELL
I COVER GIRL HI. DOLLY NO THE
RAZA. FURTADO I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NOW MONNING
I MORE LIKE BILL MORALE NO PAN
HI ALL RIGHT INNER. HI STERN HI
MY COUNTY HI. A ONE ISSUE DOWN.
FIVE THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE THE
MOTION CARRIES COLLEAGUES. SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED
REMEMBER ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR THAT SOME OF THE BOTH
BE PULLED OFF FOR SPLIT AND SO
I'M GOING TO GROUP THE VOTE- IN
ACCORDANCE TO OUR AGREEMENT IN
TERMS OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH IN TERMS OF
SUPPORTING THE STAFF ACTION I
WILL READ THE ISSUE NUMBER AND
THE ISSUE SO EVERYONE IS CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE VOTING ON
WHAT THEY'RE VOTING AGAINST
OKAY. SO I'M GONNA ENTERTAIN- A
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. TO ACCEPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
NEXT THE FOLLOWING ITEMS. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. OPPORTUNITY GRANT
PROGRAM ISSUE NUMBER THREE
ADULTS IN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
LOAN TO THE GENERAL FUND. ISSUE
NUMBERS SEVEN THROUGH FOURTEEN.
WHICH INCLUDE IF SURPLUS
PROPERTY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TERRITORY%
TRANSFERS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE HOLD
HARMLESS AN INSTRUCTION
REQUIREMENTS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM. ISSUE
ELEVEN CHILDCARE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE REDUCTION DOCTOR
BASED PROGRAM ISSUE TWELVE
CHILD CARE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REDUCTION
ISSUE THIRTEEN CHILD CARE
PROGRAM SAVINGS AND ISSUE
FOURTEEN EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS. SOME OF
THEM NOW FOR ISSUES EIGHT.
THREE TWENTY FIVE. YOU SEE
MERCED UC SAN FRANCISCO FRESNO
BRANCH. UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE YOU SEE BASS REDUCTION
IS ADAMANT TWENTY ONE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUE TWENTY TWO
YOU SEE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
HALF THE UC DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES
FOR TWENTY THREE HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW ISSUE TWENTY
FOUR SEE IF YOU BASS REDUCTION
IN ISSUE TWENTY FIVE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. I'M ALSO GOING TO
ACCEPT A PROPOSED APPROVAL OF
ACCEPTANCE OF STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR ITEMS TWENTY
SEVEN THROUGH THIRTY THREE. AND
THAT IS ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
FACILITIES REAPPROPRIATION.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT CATEGORICAL TWENTY NINE
CAL BREAK COLLEGE. THIRTY WORK
BASED LEARNING ISSUE THIRTY ONE
FIFTY THREE THE PEARLS ISSUE
THIRTY TWO S. C. F. F. RATES
CALCULATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND IF YOU THIRTY
THREE S. C. F. F. HOLD
HARMLESS. I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THOSE ITEMS
REMOVED SO MOVED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
ALL RIGHT. BELL YES CABALLERO
HI. DOLLY HI THE RAZA I TITLE.
I LEYVA HI WIRE HI. MELENDEZ HI.
MONNING THANK MORE LOCK HI
MORRELL HI. IN HIGH ROTH IRA
SKINNER I STERN HI BY CASKEY I.
I'D EIGHTEEN KNOWS ZERO THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ACCEPTED ON NOW SO YOU SAW THAT
THERE WERE SOME ISSUES THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THAT BOLTS
ARE NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH-
FOR ISSUES FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN. STARTING ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE AGENDA. PAGE
FIFTEEN DREAMER SERVICE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM SIXTEEN
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION AND ITEM
SEVENTEEN THE CALIFORNIA KIDS
INVESTMENT DEVELOPMENT SAVINGS
PROGRAM STATEWIDE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT PROGRAM I'LL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION WELL. IT'S BEEN
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
NO BELL I. CABALLERO HI. DOLLY
NO THE RAZA. HER TITLE I LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ NOW
MONNING HI. WARLOCK NO MORRELL
NOPE PAN HI RAW HI. SKINNER HI
STERN HI WHY CASKEY BY. FIVE
THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE FIVE
THIRTEEN OH FIVE THE. THE
EFFORT GOES OUR RECORD IN
MOVING ON TO TWO ADDITIONAL
ISSUES ISSUES SIX. WELL ISSUE
SIX WHICH IS THE ACCESS
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ADOPT A PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SO MOVED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTERS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI BELL.
CABALLERO HI DOLLY HI DORADO.
FURTADO HI LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ NOW I VERY. MONNING HI
MORE LOCK HI MORALE HI IN HI
ROTH AYE SKINNER BY STERN. LIKE
OWSKI NO. HI THIS FIFTEEN KNOWS
THREE. I HEARD THE CITY A
SENATOR MELENDEZ WAS A NO THEN
SHE CHAIN SO IT IS. YEAH
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I ONLY HEARD
TO NILES I THOUGHT I HEARD BAIL
IN MY COUNTY SHE DID SAY NO
FIRST AND SHE CHANGED IT WAS.
HIGHS I LOOKED AT THE WRONG
NUMBER HI SIXTEEN KNOWS TOO YES
THANK YOU. AS. THE MEASURE
KERRY'S WE ARE ACCEPTING STAFF
RECOMMENDATION OF FINAL ISSUE
FOR VOTE ONLY UNDER
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE COLLEAGUES IS
ISSUE TWENTY SIX PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE FAIR PAY TO
PLAY AT HER. SB TWO OH SIX
CHAPTER BILL FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ACCEPT STAFF RECCO SO MOVED
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE CENTERS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN
LOW BELL HI. BILL I. CARRIER BY.
DOLLY NO A RAZA. HER TITLE HI
LEYVA I WIRE HI MELENDEZ. I.
MINING HI. MORE LOCK NO THE
MORALE EL. PAN HI ROTH HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI MY COUNTY
HI. FIVE FOURTEEN KNOWS FOR.
HIGHS FORTINOS FOR THE MEASURE
KERRY'S I'M GOING TO ASK ALL
THE MEMBERS IT'S ALREADY HARD
ENOUGH IN OUR MASTER PLEASE
RAISE YOUR MIKES AND SPEAK
DIRECTLY INTO THE MASK BECAUSE
OF SAFF WAS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER TRYING TO CALCULATE THE
VOTE. HANG ON ONE SECOND.
COLLEAGUES IT DOES ANYBODY
REMEMBER US DOING ISSUE FOR.
ISSUE FOR IS- PRIOR EARLIER
LOOK PRIOR YEAR LOAN PAYMENT
ADJUSTMENTS. HEY MAJORITY WINS
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR PRIOR YEAR
LOAN PAYMENT ADJUSTMENTS ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ACCEPT-
STAFF RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS
TO ADOPT MAY REVISION PROPOSAL.
FOR RICHARD ROTH THANK YOU
SENATOR ROUTE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CENTERS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN BILL. MEL CABALLERO HI.
DOLLY. THE RAZA. HER TIED UP I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI. MELENDEZ.
MORNING HI. MORE LOCK NO.
MORALE NO. PAN HI ROTH AYE
SKINNER BY STERN HI I COUNTY HI.
FIVE THIRTEEN KNOWS THREE. THE
MOTION CARRIES COLLEAGUES WERE
NOT GONNA MOVE ON TO SUB
COMMITTEE TO WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE. SEVERAL VOTE. ONE I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR A MOTION. IN
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES THREE OR SIX
ONE FOUR. EARLY. AGAIN SUB TO
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ACCEPT. STACK ROCKS SEPARATE
EMENDATIONS FOR ISSUE THREE.
WITHDRAWAL OF FUNDING FOR SH
FOR STREAM GAVE PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION SB NINETEEN
ISSUE FOR A REVERSION OF
LEGISLATION INVESTMENTS ISSUE
SIX WITHDRAW FUNDING FOR
WILDFIRE FORECAST AND THREAT
INTELLIGENCE INTEGRATION CENTER
ISSUE TWELVE. WITHDRAWAL OF
STREAMLINED TEMPORARY PERMIT
TEMPORARY CHANGE ORDER WATER
PERMITTING FOR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY IMPLEMENTATION
A. B. SIX FIVE EIGHT ISSUE
THIRTEEN WITHDRAWAL OF CAMPFIRE
SYSTEMS ACTIVE TWENTY NINETEEN
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB THIRTY. IF
YOU THIRTY. WITHDRAW WILDFIRE
SMOKE CLEAN AIR SHELTERS FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
INCENTIVE PILOT PROGRAM A. B.
EIGHT THIRTY SIX ISSUE THIRTY
TO WITHDRAW FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH FISH AND SHELLFISH
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVISORIES AB
SEVEN SIX TWO ISSUE THIRTY
THREE WITHDRAW BUSINESS
LICENSES STORM WATER DISCHARGE
COMPLIANCE ISSUE THIRTY FIX
WITH DROPPED TWENTY FOR ON SITE
WATER WASTEWATER TREATMENT
SYSTEMS PROHIBIT COMING UP
PROHIBITED CHEMICALS SB THREE
SEVENTEEN. ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN.
WITHDRAW FUNDING FROM UPSTATE
UNIFORM STATEWIDE CRITERIA FOR
NON POSSIBLE RECYCLED WATER USE
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY ISSUE THIRTY.
GIVE ME ISSUE FORTY. CLIMATE
CATALYST REVOLVING LOAN FUND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ISSUE
FORTY ONE WILDFIRE FORECASTS
AND THREAT INTELLIGENCE
INTEGRATION CENTER SB TWO OWN
NINE ISSUE FORTY TWO GENERAL
FUND LOANS ISSUES FORTY FIX
BROUGH FORTY EIGHT WHAT CHART
WILDFIRE PROPOSALS TELL SPEED
TESTING END E. CIGARETTE
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE FIFTY ONE
THROUGH FIFTY THREE. WHICH ARE.
LOCAL AIRPORT LOAN ACCOUNT
TRANSFER TO STATE ON THE
ADDICTS ACCOUNT. THIRTY FOR
CITY TFA TO COLLECT FUEL SALES
TAX THAT UP FROM THE AIRPORT.
AARON CONFIRM EDT ACCESS TO DMB
PERSONNEL INFORMATION RECORDS I
WILL ACCEPT A MOTION MOVESET
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IT'S BEEN
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN I.
WELL CABALLERO HI DOLLY HI
DORADO TADO BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ HI MONNING
I MORE LOCK RIGHT. MORALE HI
PAN HI ROTH HI SKINNER AYE
STERN HI BY CASKEY HI. HIGHS
EIGHTEEN KNOWS ZERO. TO CALL
THE BOOK FOR ME PLEASE.
EIGHTEEN NO ZERO. FIVE EIGHTEEN
NO ZERO STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
CONCURRED IN FOR ALL THOSE
MEASURES COLLEAGUES MOVING ON.
TO ISSUE TEN WITHDRAWAL OF
WITHDRAWAL OF REPELS WATER
TRANSFERS FROM GROUND WATER
BASIS UNDERLYING DOES IT LANDS
AS REAL SEVEN. ISSUE FOURTEEN
OF ALL OF STATE WIDE BOBCAT
MANAGEMENT AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR.
ISSUE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
ISSUE TWENTY TWO. WITHDRAWAL OF
STATE BEACHES AND PARKS SMOKING
BAN SB EIGHT. ISSUE TWENTY
EIGHT. WITHDRAW SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT AUDIT AB FOR TWENTY
THREE ISSUE TWENTY NINE
WITHDRAW HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INSPECTION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM SB TWO TEN. ISSUES
FORTY THREE THROUGH FORTY FIVE
AS A RACER ISN'T WORKING. HE'S
HE LASHES. ABOUT A LOAN FROM
HIGH COST FUND BEADED GENERAL
FUND. LOANS FROM UNIVERSAL
LIFELINE SERVICE TRUST FUND TO
GENERAL FUND AND LOAN FROM
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
TWENTY ITEM FORTY NINE
REVERSION OF LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES AND ITEM FIFTY.
TRANSPORTATION LOANS AND
TRANSFER ALL EXCEPT A MOTION TO
ACCEPT STAFF RECOMMENDATION SO
MOVED THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CENTERS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN NO. BELL RIGHT. ZERO HI
DOLLY NO THE RAZA FOR TITLE I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
NOW. MONNING I MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO IN HIGH OFF HI
SKINNER FIVE STERN HI MY COUNTY
HI. PRICE THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE CONCURRED
IN. ONCE AGAIN COLLEAGUES A
SERIES OF. ITEMS THAT I'LL READ
THAT OUT THERE ARE TEN A MOTION
TO ACCEPT STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
ISSUE ONE REVERSION OF
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS ISSUE
TOO CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER
VERSION OF LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENT ISSUE NINE REVERSION
OF LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENT ISSUE
SEVENTEEN. OTHER MODIFICATION
THE DANCING BIODIVERSITY
PROTECTION OPERATIONAL
MODERNIZATION REGULATORY
EFFICIENCIES ISSUE EIGHTEEN
BASS LINE FINALLY REDUCTION
ISSUE NINETEEN TRANSFER FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION FUND
PER SPENDING PER PENDING
LEGISLATION IF YOU TWENTY.
FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
LITIGATION ATTORNEYS FEES ISSUE
TWENTY ONE REVERSION OF TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENTS ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
RESTORATION TRIGGERS RELATED TO
FEDERAL FUNDS ISSUE TWENTY SIX
VERSION OF LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS ISSUE
THIRTY ONE VERSION OF
THIRTY EIGHT. WE'RE VERSION OF
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS IN
ISSUE THIRTY NINE REDUCTION OF
CALIFORNIA BIODIVERSITY
INITIATIVE I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT STAFF RECCO SO
MOVED THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN ABSTAINED. BELL. BILL
BILL I CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
TORONTO HE- TITLE I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI IN DEATH- MONNING
NINE THE SHOOT. MORE LOCK. THIS
PHONE BASS MORALE. PAN HI RAW
HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI. PRICE THIRTEEN. NO
ZERO THANK YOU. THE MEASURE IF
KERRY IN TERMS OF- SUPPORT A
SEPARATE IMITATION COLLEAGUES
THE NEXT ISSUES WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE INDIVIDUAL ROLE ON THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES ISSUES
578-111-5162. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR AND THIRTY FIVE.
INDIVIDUAL MOTIONS ON ALL OF
THOSE ITEMS ISSUE FIVE IS
WITHDRAW FUNDING FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION SB FIVE FORTY TWO
MODIFICATION OF INCREASE
WORKERS COMPENSATION COSTS
UNLIMITED A MOTION TO ACCEPT A
MEMBER ECHO SO MOVED ALL THE
ROLE. CENTERS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN I. BELL LIKE AB HERO HI
DOLLY. THE RAZA. FOR TITLE HI
LEYVA HI FIRE AT MELENDEZ I
MONNING NINE MORE LOCK. MORALE
HI PM HI ROCK HI SKINNER HIRING
STERN BY WHY COUNTY HI. HI
SIXTEEN NO ZERO. THANK YOU
MEASURE KERRY'S- ISSUES SEVEN
WITHDRAW FUNDING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE OF DEADLY FORCE
POLICY IN TRAINING UPDATE SB
TWO THIRTY AB THREE NINETY TWO
ALERTED EMOTIONS SO MOVED CALL
THE ROLL. CENTERS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN I WELL I ZERO HI DOLLY
HI THE RAZA. FOR TITLE HI LEYVA
HI FIRE ALL RIGHT MELENDEZ.
MONNING I. MORE LOT RIGHT
MORALE. PAN HI ROTH AYE SKINNER.
STERN HI MY COUNTY HI. HI
SIXTEEN NO ZERO STAFF RECCO
KERRY'S ITEM EIGHT MODIFICATION
WILDFIRE MITIGATION FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PILOT PROGRAM AND
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AB THIRTY
EIGHT UNLIMITED HIM ALSO MOVED.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. CENTERS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI BELL
RIGHT. CABALLERO HI DOLLY BY
THE RAZA HI FOR CALLING HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY MELENDEZ I
MONNING I MORE LOCK RIGHT.
MORRELL HI PAN HI ROTH HI
SKINNER. STERN I. BY CASKEY HI.
HI EIGHTEEN NO ZERO. WHICH
THANK YOU MEASURE KERRY'S STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS- CARE IF ITEM
ELEVEN WITHDRAWAL FRESH WATER
IN AND. AND OTHER HARMFUL ALL
GAIL BLOOM PROGRAM EMILY THIRTY
FOUR. SOME MONETARY MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
SO MOVED THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN HI. WELL CABALLERO HI
DOLLY. THE RAZA HI RICARDO HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE ACT MELENDEZ
I MONNING I MORE LOCK HIGH
MORALE HIGH. IN HIGH ALL HI
SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY COUNTY
HI. I SEVENTEEN NO ZERO.
RECOMMENDATION IS ACCEPTED
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN WITHDRAWAL OF STEAM
GAGGING PLAN SB NINETEEN
UNLIMITED EMOTION SO MOVED
THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL CENTERS
MITCHELL I. NIELSEN NO BELL I.
CABALLERO I DOLLY BY THE RAZA.
TADO HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ HI MONNING HI MORE
LOCK HI MORALE HI PAN HI ROTH
HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI. PRICE SEVENTEEN
KNOWS ONE THANK YOU MOTION
CARRIES MOVING ON TO ITEM
SIXTEEN WITHDRAWAL OF LONG
COURSE FOR USE OF DEADLY FORCE
POLICY INTRIGUING UPDATE AB
THREE NINE TWO SB TWO THIRTY
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION SO
MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN NO
WELL ALL RIGHT. CABALLERO HI
DOLLY NO THE RAZA I THE TITLE I.
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
MINING I. MORE LARGE. MORALE NO.
PAN HI. ROTH AYE SKINNER. FIVE
STERN HI LIKE ASKING HI. PRICE
THIRTEEN NOES THREE THANK YOU
THE MOTION CARRIES ON ITEM
TWENTY THREE WITHDRAWAL OF
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
GRANT PROGRAM A. B. TWO OH NINE
A LIMITED EMOTIONS SO MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER IS
MITCHELL. EXCUSE E I NIELSEN
HI WELL. CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
THE RAZA. HER TITLE HI LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ NOW.
MONNING HI. MORE LOCK. MORALE
NO. PAN HI RALPH HI SKINNER. I
STERN HI MY COUNTY I. HIGHS
FOURTEEN. KNOWS TO I FORTY
KNOWS TO THE MOTION CARRIES ON
ITEM TWENTY FOUR WITHDRAWAL OF
LAWN FOURTH. LAW ENFORCEMENT
USE OF DEADLY FORCE TRAINING
POLICY UPDATE. SO MOVED. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS MITCHELL
HI NIELSEN AYE AYE BELL.
CABALLERO HI DOLLY NO A RAZA.
FOR TITLE I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
HI MELENDEZ. MONNING AYE
MORLOCK. AND. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND MORALE. PAN HI ROTH
HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI. NIELSEN THE I'D TO
KNOW. NIELSEN I TO KNOW. SIZE.
THIRTEEN KNOWS TO. THANK YOU
THE MOTION CARRIES ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN WITHDRAWAL OF STREAM
GAUGING PLAN IMPLEMENTATION SB
NINETEEN UNLIMITED EMOTION SO
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BETTER THAT ARE CONTROLLED. MID
JULY NIELSEN I. WELL I.
CABALLERO HI DOLLY HI DORADO
HI- TADA HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
RIGHT MELENDEZ I MONNING I MORE
LOG HIGH MORALE HIGH. IN HI
RALPH HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI
WHY CAL SKI BY. HI EIGHTEEN OH
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOTION
CARRIES ITEM THIRTY FOUR.
WITHDRAW FRESH WATER IN S.
HEARING IN THE WILL HAVE TO
HELP ME WITH THAT WORD HARMFUL
ALGAL BLOOM PROGRAM A. B. EIGHT
THREE FOUR SOME MOVED. THANK
YOU PLEASE CALL THE WORLD
SENATORS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
HI. BILL I CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
THE RISE OF. RICARDO I'M LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI WINDOWS. MINING
HI MORE LOCK OUR MORRELL. IN
HIGH ROTH HI SKINNER AYE STERN
HI BY CAL SKI HI. I SIXTEEN NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE KERRY'S
MOVING ON TO ISSUE THIRTY FIVE-
WITHDRAW FUNDING FOR STREAM
GAUGING PLAN F. B. NINETEEN I'M
ALSO MOODY'S THANK YOU. FEDERAL.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN
NOPE. BELL I CABALLERO HI DOLLY
BY. THE RAZA I HER TITLE HI
LEYVA I MCGUIRE HI. MELENDEZ HI
MONNING NINE MORE LOCK I RAIL
HI. TEN HI RALPH HI SKINNER.
STERN HI MY COUNTY HI. BY
SEVENTEEN KNOWS ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE MEASURE KERRY
COLLEAGUES WERE NOW READY TO
MOVE INTO WORK OF. SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE. I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES ISSUE ONE.
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
FACE TO PLANNING ISSUE THREE
LIMóN NATION OF SONG BROWN
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAM ISSUE FIVE SENIOR
PENALTY IN MEDICARE PART B.
DISREGARD. ISSUE SIX HEARING
AID THE GRANT PROGRAM ISSUES
EIGHT THROUGH SEVENTEEN ON THE-
A JUST MANAGE CARE CAPITATION
PAYMENTS JULY THROUGH DECEMBER.
COLBERT NINETEEN ESTIMATE
IMPACTS ELIMINATE MEDI CAL
EXTENSION FOR POST PARTUM
MIDDLE HELL LIMóN EIGHT F. B.
I. R. T. FOR OPIOIDS AND OTHER
DRUGS. LIMóN A COMMUNITY BASED
ADULT SERVICES ELIMINATE EPS
THE T. CASE MANAGER ALLOCATION
TO COUNTIES ALONE ELIMINATE
FAMILY MOSAIC PROJECT
ELIMINATION OF OPTIONAL MEDICAL
MEDI CAL BENEFITS ELIMINATE
MULTI PURPOSE IN YOUR SERVICES
PROGRAM. AND THE ELIMINATION OF
THE RATE CARVE OUT FOR
COMMUNITY CLINICS. ISSUES
TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY EIGHT
MANAGE CARE EFFICIENCIES ESTATE
RECOVERY FROM DECEIVE MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES WERE VERSIONS OF
PREVIOUSLY FUNDED PROGRAM STATE
ONLY CLAIMING ADJUSTMENTS BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM
ADJUSTMENT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY. QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
IN INTERNAL AUDITING MONITORING
RISK MANAGEMENT AND HOSPITAL
SUPPORT AN ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
PATIENT DRIVEN OPERATING
EXPENSES AND EQUIPMENT OUT
ENTERTAINMENT MOVED TO ACCEPT
THAT STACK BOTH STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN HI BEL I. EARLIER HI.
DOLLY HI THE RAZA HI HER TITLE
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MINING NINE WARLOCK I
RAIL HI IN HI RALPH HI SKINNER
AYE STERN HI WHY COUNTY AYE
AYES EIGHTEEN NO ZERO. STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO I'LL ENTERTAIN A SINGLE
MOTION FOR THE FOLLOWING ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE FIVE ISSUES
ISSUE TO HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS
DATABASE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUE FOR MEDI CAL ARE EX AND
THREE FORTY BE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT POOL. ISSUES SEVEN.
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY ISSUE. NINETEEN
ELIMINATE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR HOSPITAL COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
AND IF YOU TWENTY FREEZE ON
MEDI CAL COUNTY ADMIN COSTS OF
DOING BUSINESS INCREASE IN A
SINGLE MOTION. SO MOVED THANK
YOU OUR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN.
NO BELL I CARRIER BY DOLLY NO
THE RAZA HI HER DAUGHTER AYE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
NOW. MINING RHINE MORLOCK NO
MORALE EL PAN HI RALPH NINE
SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY COUNTY
HI. PRICE THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
CARRIES ON THOSE ITEMS. ON
ISSUE EIGHTEEN THERE'S BEEN A
REQUEST TO SPLIT THE MOTION.
WOMEN'S TENNIS STAFF COULD JUST
GET ON MIKE TO CLARIFY WHAT THE
SPLIT ILL BE PLANNING. MR
SEVEN CHAU THIS SPLIT WITH THE
BABY TO- MOTIONS OF FIRST ONE
WOULD- THE ONLY ON THE WOMEN'S
HEALTH AND FAMILY PLANNING-
COMPONENTS. OF THE- ISSUE IN A
SECOND MOTION WOULD BE THE REST
OF THE ITEM. PAGE WITH SOME OF.
RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION SO
THE FIRST ACT WILL BE ON. THE
ALLOCATIONS FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH
AT EIGHTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND THE FAMILY PLANNING
ALLOCATIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE AGENDA THERE FOR THE FIRST
IS. RIGHT I FOCUSING ON THE
FAMILY PLANNING AND WOMEN'S
HEALTH S. ASPECT IS EVERYONE
CLEAR YES BECAUSE ALL MOVED
IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MITCHELL WHICH
HIGH FOR NIELSEN NO NEEDED WELL
I CABALLERO HI DOLLY NO THE
RAZA TADO AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ NOW MINING HI MORE
LIKE NO MORALE NO PAN HI RALPH
HI SKINNER. STERN HI MY COUNTY
HI. FIVE THIRTEEN NO FIVE THANK
YOU THE MOTION CARRIES THE
SECOND MOTION AGAIN UNDER THE-
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE PROP
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
VALUE BASED PAYMENTS LOAN
REPAYMENT STAFFING AND THIS
WILL BE TO REJECTED
MINISTRATIONS TRIGGER PROPOSAL
OR PLACE WITHIN THE TRIGGER
PLAN FOR ALL THE ITEMS LISTED
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF WOMEN'S
HEALTH AND FAMILY PLANNING
EVERYONE AMEND THE MOTION.
MOVED THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN HI. BELL FIVE. ZERO HI
DOLLY HI DORADO TADA I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
MONNING I MORE LOCKED HI
MORRELL I IN HIGH LAW HI
SKINNER STERN HI MY COUNTY HI.
HI EIGHTEEN NO ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE SUPPORTED.
NEXT COLLEAGUES WITH THE
TRANSITION INTO THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMPONENT OF SUB THREE.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING ISSUES
ISSUES ONE THROUGH TWENTY SIX
TWENTY NINE TO THIRTY THIRTY
TWO THROUGH FORTY FORTY TWO
THROUGH FORTY THREE AND FIFTY
NINE AND I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
READ THEM ALL. ISSUE ONE SELF
DETERMINATION REPORT EXTENSION
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ISSUE TO
REDUCTIONS IN PHAM DETERMINE
PROGRAM ISSUE THREE ELIMINATE
IN MISSISSIPPI STATE UP AND LA
I AGREE ISSUE FOR ELIMINATE SEA
BASS AND STATE OP ISSUE FIVE
HEADQUARTERS RELOCATION FUNDING
ISSUE SIX DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
POPULATION STAFFING ADJUSTMENTS
ISSUE SEVEN INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL CAPACITY ISSUE A
WITHDRAWAL ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENTS ISSUE NINE SYSTEMIC
THERAPEUTIC ASSESSMENT
RESOURCES AND TREATMENT
TRAINING WITHDRAW. WITHDRAW
ISSUE TEN STABILIZATION PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE IN REINTEGRATION
START LEASE AGREEMENTS ISSUE
ELEVEN PART OF BILL
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER INSTALL
FIRE SRINKLER SYSTEM. ISSUE
TWELVE FORTY BILL DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER NITRIC REMOVAL SYSTEM
REAPPROPRIATION ISSUE THIRTEEN
PART OF BILL DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER UPGRADE FIRE ALARM
SYSTEM ISSUE FOURTEEN MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. ISSUE FIFTEEN
IMPLEMENT PROVIDER RATE
REDUCTIONS AND UTILIZATION
REVIEWS EIGHT SIXTEEN
EMPLOYMENT UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE IF YOU SEVENTY
REDUCTION REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS IF YOU EIGHTEEN ****
HEARING PLAN ISSUE NINETEEN
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE MINIMUM WAGE
RECRUITMENT. ISSUE TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TBL
EXPANSION OF SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM ISSUE TWENTY ONE LEADS
THE PROPOSAL TBL EXPERT AT IT
REGIONAL CENTER PROCESS ISSUE
TWENTY TWO REDUCTIONS IN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
ISSUE TWENTY THREE T. B. L. ON
COLLECTIBLE DEBT. ISSUE TWENTY
FOUR AUTOMATION CHANGES FOR
CHILD SUPPORT DISREGARD ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE RIVER LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCY FUNDING
METHODOLOGY TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LEVELS ISSUE TWENTY SIX
TEMPORARY REDUCE STATE
OPERATIONS IN CONTRACT. MOVING
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY NINE TRIAL
SUPPORT DISREGARD ISSUE THIRTY
TBL STAGE ONE CHILD CARE PERMIT
REMOVAL FROM SINGLE ALLOCATION.
ISSUE THIRTY TWO TV L. CAL
FRESH ADMIN FUNDING REBATE.
REBATE REBATES. ISSUE THIRTY
THREE FEMALE CAL WORK STAGE ONE
CHILD CREMATED AND CONTINUE
WITH ELIGIBILITY ISSUE THIRTY
FOUR. CAL LEARN DEALING CAL
LEARN FROM A. F. L. P. AND
UPDATE PROGRAM DESIGN. IF YOU
THIRTY FIVE REDUCE SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
RATES BY 5% IF YOU THIRTY SIX
ELIMINATE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
SOCIAL WORKER RATE INCREASE
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN SUSPEND
LEVEL TO CARE. LEVEL LEVEL OF
CARE RATE TWO THREE FOUR ISSUE
THIRTY EIGHT FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM ISSUE THIRTY
NINE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
RECONCILIATION CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMS FOR FISCAL YEARS TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. ISSUE FORTY
CAL WORKS COSTS AND CAREFUL
PROJECTIONS ISSUE FORTY TWO THE
SUSPENSION OF CAL WORK TO SPEND
IT SUBSIDIZED IT EXPANDED
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT. ISSUE
FORTY THREE CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING PROGRAM REDUCTION
ISSUE FORTY FOURTH SUSPENSION
OF CAL WORKS OUTCOME THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY RECOUP REVIEW.
IF YOU FORTY FIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT ESTIMATE
FORTY SIX WITH HOLD THE
FEBRUARY THE FEDERAL JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE COLOR TESTIFY
IF THIS P. RECIPIENTS ISSUE
FORTY SEVEN OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS LOCAL SYSTEM
ASSISTANCE ADJUSTMENTS. IF YOU
FORTY EIGHT IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES ESTIMATE IF YOU FORTY
NINE IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
HOLD COUNTY ADMINISTRATION
PUBLIC AUTHORITY FUNDING TO
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET THAT
LEVEL ISSUE FIFTY IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TRANSFER
PAYROLL FUNCTIONS. ISSUE FIFTY
ONE. IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES 7% REDUCTION TO
RECIPIENTS SERVICE HOURS ISSUE
FIFTY TWO IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES ELIMINATE. PROBATION A
PROTECTIVE SUPER VISIT
SUPERVISION HOURS RECIPIENT TO
THE SAME RESIDENTS IF YOU FIFTY
THREE IN ON SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
CONFORM. RESIDUAL PROGRAM THE
TIMING OF MEDI CAL COVERAGE.
AND IF YOU FIFTY NINE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL BACK BILL
FOR LOSS OF NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES ALTHOUGH
MOVE MOTION SO MOVE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND ALL THOSE ITEMS.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI
BILL CABALLERO HI DOLLY HI THE
RAZA TADA I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
RIGHT MELENDEZ HI MONNING HI
MORE LOCK HI MORALE HIGH PINION
HI ROTH AYE SKINNER. STERN HI.
WHAT COUNTY HI. THERE ARE FIVE.
SKINNER I. FIVE EIGHTEEN NO
ZERO. THANK YOU. BOTH MEASURES
PASS MOVING ON COLLEAGUES TO
TWO ISSUES OUT ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO TAKE TOGETHER THEY
ARE ISSUES TWENTY EIGHT IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES MEDI CAL
EXPANSION FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS AGE SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER AND ISSUE THIRTY ONE. T.
B. L. CAL WORKS IDENTITY
VERIFICATION SO MOVED IT'S BEEN
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN NO.
BELL BY CARRIER HI DOLLY NO
RAZA. HER TITLE I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MONNING HI
MORE LOCK NO. MORE LIKE NO NO
MORRELL NO PAN HI RAW HI
SKINNER AYE STERN HI LIKE OWSKI
HI. FIVE THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS- PARKING
OCCURRED IN. MOVING ALONG TO
THE FOLLOWING ISSUES ISSUES.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE AND FIFTY SEVEN AND I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO TAKE THEM
ALL IN ONE VOTE ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TBL
MODIFICATIONS TO CHILD SUPPORT
REGULATIONS. ISSUE FIFTY FOUR.
THE VERSION RENOUNCED ORDER
SERVICE THE FUNDING. A VERSION
OF FUNDING FOR VARIOUS PROGRAMS
ISSUE FIFTY FIVE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE AND ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TBL
MAINTAIN AND EXTEND PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY THAN ACTED DURING
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ON THE MOVE- XIN. THANK YOU
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MITCHELL BY NIELSEN ABSTAINED.
BELL HI CABALLERO HI DOLLY. THE
RAZA TADO I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MONNING I MORE LOCK. MORALE.
PAN HI RALPH HI SKINNER OUR
STERN BY BY COUNTY HI. ICE
THIRTEEN NO ZERO THANK YOU
MEASURES PATH WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THREE INDIVIDUAL VOTE FOR
THE FOLLOWING- ISSUE ITEMS
ISSUES FORTY ONE FIFTY SIX AND
FIFTY EIGHT. ITEM FORTY ONE IS
THE REVISED CAL WORKS
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND
CHILDCARE ASSUMPTION OF MOVED
CALL THE ROLL. CENTERS MITCHELL
HI. NIELSEN STAYING. BELL I
CARILLO HI DOLLY BY THE RAZA.
FOR TITLE NINE LEYVA I. THE
BUYER HI MELENDEZ I MONNING HI
MORE LOCK. MORALE. PIN HI LAW
HI SKINNER I STERN I WORK OUT I.
FIVE FIFTEEN NO ZERO THANK YOU
THE MEASURE KERRY'S ITEM FIFTY
SIX LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL T. B.
L. I. HSS PROVIDER ORIENTALE
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTERS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
ABSTAINED BELL HI. CABALLERO HI
DOLLY NO. THE RAZA I HER TITLE
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NOW. MONNING NINE MORE
LOCK NO. MORALE. PAN HI ROTH HI
SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY CAL
SCHEME HI. PRICE THIRTEEN KNOWS
THREE HELLO THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION CARRIES ITEM
FIFTY EIGHT LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL TBL CAL WORKS TIME
CLOCK. SO MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CENTERS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN STATE. THE BILL
COPYRIGHT HI DOLLY NO. THE RAZA.
HER TITLE HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ. MONNING NINE MORE
LOCK VOTE MORRELL NO PAN HI ALL
I SKINNER I STERN HI MY CAL SKI
HI. PRICE THIRTEEN NOES THREE.
THAT MEASURE KERRY'S. ALI THEY
SHOULD BE NOW TO VOTE ONLY
ITEMS FOR SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FOUR STATE GOVERNMENT. I'M
GOING TO ENTERTAIN A SINGLE
MOTION. FOR ITEMS TWO THREE SIX
THROUGH NINE ELEVEN THROUGH.
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE FORTY THREE A
FORTY FIVE. CAN YOUR I'M SORRY
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT PLEASE SURE
I'M GONNA READ THEM
INDIVIDUALLY BUT I'LL JUST GIVE
YOU THENUMBERS QUE IT'S ISSUES
TO. THREE SIX THREE NINE.
ELEVEN TO SIXTEEN. 382-223-2630
FIVE. FORTY THREE FORTY FIVE.
THEN HOLD ON FOR A SECOND LOOK
TO THE AND NUMBER NINE. YEAH MY
MINOR OFF. YEAH AS I GROW IT
THAT'S THE NEW ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
FOR THE REPLACEMENT CHEATS THAT
I PUT ON THE BACK. ALL RIGHT.
I'M GONNA ENTERTAIN A SINGLE
MOTION FOR THE FOLLOWING ISSUES.
ISSUES. TWO THREE SIX TWO NINE.
861-820-2320. FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SIX FORTY FOUR AND FORTY
SIX. I HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK YOU
ONLY SEE WITH THE DIFFERENT C.
F. OKAY I SEE IF YOU ALL RIGHT.
ISSUE TWO SMALL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE ISSUE THREE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FUND
LOAN TO THE GENERAL FUND.
ISSUES SIX THROUGH NINE ARE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTION. AN AMERICORPS
FUNDING STRATEGIES FRESNO
INTEGRATED QUE TO SIXTEEN
COLLABORATIVE. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF. INSURANCE RATE
INCREASES ISSUE NINE WORKERS
COMPENSATION FRAUD PROGRAM.
ISSUES ELEVEN THROUGH SIXTEEN
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
EXPANSION CEMETERY FUNERAL
BUREAU ENDOWMENT FUNDS CHIEF
ATHLETIC INSPECTOR AN ASSISTANT
CHIEF ATHLETIC INSPECTOR TBL
FOR VERY FEE INCREASES CURE IS
EXPENDITURE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT FOR CHAPTERS FOR
STATUS OF TWENTY NINETEEN. TEN
CURES EXPENDITURE ADJUSTMENT
VIA AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. ISSUE
EIGHTEEN FACILITIES OPERATIONS
FUNDING AUGMENTATION FISHING
TWENTY TECHNICAL TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO MOVE FUNDS THE
FINANCIAL PROTECTION INNOVATION
FUN. IF YOU TWENTY THREE
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
PRODUCTION EARLY REVERSION
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN EARLY
REVERSION ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN.
HOUSING FIRST ISSUE THIRTY SIX.
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX ISSUE.
FORTY FOUR WITHDRAWAL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY. AND ISSUE FORTY SIX
FILED THE CELL ADJUSTMENT
ALERTING THE MOTION TO ACCEPT
STAFF GRECO SO MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE CENTERS
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN HI BILL I.
CAREER HI DOLLY HI DORADO HI
FOR TITLE I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE AYE MELENDEZ. MONNING HI
MORE LOCK. MORALE HI PAN HI
RALPH HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI
MY COUNTY HI. HI EIGHTEEN NO
ZERO THANK YOU STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE CONCURRED
IN. I'M GONNA TAKE ONE MOTION
FOR THE FOLLOWING ISSUES ISSUE
NUMBER ONE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION BASE LINE COST
INCREASES ISSUE FOR ONLINE
LEARNING PROGRAM TO REDUCE
EXPENDITURES BY 20% ISSUE
SEVENTEEN BOARD IN VERO WORK
LOAD ISSUE NINETEEN. EIGHT LET
ME SKIP ISSUE NINETEEN ISSUE
TWENTY TWO FOSTER CARE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING EXTENSION
ISSUE. TWENTY SIX. AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE CLEAN UP ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT. WORKERS STATUS
EMPLOYEES INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS ISSUE TWENTY NINE.
WORKERS STATUS EMPLOYEES
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ISSUE
THIRTY FOUR USED CAR DEALER
SALES TAX THREE RUBIO ISSUE
THIRTY FIVE REMOVED PROVISION
TO OF ITEMS. SEVENTY SIX
HUNDRED. ZERO ZERO ONE ZERO
ZERO ZERO ONE ISSUE THIRTY
SEVEN. INDIVIDUAL SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY PAYMENT PENALTY
T. B. K. IF YOU THIRTY EIGHT
THAT OPERATING LOSS ISSUE
THIRTY NINE. BUSINESS TAX
CREDIT LIMITATION ISSUE FORTY
THE I. T. C. ISSUE FORTY ONE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS CANNABIS CAN I GET A
SINGLE MOTION TO ADDRESS- MOVE
ISSUES. SOME OF. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS MITCHELL. HI
NIELSEN NOPE WELL I CAREER BY
DOLLY NOPE DORADO HI- HURTADO
AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
NOW MONNING HI MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO PAN HI RALPH HI
SKINNER. STERN HI MY CAL SKI HI.
HI THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION KERRY'S ON
ISSUE NINETEEN CALLING. I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO EXCEPT.
ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR ISSUE NINETEEN
WHICH IS PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE SO
MOTION A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT'S IN THE AGENDA AGAIN
ISSUE NINETEEN OF THE MOTION IS
TO ACCEPT TRAILER BILL
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SO MOVED WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NO
CENTERS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN NO
BELL COPIER HI DOLLY NO. THE
RAZA HI. HER DAUGHTER I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO NO MONNING HI
WARLOCK NO IN MY MORALE HELLO.
PAN HI RALPH HI SKINNER AYE
STERN BY MY COUNT HI. FIVE
THIRTEEN NO FIVE THANK YOU THE
MEASURE KERRY'S. I'LL ENTERTAIN
A SINGLE MOTION FOR THE NEXT.
SEVEN ITEMS IF YOU TEN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY GENERAL ELECTIONS. ISSUE
TWENTY ONE NEW DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER FINANCE PROTECTION
INNOVATION ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT
ISSUE THIRTY FOR THE BILL
PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH NICOTINE
BASE BAKING TAX ISSUE THIRTY
ONE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROPOSED NICOTINE BASED VAPING
TAX ISSUE THIRTY TWO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROPOSAL
VAPING TAX. ISSUE THIRTY THREE
VEHICLE VALUATION A PRIVATE
PARTY SALE USED CAR SALES TAX
FREE RUBIO. ALERTED EMOTION SO
MOVED THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CENTERS MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN ABSTAINED BELL I
CABALLERO HI DOLLY. RAZA FOR
TITLE I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MONNING HI MORE LOCK
NO ABSTAINED. MORALE. PAN HI
RALPH HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI
MY COUNTY I. HI THIRTEEN NO
ZERO. THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE PASSED FOR
THE NEXT. NINE ITEMS WE'RE
GOING TO DO AN INDIVIDUAL ROLL
CALL ON EACH. STARTING WITH
ISSUE FORTY TO TRANSFER FROM
THE STATE. ODJICK
INFRASTRUCTURE FRONT THIRTY TO
NINETY TWO TO THE GENERAL FUND.
UNDERTAKEN MOTIONS. I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FROM THE
MOVED THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MADAM SENATORS MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN HI. WELL I. HI DOLLY HI
THE RAZA. HER TITLE I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ HI MONNING
HI MORE LOCK. MORALE HI PAN.
RALPH. SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY
CAL SPEAK HI. PRICE SEVENTEEN
NO ZERO. THREE AMERICAN MUSEUM
OF. OR ON THE FORTY. FIRE IS
ICY WITH MATT AT THE END OF THE
DEBATE. YEAH MY NUMBER THAT
WOULD I THINK THAT IT IS FORTY
ONE. HEY THE RECOMMENDATION OF
KERRY'S ITEM FORTY THREE.
REVERSION OF FUNDING FOR THE
KOREAN AMERICAN NATIONAL MUSEUM
SO MOVED. THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FOR THE NEXT
ONE FORTY THREE. FORTY THREE
FORTY THREE. YEAH. IT SHOULD BE
ON PAGE SEVENTY TWO OF YOUR
AGENDA. WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR THE ISSUE FORTY
THREE. MITCHELL. SENATE
MITCHELL YES BY. NIELSEN HI.
FORTY TWO BELL I. FERRERO HI
DAWALY THOUGH. THE RAZA HI HER
TITLE HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NOW. MINING HI MORE
LOCK NO. MORALE NO PAN HI RAW-
SKINNER ARE YOU TURN BY WHY CAL
SKI I CAME AFTER THE SIX ON THE.
AT HIGHS FOURTEEN KNOWS FOR
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS CONCURRENT IN
ITEM FORTY FIVE FOR VERSION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY MASTER DEVELOPMENT
FUND. ALERTING THE MOTION. SO
MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ONLY SENATORS MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN HI. BELL I. CABALLERO
HI DOLLY NO. THE RAZA. HER
TITLE I. LEYVA HI MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ. MONNING I MORE LOCK
NO MORALE HELP PAN HI RALPH HI
SKINNER I. STERN HI MY CAL SKI
HI. NIELSEN I LIKE TO KNOW
NIELSEN I TO KNOW. HI THIRTEEN
KNOWS FIVE. HI THIRTEEN KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE KERRY'S MOVING
ON TO ISSUE FORTY SEVEN NO PAY
ROLL WORLD THE JEFF MENTAL
MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE SENATORS MITCHELL I NIELSEN
HI. BELL I. CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
THE RAZA HER TITLE I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE RIGHT MELENDEZ. MONNING
HI MORE LONG NO. FOR RAIL OKAY
PAN HI ROTH HI LATER I STERN HI
MY COUNTY HI. ICE FOURTEEN
KNOWS TO AYE FORTINOS TO THEIR
RECOMMENDATION KERRY'S ISSUE
FORTY EIGHT. SALARY REDUCTION A
LITTLE MOVED LOCATIONS THANK
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL I. NIELSEN.
WELL I. CABALLERO HI DOLLY. THE
RAZA HI FURTADO HI LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MONNING I
MORE LOCK NOPE. MORALE HELLO
PAN HI ROTH HI SKINNER AYE
STERN HI HONEY MY COUNTY HI
NEXT. PRICE THIRTEEN KNOWS TO
AFTER RECOMMENDATION KERRY'S
ITEM FORTY NINE FLAT PAYROLL
MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN
NO. BELL I CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
THE RAZA HI- TADO I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE RIGHT MELENDEZ. MONNING
HI MORE LOCK NO MORRELL NO TEN
HI. ROTH HI SKINNER AYE STERN
HI MY COUNTY HI. FIVE THIRTEEN
NOES THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO ISSUE
FIFTY ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
FOR SALARIES AND WAGES- MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTERS
MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN HI FIFTY
ONE NO FIFTY FIFTY FIFTY
NIELSEN AYE HI. BELL I ZERO HI
DOLLY. GOING THE RAZA. THANK
YOU HOTEL HI LEYVA HI MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ I MONNING HI MORE LOCK.
MORALE. PAN HI RALPH HI SKINNER
AYE TURN HI MY COUNTY HI. ICE
FIFTEEN NO ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS.
CONCURRED IN ISSUE FIFTY ONE
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
AND SUPPLANTING PAYMENT- MOVED
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. SENATORS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI BELL HI
CABALLERO I DOLLY NO THE RAZA.
HER TITLE I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ HI. MONNING I. MORE
LOOK NO. MORALE NO IN HI RALPH
HI THE GENERATOR HI STERN HI
MIKE OWSKI HI. WHAT NUMBER WE
ON Q. EXACT. PRICE FOURTEEN JUN
LOS LOTTERY THANK YOU. AFRICA
IN ADDITION WANTED TO WHAT FATE
WHAT PAGE ARE WE ON ISSUE FIFTY
TWO SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION
PAYMENT SUPPLANTING PAYMENT AND
THE RATE SETTING AUTHORITY
MOVED THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN HI.
WELL I. CABALLERO HI DOLLY NO.
THE RAZA. HI HER TITLE I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ I.
MONNING HI MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO IN HIGH. ROTH HI SKINNER I
STERN HI MY COUNTY I. ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE FOURTEEN NOES THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEY'RE
FRECKLES CONCURRED IN OUR LAST
ITEM UNDER SUB FOR IS ISSUE
FIVE. I JUST WANT CURRENT YEAR
PRECISION MEDICINE TO REFLECT
AVAILABLE GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
I'M GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
ENTERTAIN TO SEPARATE MOTIONS
THE FIRST MARK MOTION WILL BE
ON THE RIVER VERSION OF THE
EIGHTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ALERTING EMOTION
SO MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
HI BELL CABALLERO HI DOLLY BY.
TORONTO HI THE TITLE AYE LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MONNING HI
MORE LOCK OUR MORALE HI IN HI
RAW HI SKINNER OUR STERN HI MY
CAL SKI HI. I SEVENTEENTH NO
ZERO THANK YOU THAT MOTION
CARRIES THE SECOND MOST WILL BE
ON THE REDIRECTION OF NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION TO THE ASUS
PROGRAM THE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES PROGRAM- MOVED ALL
XIN THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
NO. EL ALL RIGHT CABALLERO HI
DOLLY NOPE DORADO. YEAH HI. HER
TITLE NINE LEYVA HI AND THE
CHOIR. MELENDEZ NOW MONEY I
MORE LOT NO MORRELL. NOW IN HI
RALPH HI SKINNER HI STERN BY
LIKE OWSKI HI. I THINK THAT THE
ICE TWELVE KNOWS FIVE. THANK
YOU THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
KERRY. MOVING ON TO
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER BY PUBLIC
SAFETY CORRECTIONS IN THE
JUDICIARY MADAM CHAIR. YES
SENATOR DO WE HAVE A FIFTY
THREE YEAR NOT IN THIS. SECTION.
FOR THE STATE FAIRS. GOOD POINT.
IF THE. A LOT OF. ACTUALLY WHAT.
WE DIDN'T DO FIFTY THREE
THROUGH FIFTY NINE. OF THE
THREE FIFTY NINE YEAR. WELL.
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN GOVERNOR
FIFTY THREE BUT- AND LOOK IN.
RIGHT I DON'T SEE IT WE'VE DONE
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY NINE. THE
SEVENTY STUFF ONLINE SYSTEM
RIGHT ONE. ON ON HERE LATER
WITH THE CHECKER CENTER MORE
LAW YOU GET A GOLD STAR FOR THE-
THANK YOU GOOD AT COLLEAGUES
THAT'S TRUE YEAH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL ITEM FIFTY THREE I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SO MOVED
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THERE. MITCHELL I NIELSEN
HI BEL CAREER HI DOLLY HI
DORADO HER TITLE I LABOR HI
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ I. MONNING
NINE MORE LOCK I MORALE HI. IN
HI RALPH HI SKINNER AYE STERN
HI MIKE OWSKI HI. FIVE
SEVENTEEN ZERO ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT FINAL MEASURE
THEORIES NOW WE WILL TRANSITION.
MILLION BUCKS. I TELL A LOT
MORE LIKE YOU HELP ME TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T MISS ANYTHING
ELSE AS YOUR NEW ASSIGNMENT I'M
HERE FOR YOU. THANK YOU. POR
KNOWS I NEED ALL RIGHT- WE ARE
MOVING INTO SUB BY COLLEAGUES
FACE SEVENTY EIGHT OF YOUR
AGENDA. I WILL ENTERTAIN A
SINGLE MOTION TO COVER ISSUES
ONE THROUGH. SIX EIGHT TO NINE
TWELVE TO FOURTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE AND. TWENTY FOUR
THREE TWENTY FIVE. I WILL BE
READING THEM I APPRECIATE THAT
ISSUE ONE ABILITY TO PAY
EXPANSION ISSUE TO
MODERNIZATION OF COURT
OPERATIONS ISSUE THREE.
WITHDRAWAL OF WILD FIRE
MITIGATION FINANCIAL SYSTEMS
PILOT PROGRAM ISSUE FULL. ISSUE
FOR WITHDRAWAL OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT MEDICAL EVIDENCE YOUR
EXAMINATIONS ISSUE SIX
REVERSION OF LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENT. ISSUE SIX
WITHDRAWAL OF STATEWIDE SMART
NINE ONE ONE FEASIBILITY STUDY.
ISSUE EIGHT. THROUGH CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM A. B.
TWELVE NINETY SIX ISSUE NINE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE FACILITY.
LEGIONELLA REMEDIATION ISSUE
TWELVE RE ENTRY REQUIREMENTS
MODIFICATION ISSUE THIRTEEN
MODIFICATIONS OF AB NINE
HUNDRED GENERAL FUND
REAPPROPRIATION AN ISSUE
FOURTEEN PHARMACY COMPLIANCE SB.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. ISSUE
NINETEEN. TECHNICAL JUST MAKE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES ISSUE
TWENTY ONE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
REHABILITATIVE COMMUNITIES.
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR. I DON'T HAVE
AN ISSUE TWENTY FOUR. I DON'T
HAVE IT WE GOT ALL NIGHT
MODIFICATION OF CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON CORCORAN
MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
IMPROVEMENTS FACE. AND ISSUE
TWENTY. FIVE FOR I SEE TWENTY
FOUR. A ALL. ADULT POPULATION
ADJUSTMENT SO MOVED EXCUSE ME
THANK YOU UP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN. HI WELL I CABALLERO HI
DOLLY BY THE RAZA HI FURTADO HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK MORALE HI.
I YES BEN ALL RIGHT LAW HI
SKINNER. STERN HI MY COUNTY HI.
BY SEVENTEEN NO ZERO. ARE YOU
CHANGE YOUR BUT BEFORE I CALL
THAT NO I'M NOT MADAM CHAIR DID
WE- DID YOU CALL IF ISSUE FIVE
YES YOU DO YES OKAY AND YES I
DID ISSUES ONE THROUGH SIX OKAY
ONE MAKE SURE SORRY OKAY AND SO
THE VOTE IS SEVENTEEN ZERO HE
JUST CALLED MEASURES ALL AFRICA
ARE ACCEPTED. THE NEXT GROUP OF
ISSUES WILL ADDRESS- ISSUES
SEVEN. TEN FIFTEEN THROUGH
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY SIX.
ITEM SEVEN SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION FUNDING- ALIGNMENT
TO SB THREE EIGHTY FOUR. ITEM
TN ELIMINATE PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLOSE CLINICS ISSUE. FIFTEEN
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL PRISON
CLOSER TBL ISSUES SIXTEEN IN
INDIGENT DEFENSE PILOT ISSUE
SEVENTEEN INDIGENT DEFENSE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ISSUE
TWENTY TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
CRIMINAL RECORDS AUTOMATIC
RELIEF AB TEN SEVENTY SIX.
ISSUE TWENTY TO MODIFY INDIGENT
DEFENSE ISSUE. TWENTY THREE.
JUDICIAL BRANCH BUDGET
REDUCTION IN ISSUE. TWENTY SIX.
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT SO MOVED IT'S BEEN
MOST THE WE'VE GOT A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN I WELL I'VE
CABALLERO HI DOLLY I GOT THE
NOTE TO ONE. THE RAZA. HER
DAUGHTER I. LEYVA HI FIRE
MELENDEZ NOW. MONNING HI MORE
LOCKED ME MORALE NO PAN HI ROTH
HI SKINNER. STERN HI BY CAL SKI
HI. NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW.
NIELSEN HI THE NO. FIVE TWELVE
KNOWS FIVE. THE MOTION HERE.
YEAH AFTER THE. THAT OKAY AND
TWENTY THREE WE DID THE TWENTY
THREE. YEAH YOU CAN DROP THAT
ONE THIS IS THE FIRST OFF THE
DUPLICATE.
YEAH.
UHHUH. YEAH.
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES NEXT I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. FOUR ISSUE
ELEVEN. TO CONSOLIDATE THE IN
MAKE FIRE CAPS ON PAGE EIGHTY
ONE OF YOUR GENDER SO MOVED
THANK YOU AGAIN ISSUE ELEVEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN NO WELL.
CABALLERO HI DOLLY NO. THE RAZA
HI HER TITLE I LEYVA HI.
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ NOW MONNING HI
MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO. IN HIGH
ROTH HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI BY
CAL SKI BY. PRICE TWELVE KNOWS
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION CARE IS
CARRIED. HE FINISHED.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE NOW ABOUT TO
MOVE INTO VOTING FOR THE ITEMS
THAT WERE UP FOR DISCUSSION
TODAY. ISSUE EIGHTEEN AND MARK.
SO FAST ALRIGHT.
SO.
THE
SENATOR NIELSEN MADAM CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THAT WE WOULD YOU
DIVIDE THESE QUESTIONS. AT THE
RECONSIDERATION ON ITEMS ONE
THROUGH SIX. BUT SHOULD BE
SEVEN NOW THESE WOULD BE ITEM
SEPARATE SEPARATE INDEPENDENT.
SEVEN TEN. FIFTEEN THROUGH
SEVENTEEN TWENTY. TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY THREE. AND TWENTY SIX.
SENATOR NIELSEN I AM TWENTY
THREE WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THAT
YEAH YEAH SO LET ME RESTATE
WHERE YOU'RE ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION WE'RE GOING TO
VACATE THE- PAST VOTE YES- YEAH
AND LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE A
ROLL CALL. ON THAT REQUEST SO
THE REQUEST FROM CITY TO
NIELSEN TO VACATE RECONFIGURING
THE VOTE ON ITEM 710-152-1720
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY SIX AND THEN I'LL
ENTERTAIN ANOTHER MOTION FROM
YOU SIR. LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON
THAT. I WOULD SUBMIT IT FOR YOU.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI
TO SPELL THAT BACHA RARE HI
DOLLY HI TO RAZA TADO HI LEYVA
LISTED WIRE. LINDA SHE MINING
NINE FIVE MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE
HIGH PAN HI RALPH HI SKINNER.
STERN HI MY COUNT. YEAH HI I.
THANK YOU SIXTEEN ZERO
BEAUTIFUL THAT WAS UNANIMOUS I
WHICH ARE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
JUST ASK FOR I WILL NOW
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. ON ISSUES
SEVEN TEN FIFTEEN THROUGH.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY SIX. IT'S BEEN MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
RICHARD INTERVENTION WERE
REVOKED MITCHELL II. NIELSEN NO.
MEL CABALLERO I A DOLLY NO TO
RAZA HI HER TITLE HI LEYVA.
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ NOW MONNING HI
MORE MORE LOCKED OKAY MORALE NO.
PAN HI. TWICE WE WILL DRAW HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI WHY CAL SKI
HI. NO. FIVE TWELVE KNOWS FIVE
THANK YOU ICE TWELVE BILLS BY
THE MOTION CARRIES OUT
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO SUPPORT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON
ISSUE TWENTY THREE JUDICIAL
BRANCH BUDGET REDUCTION. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTERS MITCHELL
HI. NIELSEN ABSTAINED. BELL.
CABALLERO HI. DOLLY THE RAZA.
THE TITLE I. LEYVA MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ. MONNING HI MORE LOCK.
MORRELL. PAN HI RAW. SKINNER
STERN HI MY COUNTY HI. PRICE
TWELVE NO ZERO FIVE TWELVE NO
ZERO THE MOTION THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ISSUE TWENTY
THREE CARRIES FINAL ISSUE FOR
VOTE UNDER SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE IS ISSUE EIGHTEEN
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL BAY ON THE
BOX EMAIL POLITICALLY THE
MOTION. TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SERVICE SENATORS
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN. ABSTAINED
CHOIR LEFT SMELL FROM GETTING
CABALLERO. DAWALY GO. THE RAZA
HER TITLE. LEYVA MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ NO MINING HI MORE LOCK
NO MORALE EL PAN HI RAW HI
SKINNER HI. STERN BY. BY COUNTY
HI. HI TEN KNOWS FOR. I CAN
KNOWS FOR THE MOTION KERRY.
PROBABLY WE NOW HAVE FOR ITEMS.
THAT WE- START THE HEARING WITH
THAT WERE DISCUSSION ITEMS.
THAT WE WILL NOW PUT UP FOR A
VOTE STARTING WITH. ON PAGE
NINETY FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA.
ISSUE ONE BUDGET FRAMEWORK
CONTROL SECTION EIGHT POINT TWO
EIGHT RESTORATIONS TRIGGER
RELATED TO THE FEDERAL FUNDS IN
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY FIVE
POINT FIFTY BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT ESTIMATE.
SO MOVED THE. YEAH STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT THE
SINISTER PLAN AND DISPLAYED ALL
ON THE AGENDA SO THAT I HAVE A
MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN ISSUE ONE BUDGET
FRAMEWORK I JUST SENATORS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN. BELL RIGHT.
CABALLERO HI DOLLY. THE RAZA.
FOR TITLE HI. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ. MINING HI MORE LOCK.
MORALE. PAN HI LAW HI SKINNER
STERN HI MY COUNTY HI. FIND
ANOTHER ICE TWELVE NO ZERO
COULD YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. THIS
MCGUIRE. HE'S BEEN GONE FOR
OKAY HE'S NINE YEARS ON HIM
THOUGH SO GIVING ON WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN. REALLY
THERE'S A NEED TO THIRD
COLLEAGUES AGAIN WE ARE- NOW
VOTING ON OUR ITEMS THAT WERE
UP FOR DISCUSSION AT THE TOP OF
THE HEARING WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ISSUE TO WHICH IS ON PAGE
NINETY SEVEN OF THE AGENDA AND
IT'S THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE. SO MOVED THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE AND
THERE IS A FULL ATTACHMENT
IDENTIFYING THE- DELINEATING.
THE NATURE OF THE SENATE
VERSION. I HAVE A MOTION
REMOVED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTERS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN. YOUR BILL
ALL RIGHT CARRIER HI DOLLY HI.
THE RAZA. HER DAUGHTER I LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ HI MANY OF
THESE MINING NINE. MORLOCK
ONLINE MORALE AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE WE'RE AT
DURING. MORALE HI OF. MILLION
HI RAW ON SKINNER STERN BYE BYE
COUNTY HI. YES HI. NIELSEN HI
HI. I SEVENTEEN BELOW ZERO
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THAT ITEM
OPEN. ISSUE THREE PAGE NINETY
NINE OF THE AGENDA. CONTROL
SECTIONS ELEVEN POINT NINE
ELEVEN POINT NINETY FIVE AND
THIRTY SIX POINT ZERO SO MOVE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION. SO MOVED.
THE LINEATED ON YOUR GENDER ON
PAGES ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE WE HAVE A
MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL HI. NIELSEN
HI. L. THREE CAREER HI DOLLY BY
RAZA HER TALK HER DAUGHTER HI
IT IS LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ. WRITTEN BY THE
MORNING I MORE LOCK. MORALE.
PAN HI ROTH HI SKINNER AYE
STERN HI MY COUNTY HI. SENATOR
DOLLINGER MADAM CHAIR I MIGHT
NUMBER OF PAGES ARE NOT THE
SAME AS YOURS AND SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY SIX WAS NOT IN THAT VOTE.
WHICH WOULD BE. WELL YOUR
INSURANCE YOU'RE RIGHT WELL IN
OUR AGENDA DOES SAY WELL THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOCUSES ON.
ALL SIX ELEVEN NINETY ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE IN CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY RIGHT. MINE SAYS THIRTY
SIX SO DOES MINE. RIGHT WHICH I
THOUGHT WE BROKE OUT AND FIDDLE
SECTION. MARTY I WOULD HAVE IS.
YEAH I DO NOT SEE THAT IN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION SEAT AND
THE DESCRIPTION YEAH I MAY BE
WRONG IT'S NOT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AT THAT RECORD
THIRTY SIX IS OUT HANG ON ONE
SECOND WITH A TO STAFF DO YOU
WANT TO DO. ALL THREE. YEAH AND
THEN TELL ME YES. YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOUR TWO THREE TWO SEVEN THREE.
UNDER THIS DESCRIPTION ON THE
AND THE ANALYSIS IS CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX YEAH OKAY IN
ONE SECOND I BELIEVE THAT I
WONDER IF THIS IS A TYPO UNDER
ITEM THREE BECAUSE UNDERNEATH
THAT IT SAYS TO REVISE SECTION
THIRTY SIX. YEAH THE TRUTH IF I
THINK THAT CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY IS A TYPE OF. CAN ORDER
AND SIX WHY DO WE HAVE RIGHT.
THERE ARE TWO PAN YES JOHN
FORTINO THREE SETS CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY BUT THE
DESCRIPTIONS IS REVITALIZATION
THIRTIES YEAH I THINK THAT'S
THE TYPE WHICH SHOULD BE
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX OKAY
SO HANG ON ONE SECOND. HANG ON.
EMERGENCY VOTE RIGHT YES IT
WORKS TO. DO YOU THINK THE TWO
ONE ON TRAILER BILL PROVIDES IS
THERE SO I DON'T WANT TO GET. I
KNOW. BY THE. WITH THAT IN THE
BILL WHICH MADE A- THEY HAVE A
TYPO IN THERE AND THEY ALSO
PROVIDE. AND WOULD YOU PLEASE
REMEMBER. THAT. NO WAY WELL
THERE EXCEED CONFUSION YEAH
THIS SECTION OF. THE TAKE BACK
FOR. COULD HAVE BEEN OUT HERE
DAHLE IF YOU WANT TO SAY. YOU
WANT TO GIVE THE GOVERNOR
TH<c.cyan> I WOULD ENTERTAIN THEM</c>
HOPEFULLY FOR YOU CONSENT TO RE
THE LAST VOTE WE HAVE
COLLEAGUES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A- SEPARATE VOTE ON EACH
CONTROL SECTION IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO RESCINDING OF THE
LAST VOTE. YEAH WE DID WE DID.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION GREAT
THANK YOU SO. I WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN NINETY AS
REFLECTED ON PAGE ONE HUNDRED
OF THE AGENDA SO MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WELL THAT'S THE
FIRST. ELEVEN NINE BETTER
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT NINETY
SENATORSMITCHELL AYE. NIELSEN
I. WELL I'VE CABALLERO I DO.
DOLLY I DORADO HI RICARDO I
LEYVA GIVE HIGH MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ HI. MINING HI. MORE
LOCK HI MORRELL I IN BY RAW ON
SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY COUNTY
I. HI SEVENTEEN NO ZERO FIVE
SEVENTEEN OH ZERO WILL HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON CONTROL
SECTION. ELEVEN NINETY FIVE AS
REFLECTED ON PAGE ONE ON ONE ON
THE AGENDA. IS THAT I'M MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN HI BILL. HI
CABALLERO HI DOLLY HI ONE OF
THE RAZA HI THE TITLE HI LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MONEY BY
MORE LAW HI MORALE HIGH PAN HI.
ROTH HI SKINNER OUR STERN HEY.
WHAT CAL SCHEME HI. FIVE
EIGHTEEN NO ZERO THAT MOTION
CARRIES IN TERMS OF SUPPORT OF
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
FINALLY RETAIN A FINAL MOTION
ON TO EXCEPT ACCEPT THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX SO MOVED.
THIS CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MITCHELL HI NIELSEN NO BELL
CARRIER HI DOLLY NO THE RAZA I
FOR TADO I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ NO MONNING I AM MORE
LOCK OKAY. MORALE PAN HI LAW HI
THERE'S A NICE IS GATOR AYE
STERN BY MY COUNT HI. FIVE
THIRTEEN KNOWS FIVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT STAFF
RECOMMENDATION KERRY'S
COLLEAGUES ISSUE FOR HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS TRAILER BILL
PROPOSALS WE WILL SPLIT. BUT
THE VOTE ON THIS ITEM THE FIRST
MOTION I WILL ENTERTAIN WILL BE
TO APPROVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES FOR EIGHT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN HI
THAT WERE DEVELOPED ALL RIGHT
CABALLERO HI DOLLY HI DORADO.
FOR TITLE I AM LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MINING NINE
MORE LOCK. MORALE. TEN HI RAW
ON SKINNER AYE STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI. FINAL JEOPARDY AND.
MELENDEZ ABSTAINED TO I.
MELENDEZ HI. FIVE SIXTEEN KNOWS
ZERO. FIVE SIXTEEN NO ZERO THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION KERRY'S
THE SECOND MOTION I WILL
ENTERTAIN IS TO ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOCATE THESE
FUNDS. MOVED WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JOHN.
SENATORS MITCHELL FIVE NIELSEN
HI. WELL ALL RIGHT CABALLERO HI
DOLLY. THE RAZA HI FOR TITLE I
AM LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MONNING NINE MORE
LOCKED. MORALE PAN HI RALPH HI
SKINNER. STERN BY MY COUNT SKI
HI. PRICE FOURTEEN NO ZERO.
FIVE FOURTEEN Nó ZERO. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION PASS THIS.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER ON ISSUE ONE
BUDGET FRAMEWORK. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI. FIVE THIRTEEN NO
ZERO FIVE THIRTEEN OH ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ISSUE TO PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACK. CENTER
MCGUIRE HI. FIVE EIGHTEEN NO
ZERO SIZE EIGHTEEN NO ZERO. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION KERRY.
SHOULD. THE BOTTOM THREE DIDN'T
NOT FAMILY ISSUE TO. ISSUE
THREE. CONTROLS SECTION. ELEVEN
NINETY CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER
CENTER MCGUIRE HI. FIVE
EIGHTEEN KNOWS THERE ARE SELF
REGULATION KERRY'S ISSUES THREE
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HE
DID ALL THOSE OTHER GREAT SO
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE AND THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED YOU VOTED ON
ALREADY WE JUST DID WAS JUST
THE FIRST ONE. BECAUSE WE SPLIT
THE VOTE. GOT IT. THE. THIRTY
DOLLARS. TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK YOU FOR A
INTELLIGENCE WITH ALL THE
CHANGES IN THE NUMBERS TODAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. I
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL- CENTER
DAHLE AND LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE THE
CORPORATION- WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. I'D LIKE TO A THANK
OUR IT STAFF ARE SERGEANTS ARE
DEAF YEAH SENATE. STAFF ALL WHO
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO MAKE TODAY
POSSIBLE WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED-
FINANCE LA- THEIR TEAMS AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
HAVE. WATCHED TODAY'S HEARING
FROM ONE O'CLOCK UNTIL NOW WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROCESS WE ARE CLEAR THAT THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
PANDEMIC IS CATAPULTED
CALIFORNIA INTO A RECESSION AND
THE SENATE TODAY HAS TAKEN ITS
FIRST STEPS TOWARDS STABILIZING
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU ALL.